um it would um take effect 45 days after
the um um after the bill was is passed
and the uh uh committee that is named
would have until November to um produce
a report from what you learn what what
the committee learns um um during its
its lifetime so I am here
um as as the members of this committee
are aware New Hampshire's lack of
affordable housing is a is a significant
problem in the state it's even more
challenging for people with disabilities
and this is why Advocates from the
disability Community asked me to submit
this bill one issue that makes it
difficult for people with disabilities
to find housing is that people who rely
on social security or SSI have very low
income comes there's no way they can
afford market rate housing another
consideration is the appropriateness of
the housing for example people with
mobility issues need ground floor
apartments or access to elevators other
people need Supportive Housing that
include services to help them live
independently My Hope Is that this
proposed committee can identify the
scope of the shortage of housing for
people with disabilities and identify
ways to provide incentives to developers
to build appropriate and affordable
units and ensure that these developments
are distributed around the state so
people can remain in their communities
and be close to family and friends um I
am going to be very brief there are a
lot of people with a much deeper
understanding of these um issues and
challenges who are are also here to
speak um but I am happy to answer any
questions thank you representative any
questions representative
Reed thank you for taking my question
representative um and thank you for
bringing forward this bill uh the last I
checked and this was quite some time ago
what we formally called Section 8 uh
Voucher Program um was something like a
nine-year weight list in this state and
uh do you happen to know how long the
weight list currently is and how long
specifically it is for people with
disabilities who need special
accommodations uh no I cannot answer
that question um I do know that um um
there are significantly long weights um
my
my suspicion is that there's probably
someone sitting behind me who has that
information for you and that's another
reason why um we need to have a special
committee to to look at this so that you
can gather all of that information and
find out what the scope of need is so
thank you for that question yes uh a
follow-up question um this is a would
you believe Mr chair uh would you
believe that I have a constituent that
lives in my own complex that I found out
during Bill filing last last year um she
lives on a third floor or lived I should
say on a third floor walk up um she lost
the use of her legs Midway through or
even just a little bit into her lease
and the landlord refused to let her out
of her lease even though that meant that
she would be completely bound to her
apartment and unable to leave um and
that I then filed legislation to try to
address that issue um but if it had come
to this committee perhaps it would have
ended differently but it did not end
well would you believe yes I would
believe it and and um I think anybody in
this room could wake up tomorrow and
find themselves with a disability if and
you know that that's just the nature of
it so some folks are are born with um
with challenges and other people develop
them during the course of their life I'm
just waiting for mine to kick in thank
you representative any other questions
represent VI Kell thank you thank you
for taking the question
um this this this uh committee that
you're proposing seems to have a lot of
overlap with this this specific
committee and we did um uh specifically
that on line 12 it says um and potential
remedies for
increasing the supply of housing that is
both affordable and suitable I think
that that isn't that within the scope
of this committee that we are trying to
address some
those um problems and so I'm just
wondering what what is different in your
mind from what this committee could have
a hearing to to listen to those same
people I I'm not sure of the benefit of
creating a whole another committee for
that purpose um thank you for the
question um I was approached um by
people in the disability Community to um
submit this bill um I spoke with some
members of the committee uh about
whether um they had had you had had
significant testimony regarding these
issues and I was told that at that at
that point there hadn't been my goal for
for submitting this bill is for this
issue to be addressed um as I've been
told I'm a rookie um uh legislator and
as I've been told once I submit a bill
to a committee it then becomes yours um
so my goal for this is to have um
somebody look at um the scope of the
issue that's facing people with
disabilities when it comes to housing
and to um and to figure out some
potential ways uh to address those
issues so that we can create more
affordable and appropriate housing for
people with disabilities so thank you
for that question go ahead thank you
thank you for uh taking this followup so
so what what would you see as success as
as far as this committee
uh like the report what what do you what
would you envision as a su a successful
committee um well report if if I were to
be on this committee what I would be
looking at would be you know to define
the scope of the problem how many people
are there with disabilities who need
housing um to um look at determine you
know um
the the the scope of the issues with um
with people who hold vouchers or who
people who need vouchers um you know H
how many more units do we need for um
that where the landlords will take
vouchers
um and and also to kind of look at um
different kinds of solutions for example
some of it may be new construction some
of it may be retrofitting um you know if
an older person um is living in their
home and they develop significant
Mobility problems they may not if
they're on Social Security they may not
have the resources to retrofit their
home in order to accommodate this new
disability looking at at the at the wide
range of ways that um housing can be
made appropriate for um for people with
disabilities and also looking at what
the disabilities are you know you have
people with physical disabilties you
have people with um developmental
disabilities you have um people with um
uh who suffer from mental illness um and
substance abuse disorders they need some
kind you know they also need um
Supportive Housing so and and also to
look at the um restraints against um
building this kind of housing um um you
know for example um I I was listening um
to the uh uh to to a a phone call and it
was a developer who had been working on
building Supportive Housing for adults
with developmental disabilities and um
they were having a a hard time making
the the project work financially because
of the number of they needed to put in I
think it was 12 units and um the the
parking
requirements um made it virtually
impossible for them to put it on the lot
that they had available to them and um
most of the people that would be living
in this housing did not drive for you
know either their disabilities prevented
them for driving or they couldn't afford
to own and maintain a car um so they you
know they didn't need all that parking
but the um but the zoning requirements
um uh were forcing them to put in that
much um parking so they had to go and
get variances so I mean those are the
cuz you know people who have
disabilities should be able to stay in
their communities in Manchester we're
building a whole bunch of um units for
um people with very low incomes um and
there these these units are going to be
appropriate for people with disabilities
um but you know everybody C with
disabilities shouldn't have to move to
Manchester to get housing I mean you
know if you're living in a small rural
community where you've lived your whole
life and suddenly you find yourself in a
wheelchair you shouldn't have to move to
Manchester
so so I I think finding ways to
um encourage communities uh to uh
provide this type of housing for their
for their residents is is another thing
that the the committee could be looking
at okay any other questions
representative
Gibbs thank you uh the Section 8 waiting
list was mentioned um and uh I know that
those are always very long um are you
familiar with Section 811
housing I'm not sure is that is that the
bridge housing or uh no it's
specifically it's a HUD program that
provides funding for housing
specifically for people with
disabilities so I think that uh I should
mention I'm a former HUD employee uh so
I have some familiarity um that's
probably something that should be
considered uh when looking at
availability for housing for people with
disabilities and um perhaps local
organizations applying for uh
participation in the section 8 program
uh sorry section 811 program uh and uh
getting that kind of assistance to
create that kind of Housing and uh
there's a new version also that provides
rental assistant um I'm not as familiar
with that but it does exist oh thank you
so much for providing that information
that and that's exactly the kind of
information that I would like this this
proposed committee to be exploring you
know what are the what are the assets
what are the resources that are
available and you know find out what the
needs are find out what the resources
are and figure out ways to match
them any other
questions would the prime sponsor be
okay if the special committee scheduled
spe time specifically for this purpose
once we've disposed of our
bills um personally yes I I think I
would I would be I would be satisfied to
have this committee um spend time
looking specifically at this issue I
mean that's why I brought the bill
forward because I thought it needed
special
attention um I don't know if everybody
behind me agrees but um yeah I I would
be willing to to to to accept that okay
thank you representative thank
you um so we have about 15 people here
to testify on this bill and everybody is
in support so if you have written
testimony andd like to submit it to the
committee that'd be great um but I'm
next I'm going to call on representative
HR I will speak closer to the mic does
that
work
representative HR can you just speak
close to the mic oh yeah can everyone
hear this I'm GNA speak louder thank you
hi I'm representative Heidi HR
Manchester Ward 10 and a co-sponsor of
the bill our 36-year-old son has a
disability we are a squeaky wheel our
son has been living in his own apartment
since 2012 with a furry four-legged
roommate our son is a lucky one there
are many individuals with disabilities
who are not able to live on their own
due to availability of affordable
housing this committee would be their
squeaky wheel by working with the state
agencies Advocates and members of the
disability committee to find a solution
I feel it is important we move this
legislation right along to help our
disability Community find avoidable
housing we need to be their squeaky
Wheels thank you thank you are there
questions for representative
HR representative D Lorenzo hi thank you
for taking my question um what would you
envision as appropriate for a person in
your son's
um or someone like your son's present
condition would you think about
congregate housing um at
all I think it's up to the individ
idual um and people working with that
individual where my son has Aspergers
and he's high functioning he does have a
job he doesn't
drive but he lives on his own and that's
what he wants that's that's why we let
him be thank you thank you
representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
believe the prime sponsor mentioned this
but I'll ask the question of you
um is it fair to say that this is a bit
of a double whammy situation where not
only do you need to deal with housing
for people with disabilities but very
frequently many of those people with
disabilities are living on limited
incomes usually Social Security
disability income which further makes it
difficult for them to find housing
especially in our current
market thank you for the question um not
sure how to answer it but there
are project vouchers out there that
would help with lowincome
disabilities
people
um I guess that's it yeah
yeah okay any other questions thank you
representative next up I'm going to call
on representative
Howard
thank you Mr chair my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington and
I'm a co-sponsor on the bill uh I
support this legislation because while
the issue of housing is a very important
one here in the state there's extra
hypers specificity when we're looking at
people who with disabilities looking for
housing and we need to make sure that we
are able to supply that housing for uh
everyone as we've heard already we
already have people who are living on
limited income and it is not always easy
to find a home even for people with
higher income uh who are
able-bodied uh and are trying to find
competitive uh rates for apartments uh
or other housing I think that this uh
study committee would be a good way
forward to look at how we can ensure
that the people of our state no matter
their ability level can guarantee that
they can find housing uh and with that
that's everything that I have I'm open
to any questions thank you thank you
representative representative yulla
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um I hear you and the previous speaker
talking about a affordability um however
I think that is cross the Spectrum not
just people with disabilities so I guess
from your
perspective
um
in the in the scope of what this
committee has heard before about you
know if and and we're well aware of the
the affordability issues what do you
think that
this this committee or or our committee
the special committee on housing um
could gather as far as the special need
of let's
say ramps or whatever uh you know uh
accessibility options in the housing
that are not being you know addressed I
guess by the overall trying to increase
the housing Supply and and decrease the
cost in general what what do you see as
as the specific purpose or success of
this uh focus of the legislation yeah uh
so thank you for the question uh I think
that in ter terms of how this committee
has uh been set up I mean we have all of
the bills that you guys have been
assigned to uh being heard today and
potentially being exec today and I mean
when I was leaving this morning uh I I
was having to deal with uh quite a bit
of snow on my road and uh I understand
that that can be potentially problematic
for people with disabilities uh
especially if they were trying to come
to speak on this bill uh and I think
that if we set up a special committee
that
can uh or a study committee that can
actually spend additional time going to
other communities in actually listening
to people with disabilities who may
struggle to come to conquer uh I think
that that would be very valuable uh to
the types of legislation that we'd be
actually providing uh I mean again
that's an option for you know this
committee as well uh but I think that in
terms of allowing uh for more
opportunities for people to come and
actually speak on some of this
legislation and share their stories uh
so that we can actually come to a better
conclusion that would be the best way
forward representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is it fair to
say that first of all and this is
hearkening back to a previous question
that wasn't fully answered um by the
last person
um that the reason the affordability is
specifically important in this matter is
because the the disabled Community is
disproportionately affected by it and
secondly the need for specialization on
a study committee is important because
not all accommodations are as simple as
a ramp there are many different types of
accommodations that can't even be
retrofitted to a unit for example if you
need a unit to be spacious enough to
accommodate a large wheelchair units
just aren't built that way and because
we don't have that spe uh specificity or
specialization in that Committee in this
committee to understand those
differences and those nuances that might
be a reason to um both of those might be
a reason to need a a study commission or
committee yeah uh exactly I mean we have
people who are living on uh Social
Security Disability uh who are limited
to a few thousand a month uh and that's
not necessarily enough to be able to uh
pay for rent pay for food pay for uh you
know uh any other bills that may end up
coming up and we need to make sure that
we can be able to uh have options
available for people when not
necessarily all of the housing stock
that we are going to be looking to add
may actually be uh available for these
people with disabilities because as you
said they may not necessarily be able to
be retroactively fitted with uh the
necessary accessibility components uh in
order to make the home
livable okay thank you representative
all right thank you so much all right
next up is Kristen
Evans and I'll just remind everybody
that if you have written testimony
please send it to us and we will read it
but if you have something else say other
than what's written down that would be
more helpful thank
you thank you for the opportunity to
testify in support of
hb1 168 for the record my name is
Kristen Evans and I am the director of
policy and advocacy for AEL New
Hampshire AEL is a disability Justice
organization and we are a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that fights for
the civil and human rights of children
and adults with disabilities I would
like to express our strong support for
House Bill 1168 as a disability Justice
organization deeply committed to
addressing the systematic barriers faced
by individuals with disabilities would
believe this bill is a crucial step
towards creating Equitable housing
opportunities for all our organization
along with our dedicated housing task
force comprised of family members
Advocates and individuals with
disability has been tirelessly working
to identify and address the many
challenges faced by our community in
accessing safe affordable and accessible
housing the findings of our task force
coupled with extensive research
highlight the urgent need for
comprehensive action to address the
housing crisis affecting people with
disabilities in New
Hampshire I'll skip over some by
establishing a committee to study the
impact of the housing crisis on people
with disabilities House Bill 1168
demonstrates a commitment to
understanding the complex factors
contributing to housing inequities and
developing evidence-based solutions to
address them through data collection
state stakeholder engagement and
comprehensive analysis this committee
will lay groundwork for informed policy
recommendations aimed at expanding
affordable and accessible housing
opportunities for individuals with
disabilities across the state state in
conclusion we urge the committee to
swiftly Advance House Bill 1168 and
allocate the necessary resources to
support its implementation by
prioritizing the housing needs of people
with disabilities we can move closer to
realizing our shared vision of a more
just and inclusive Society where
everyone has the opportunity to thrive
thank you representative Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question and thank you for being here in
the important work that you do actually
have two questions um you referenced
Abel having a housing task force that's
already done some data collection is
there a report from that work or where
might that data be available to us we uh
it's been uh mainly family members of
people with disabilities who have really
the theme has been that adult PE adult
with disabilities have to be have been
living with their parents because they
have no other place that's um
appropriate for them but I can get you
some data from the task force I it would
be helpful to share with us whatever you
have already collected to inform us
absolutely
so well I'll ask the second question
maybe sort of already answered it I'm
wondering about what we know about the
availability of com criet housing for
developmentally disabled people I
actually used to work consult in that
population some quite a few years ago
now um and at the time I know there was
a wait list at all of the community
homes that I would visit does that
remain the
case I don't believe there is congregate
housing anymore ah
right there's no group homes that's what
I meant so they've gone away entirely
yes when when we closed the sonuna
center the no the um the institution
they also got gr went away with group
homes so that's the problem where people
have who want to live on their own but
also need support and also people who
need um to live with other people if
that's what they choose to also need
support that's what we're looking for
thank you for your help
welome representative D Lorenzo uh thank
you for take my question um good one
would you believe that I managed group
homes um um in Boston and that the
congregate housing was really really
successful at worked we've seen that
it's been successful in other states um
part of our housing task force we've
looked at other states and see that it's
been
successful thank
you representative Gibbs and
representative
yell thank you Mr
chairman the uh I believe that the
section 811 housing that I mentioned
earlier
can be congregate housing I don't know
whether there is any in New Hampshire um
but that is definitely something to
consider
absolutely represent M Kell thank you
thank you for taking the question um I'm
wondering uh I guess it's two parts if
you have been following this this uh
like last year this committee heard from
a lot of people um regarding in the
housing issues in the state and I'm
wondering if you um followed that and if
they they there was anyone that
you thought should be coming and and and
addressing the committee about the needs
um of the state that we didn't hear from
and so therefore you believe that this
this either this committee is unwilling
or un unable to be able to um tackle the
issue that that this one this bill could
have or any recommendations as far as um
people that this committee could invite
to speak as far as addressing this topic
I think there are a lot of people behind
me who are experts and would love to
testify on this
bill okay thank you very much thank you
for your time all right next up is
Blaze welcome thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you members of the committee
for being here and listening to us
testify today my name is Vanessa blae
and I am the director of policy and
planning for the New Hampshire Council
on developmental
disabilities I am providing testimony on
behalf of the DD council members who
believe that this bill would have a
positive impact on the disability
community at the heart of the ongoing
housing crisis there exists an untold
story about the unique challenges faced
by people with developmental
disabilities and their unmet need for
safe stable and affordable housing in
their
communities having a stable home is the
foundation of everything that we build
our lives on lack of housing inevitably
escalates challenges that could other
wise be met through natural supports to
crisis situations that unravel
everything else in our lives the housing
crisis is a daily topic that is
adversely affecting our entire State and
is now putting our social and economic
stability in Jeopardy as we explore
Solutions the intellectual and
developmentally disabled are again left
out of the
conversation it is our hope that by
establishing a committee to study the
effects of the housing crisis on people
with disabilities we can address this
need in an effective way that puts our
state's most vulnerable people at the
Forefront of developing
Solutions while weighing this decision
to bring this legis legislation to vote
legislators and the public will hear a
lot about data and
statistics while these numbers are
important we hope that our legislators
take into consideration the stories that
people want to share about how the lack
of suitable housing has been a barrier
to living a safe healthy inclusive life
of
meaning something that we all deserve
and something that disabled people
should not have to wait longer
for while these numbers are important
I'd like to also remind you that people
are not looking for this committee to
come up with a silver bullet
solution what they're look looking for
is to be able to inform the
legislators on the needs of people with
disabilities and the barriers that they
are facing to housing in a historic
housing
crisis according to UNH Institute on
disability 12.1% of New Hampshire
residents are currently living with a
disability that means one in eight
Granite
Staters it is more essential than ever
to continue to support inclusion and
enhance the lives of the disability
Community I am willing to take any
questions thank you thank you very much
any questions represent
Damon thank you thanks for taking my
question could you just tell us a little
capsule about New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities I'm not
familiar with it is it a state agency or
nonprofit or thank you for your question
the DD Council
are in every state and territory we are
a ferally funded state agency we're
mandated out of the Developmental
Disabilities Act and our charge is to
basically identify barriers to people
living with developmental disabilities
and helping to live inclusive lives in
the community and help the community
also able to understand how they can
support people with
disabilities
yep thank you that's very helpful does
your agency collect data or have some
information you could share with us
about where there is housing in
communities throughout New Hampshire for
this population and you know more
concretely what the need is so the
nhcd is part of a um triumverate that we
are all part of the Developmental
Disabilities Act so our charge is for
advocacy and capacity building the UNH
Institute on disability is our sister
agency and they do the research and
collect most of the data I I am happy to
provide data for you um in the future I
would like to say that that is one of
the reasons why we want to have a
special committee so that these agents
will be able to come and give that data
for you thank you very
[Music]
much all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you I have a gentle
reminder that people are saying they
still can't hear testifiers so if you
could please speak into the mic that
would be helpful next up is Heather
stackwell
oops good morning can everybody hear me
all right I'm generally pretty loud
without a microphone so um good morning
my name is Heather Stockwell and I'm
here to in support of HB
um an act establishing a committee to
study the impact of the housing crisis
on people with disabil ities and I'm I
work for rights and democracy as a
healthc care campaign organizer
um so I talk a lot about Healthcare
usually but I really see the
intersection of how this also impacts
our housing um
because people living on limited incomes
um are going to be struggling more and
more as we see prices
increase as we know New Hampshire has
had a housing shortage for some time now
and people would living with
disabilities already had long wait times
for apartments and as we've discussed
the Section 8 voucher
system
um it's it's very difficult for people
to find appropriate housing that is
actually affordable for their budgets
and there are also I believe no
resources to help people find these
types of
Apartments um and from 20 to2 to 2022
New Hampshire grew by almost 20,000
people
the census report uh states that we
increased our population by
17,700 people during those two
years um and that has reduced the number
of available units overall in the market
and during that time we also saw prices
soar not only for
housing but we've also seen record
inflation numbers on just regular
household items including groceries
the number of seniors in New Hampshire
also continues to increase it's
currently reported at about 20% of our
population is considered a senior
citizen seniors is a popular are a
population that are more likely to
develop disabilities as they age and I'm
speaking from experience today because
I'm not a senior citizen yet but I am a
person that is experiencing Dynamic
disabilities
and what that term means is that you
can't see my disabilities
probably but if you talk to me about it
or you caught me on a day that I'm tired
and limping you might
notice my Mobility isn't what it used to
be and I live in a very old home that I
already have struggled to afford and I I
honestly don't personally see myself
having the money to convert that home so
that it is accessible for me so I'm
therefore looking around at what's
available and it's very slim expensive
and it's not appropriate for my needs as
I as I age and I know I'm not alone here
which is why I'm speaking up I'm not
even 60 yet but I see that I am going to
need a better place to live I'm also
live in a rural
community in accessing some of the
services I might need as I age will also
become more of a struggle because I'll
have to drive maybe 20 30 minutes maybe
a full hour or more to find the things
that that I'm going to
need with that said many people living
with disabilities may also be living on
a fixed income as we've talked about
today and from my experience uh my
husband is disabled also
it's a little more visible for him but I
also understand if we were both on
disability we would not be able to
afford even where we live
currently and and frankly that's quite
affordable compared to today's
standards I also talked to a lot of
people that have these vouchers that
cannot find a place that is appropriate
for them in the amount of time that they
need they are told over and over again
that aart ments do not take vouchers or
they have already rented all of the the
apartments that they can
um uh that they can use for vouchers so
even with those social security updates
those amounts are
calculated on really out ofd cost of
living um scales and those vouchers
reflect
that and I'm not saying that that's your
problem necessarily to figure out but I
urge this committee to take this on
because when we build and uh appropriate
places for disabled people we're
building appropriate places for everyone
and that's that's a goal I think that
I'd like to see in our state if we want
people to stay living here thanks so
much for your time happy to take
questions if anyone has any thank you
miss stackwell any questions represent
yell thank you
um is there any um agencies or uh groups
that that you're aware of that this
committee has not already heard that you
think that the this new committee or or
a listening session from from in this
committee that they should hear from on
this topic I think you're hearing from a
lot of them today I I'll add that I'm
also a participant in the class of 2024
uh the leadership series with uh the
institute on disability at UNH uh there
are several of us I think here today um
so that's one AEL New Hampshire has
spoke today
um there are there are several different
um organizations that do work around
this well I thank you I guess my
question is if the people are already
here why do you need another committee
to have them those same people come back
again I'm not sure I understand your
question I think we're here today
because a the committee doesn't exist at
this
time there this housing committee but a
committee to study the impact on
disability housing does not exist at
this point not within the state house
okay thank you representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair thank for taking my
question so you know you talked about
elderly the elderly in their needs as
far as housing is concerned do you see
an intersection between the elderly
folks and then the disabled folks for
sure that's that is why I brought it up
in my testimony today um because I've um
I finally I guess realized even though I
have worked with disabled folks uh many
times in my life uh that I'm coming to a
new understanding that everybody as they
age it is possible to develop a
disability as you age
so we're talking about all of ourselves
maybe not right now but down the road so
there is an intersection there um I
think both those populations also uh are
on fixed or low incomes uh so need a
little extra
help thank
you any other questions thank you very
much for your testimony thanks so much
all right next up is Tracy
long and I miss miscalculated how long
this hearing would take so if you have
written testimony and you'd like to give
it to the committee we would definitely
read it but um we would appreciate
brevity in your remarks if you could
thank
you
I am in support of HB 1168 do you mind
just introducing yourself again yes good
morning chairman and members of the
housing committee sorry this is my first
time a little nervous no problem thank
you for your time and service my name is
Tracy long I live in Alton I
wholeheartedly support HB 1168 and I'm
going to go off talk but real quick
because I keep hearing a similar
question from
representative thank you um there's a
glare
um and I'm probably not answering it
correctly but the reason why in my
opinion I'm a mother of a child with
special needs and when you hear the word
disability it really is a huge word it
means so many things whether it's
physical you're born with it you're
acquired this it's too big for I'm
assuming you have lots of topics you
deal with to me disabilities in itself
is so big it needs something unique and
special cuz it's
complicated um so I'm here to speak on
behalf of thousands of parents across
the state who feel exactly like me who
are fearful just like me not long after
my son Andrew was born it was clear he
had disabilities and due to these
disabilities Andrew is reli Reliant upon
his parents and support to keep him sa
safe make sure he is healthy and that he
has a roof over his head Andrew is 30
years old
now he has lived with his parents all
his life not because he wants to he
wishes to be like every other
30-year-old and have a home not with his
parents it's through new fault of his
own that he cannot he works he
entertains he volunteers and is a
well-rounded voting civic-minded
individual since Andrew was born my goal
my drive has been to help him become the
best Andrew he can be set the bar High
work hard and more the more he learns
and becomes the more independent and
safe he would be or so I thought as he
ages so do his father and I I was 27
years old when I had Andrew and that's
when my mission
began um that's three years younger than
he is
today um I'm about to turn 50 9 his
father is 61 soon to retire he's a
teacher in the
state um it became clear as Andrew got
older no matter how hard he works or we
work he will never be able to live on
his own without
support um I will focus on him as an
individual and not go into the details
of the impact on the parents lives our
lives have become an extension of our
adult CH child children with special
needs and we are dutiful no matter how
old we get or how difficult it is that's
another testimony in itself New
Hampshire severely lacks safe inclusive
and appropriate places for those with
developmental disabilities to live out
their lives with dignity and with
support what will happen to Andrew who's
behind me when we his parents can no
longer do for
himself sorry we can can no longer
provide what we always could um what
will happen when we
die um I implore that you assemble a
special committee because this is way
too
big um and that committee I am quite
sure will see all the red flags and will
understand the urgency that exists um
it's Pas time to ask every day there are
children born with
disabilities this isn't going
away time for New Hampshire to blaze a
trail and be proactive to solve this
horrible
problem will you support HB 1168 and be
the Trail Blazer bringing New Hampshire
out of theing housing crisis for those
with
disabilities so if you have any
questions thank you Miss Long any
questions thank you for your testimony
sure
next we'll have Lisa
Bodwin good
morning my name is Lisa Bodwin for the
record I'm the principal of strategies
for disability equity and I ask you to
support HB 1168 a bill to study the
impact of the crisis on people the
housing crisis on people with
disabilities you'll hear countless
stories I'm going to I'm going to edit
my testimony
here in my capacity as a Disability
Policy professional I co-authored a
disability housing report in
2021 based on an informal survey of over
400 families across the state of New
Hampshire and individuals living with
disabilities it revealed that the severe
crisis in Workforce and affordable
housing has a disproportionate negative
impact to individuals with disabilities
and that's why we're here and in
particular individuals as uh identified
as having an intellectual or
developmental
disability among the many issues
contributing to this problem currently
most adults with the label of
intellectual or developmental disability
live with their parents or other closed
family
members parents are not obligated to
provide housing or any care to their
adult children there are currently over
4,500 individuals in the state of New
Hampshire this means that there is a
small tidal wave of housing needs on the
doorstep of the New Hampshire
legislature we do not have institutions
for people with disabilities and the
center for Medicaid Medicare
Services um prohibits the building of
congregate housing if you want Medicaid
funding New Hampshire's Department of
Health and Human Services is disallowed
from letting Medicaid waiver funding be
used on
housing there is a serious structural
flaw in the current system that's
ignoring the lifespan threat of housing
instability and homelessness for
individuals living with intellectual and
developmental
disabilities the system we currently
have in place is functionally not
sustainable and it is incumbent on the
New Hampshire
legislature to understand the
constellation of factors that are
contributing to this overwhelming
problem parents carry the vast amount of
responsibility but it's in fact not
their job the disability housing study
committee can examine the statutory
regulatory funding and Workforce
components then establish a priority
list of actions that the New Hampshire
legislature can take to play its role
because it can't be fixed by any one
entity in creating inclusive appropriate
accessible affordable housing people
with disabilities as others have said
want to be contributing taxpaying
citizens um this housing study committee
for the for the disability Community
will help to create a road map for the
homes they need to take their place I
will um I can be a resource for you on
on data and um how the current systems
of supports and
services can and cannot uh help with
housing and how the different silos
either engage or or or not work together
uh on this
problem thank you very much for your
testimony are there any
questions Mr sherff representative
Lorenzo thank you thank you for taking
my question question um Miss bodone um
the 4500 individuals that were counted
in that that study or survey that you
did would you have um would you be able
to give us a copy of that survey yes I'd
be happy to provide a copy it's four
over 4,500 individuals are currently on
the developmental disability waiver the
survey had a an end of I think just over
400 thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony
next I will call on Will
Walker we'll go ahead and pass him
around thank
you
dear chairman Alexander and members of
the house uh special committee on
housing thank you for the opportunity to
speak today I'm here to ask you for
support for HB
1168 in my written testimony I apologize
I have transposed the last two digits of
the bill number I live in Hollis with my
wife and 24-year-old son with autism I
was here uh prepared to get testimony on
my personal story I'm going to give a
different story after hearing the
testimony today so far okay in
1990 I started a project to develop
software for people with hearing Visual
and physical
impairments at that time everybody
thought well you know what do those
people do right they can't be employed
um and what does what does it mean to be
blind I can just close my eyes I can
plug my ears I can pretend I can't move
my hands or my arms and um I had to go
through working with people with dis
disabilities themselves to understand
the space better I had to develop a
story for why we could employ people
with develop sorry with um disabilities
and I was able to convince people with
the pur strings that it was a worthwhile
project to take on okay so where am I
right now with that we um we developed
an architecture that's in place today
and it allows people with physical
hearing and visual impairments sorry
physical hearing and uh yeah visual
impairments to become employed be
gainfully employed have equal access to
software after hearing the testimony
today I would argue where we are with
housing for people disabilities is where
I was back in 1990 I listened to the
housing committee testimony from last
June I heard somebody say or ask a
question what would we do about
accessibility and I think the response
was the Ada will just take care of that
okay so we'll think well just put a ramp
in okay and I hear testimony today it's
very similar and it's not that it's
insulting it's just because you don't
understand the problem and the
subcommittee will help you understand
that problem and with the subcommittee I
would say you need to talk to the
developmental Services quality Council
to find an RSA 171a 33 you need to talk
to the institute on disabilities you
need to talk to um the governor's
Commission on disabilities the New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities the Brain Injury
Association um and so on okay so you
need to talk with the subject matter
experts you also need to learn from the
failures of the lonia state school and
why congregate settings aren't always a
great solution why they can be an
absolute disaster okay so my thing here
is I Chang my testimony from a personal
testimony to say why is this
subcommittee necessary NE why it is
important why do we want to make a very
special Focus thing to learn about this
problem and because of that I ask you to
support House Bill 11
68 thank you very much Mr Walker any
questions representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman um my
question is isn't the problem with
congregate housing uh basically when
people with disabilities are denied a
choice that is they don't have a choice
about whether to go into congregate
housing or another type of perhaps more
independent living type of housing uh
rather than uh the problem being the
existence of congregate housing well
it's a very long conversation to have
about uh issues with congregate housing
uh there's a very very good video on
YouTube that talks about the L lonia
state school and how it started off with
possibly great intentions and ended up
with a disaster in inhumane
environment all
uh thank you uh but isn't congregate
housing uh such as it may exist today
quite different from the lonia state
school yeah I I I'm not an expert so I
got the speaker in front of me I'm not
an expert uh in in the laws but I
believe there are laws in place that
will prevent the overall size of of
congrega housing uh yes I I am familiar
with that um so that it's not not uh
there are laws in place that prevent the
development of
Institutions uh but rather that provide
uh essentially
choice so was that a question um sorry
it was a comment okay all right thank
you any other questions thank you very
much for your testimony thank you very
much next I call on Maria
cousins
welcome thank
you okay the lights red so I don't think
the microphone went off yes um hi my
name is Maria cousins I live in stratum
New Hampshire and I'm I am in support of
House Bill
1168 um I live with my husband and my
adult daughter Samantha Samantha is 31
years old and she has Down syndrome I am
going to tell my story and Sam's story
because it is a similar story to so many
other
people
um did I say Sam has Down syndrome she
is ready to move out of her childhood
home uh and live in her own apartment
but she needs support every single day
um so that she can get out into the
community and um do the things she loves
to do the reality is that her dad and I
are not always going to be around to
take care of her drive her everywhere
and meet all of her
needs I'm here to speak for Sam and her
situation as well as others who are so
very scared and concerned about what's
going to happen happen to their children
when they can no longer take care of
them both my husband and I will be 63
this year though I would like to believe
that I'm still young I do live with two
unseen medical conditions that could
leave me
incapacitated at any time unable to
provide Sam with my time my attention or
ability to get her out in the community
so she could live her life and she
depends upon us to do
that um without our assistance she would
live a very isolated life which is
detrimental to
anybody if she were to live in supported
housing and I'm talking about supported
housing in an apartment that is a group
of Apartments together that are
supported 24 hours she would continue to
have access to the community
her job she works 13 hours a week her
volunteer
work her recreational activities and her
friends long after we can no longer take
her to these places she thrives on her
time in the community and the community
Embraces her
presence since 2019 I have been on the
board of a nonprofit working towards
creating housings housing for ID
individual
idual it has been a long hard journey to
fulfill its Mission there are so many
barriers including zoning regulations
licensing rules and raising the funds to
carry the job to completion we need to
create safe supported housing for
individuals with ID aged 18 to
64 policies need to be reviewed and
created that best meet the needs of
these individuals as soon as possible
we're talking about housing choice at
this time there is no housing choice for
individuals with
ID they need 24-hour support they need
support to get out in the community and
they need they need
Transportation please I urge you to vote
Yes to form this committee who can can
explore these options and to see what
the need is parents are aging and will
not be able to take care of their
children in indefinitely our children
desire to live independent and live
amongst their friends in their own
Apartments they want a place to call
their own just like their siblings
their their non-disabled siblings and
peers there are many families in crisis
situations right now and many more will
be as the years tick by the committee
can only be a win to help find the
solutions to long-term inclusive and
safe Housing
Solutions thank you for your service
thank you for being here and thank you
for listening to us today thank you for
your testimony Miss cousins are there
any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you next I would call
on Jan lard
prel payel okay thank
you
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today I am Jan lard pel and you did well
with my last name and I live in candy
and New Hampshire the bill that I'm
testifying in support of is House Bill
1168 Bill 1168 is a first step in
gathering current numbers of how many
individuals like my son Micah are at
risk of homelessness if something
happens to their family member caretaker
I'm here today representing a parent
group that most people would not want to
join parents who hope we live longer
than our children because we fear for
their care when when we are no longer
alive I am part of a parent group
connected to the mo Center who have been
exploring housing options here and in
other states with the goal of creating
viable options for this highly
vulnerable
population having solid numbers for the
upcoming need in New Hampshire as well
as a plan for New Hampshire to move
forward is crucial for the future of our
children my 30-year-old son Micah has
level three autism also known as severe
autism
falls under the diagnosis of
intellectual developmental disabilities
or ID in Micah's case his diagnosis
means he's non-verbal and needs
one-on-one care every waking moment I'm
blessed that my son is a gentle guy but
his impulsive actions such as bolting
away from caretakers and Pica eating in
editable objects often places him and
sometimes other people's at risk Micah's
father died when he was aged 14 and I
his only surviving parent he has
siblings who will be there for him in
the long run but my hope is that they
can fulfill the important sibling role
with Micah settled into a residence
where he can age in place before I am
too old to care for him Micah currently
lives at home and has a day program
through the moris center there are many
families like mine doing their best to
care for their adult children at home
because supporting housing options are
not available New Hampshire has a few
group homes and programs for adults with
ided including enhan enhanced family
care which is like an adult foster care
program these housing options only meet
the needs of some individuals and are
not for long-term Solutions because when
the foster parents decide to end their
caring role the adults with ID have to
move to another home change is
especially difficult for individuals
with ID even minor changes like wearing
a new shirt can be be met with meltdowns
confusion and self-injurious behaviors
long-term stable housing is a critical
need for mic his peers and for families
who just want to sustain their quality
of life in New Hampshire I'm asking that
you please support this bill and support
our efforts to provide for our children
thank you for your time and
consideration of this critical need
thank you Miss Patel any questions
representative D Lorenzo hi thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I was really interested in
hearing more about the enhanced Family
Care Program could you tell me about
that please um it is a program provided
through the state for some individuals
where um it's it's like foster care
people become foster care parents for
adults and so um Micah could potentially
move in with another family but as I
said it tends to be shortterm 3 to 5
years they decide to um end their
fostering and then the child the adult
has to move out which is not a solution
for children with extensive adults with
extensive needs like my son followup
please follow okay so um these fosta
families um do they have any
special education for the are they
trained in any way do they have do they
have a background not my area of
expertise but I would assume they are
trained they're paid um to provide the
service so they have some training um
again it's a short-term option for some
clients that that seems to work but very
few I mean there's literally hundreds of
families with their child living at home
like mine because there aren't enough
options for them thank
you right thank you very much for your
testimony next I'll call on
representative Jessica
lontine I apologize I didn't see the
pink card ahead of time but welcome to
the special
committee
hello I'm Jessica lontine representative
from do straford
17 and I'm here to speak in favor of HB
1168 and I want to tell a story um about
one woman in particular who is my
stepdaughter Eliza who has Down
syndrome
and both Eliza's parents um realized at
some point that they they would also
um Eliza would most likely survive them
when they were worried about her future
where would she be and also with their
own experience they saw what happened
with um you know other adults with
disabilities who suddenly found um when
they lost their parent one of their
parents it was a shock that trauma in
itself but for that adult with a
disability to have never never lived on
their own away from their parents and
they wanted to prepare a liers for
that so when she was at 25 years old in
2010 um Eliza started in a home care
providership
program and that's an arrangement in
which a nonprofit agency pays a
individual to provide room and board and
a limited number of
services
and that worked um the Eliza's first one
worked out really well it was a young
woman who then rented a two-bedroom
apartment for Eliza to live with her and
Eliza adapted very well to that
situation and then that woman you know
she wanted to move on with her life and
um get married and so Eliza moved back
with us the agency then it took them a
couple months they found another one
that lasted about 6 months so so this
went on for a couple years where Eliza
was moving out and then back in which
had its own um challenges emotionally
for Eliza then they found one woman who
was the home care provider and that one
lasted for six
years and the big difference was is this
was an older woman who owned her own
home she was an empty
nester and she you know she had her own
goals of double paying her mortgage and
you know that one worked out well but
that brings us to like 2019 and the
light of move back with us in the agency
then had to find another home care
provider but at this point the housing
market in Dober was kind of out of
control they could find a home care
provider who then had to rent a place
and they could not find an affordable
place to live in
Dover um so for about a year Eliza lived
with us while they're trying to find
someone and my husband thought you know
but really we should find a permanent
place for Eliza to
live um and then it's the home care
provider that moves in and
out and we did that and but we realized
how lucky they are that first we found a
place that needed a lot of work and my
husband and I are contractors so we
could do the work so we created this
situ ation where the home care provider
lived um in the house and we created a
semi independent apartment for Eliza and
then her boyfriend who also has Down
syndrome so they could live together but
it was really a lesson for us of how
much we saw the housing market impact
the agency's ability to find um suitable
housing for the home care providers to
live in um
and it also was really a lesson in you
know how much the stability of of our
being able to
secure um a permanent place as opposed
to be dependent on the housing rental
market in order for this whole
arrangement to
work
and I say one other thing
really learn to appreciate what
Supportive Housing
means and Eliz is always going to need
Supportive
Housing and in some ways because she has
such a defined disability you know she
has Down syndrome that she's El eligible
for these funds to help pay for this
housing she also has all her health care
needs taken care of and I see so many
people that have less um clear clearly
defined
disabilities that are just a little
higher functioning than Eliza and they
get no help at all but I think in our
society we need a lot more Supportive
Housing across the
spectrum of disability in the future
so that's my story yes thank you very
much representative for your testimony
representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative I
have a kind of um
philosophical uh would you believe
question and I apologize for throwing it
at you in spite of your personal um
story um but you you hit on it the topic
at the end of your testimony which is
how do we take care of each other in
society would you believe that the first
um artifact that archaeologists point to
as the first sign of human civilization
is not a particular tool or a form of
currency or anything like that but a
femur that had been broken and healed
because without human civilization
taking care of each other that person
who had the broken femur would have died
and the bone would have never healed so
that is the singular beginning according
to archaeologist beginning of human
civilization would you believe that yes
don't believe it was considered a
neanderthal not a homo sapian you may be
right okay thank you very much for that
enlightening okay would you believe
represent Kell thank you thank you for
taking the question
um you mentioned these Home Care
Partnerships
um are you aware that that that that the
group or or company or whatever is here
today or um is going to be bringing us
testimony or or could you provide the
name of that that uh the agencies yes
it's Community Partners I'm not sure if
anyone's here from Community Partners
but there are different agencies all
over the state
that um they managed a lot of different
services for people with with
intellectual disabilities and the
housing is just one of those thank you
um but I could put you in touch with
them okay if there are any questions
thank you very much representative for
your testimony thank you next I'm going
to call on Lori
Macintosh thank
you and I I hope that you we have the
written testimony if you would sumarize
it for us that' be great oh okay I was
hoping to say it all it's three minutes
say what you can yeah I can fast okay hi
thank you Mr chairman and the we are an
hour and a half behind so I'm honorable
committee members thank you um I'm in
I'm my name is Lori McIntosh I'm a
resident of Dover and I'm a parent of
two adult children with intellectual
developmental disabilities and yeah I'll
shorten this up a little bit I feel a
huge pressure to get my boys into some
place where they can survive when I'm
gone um I'm working with a bunch of
parents um on a nonprofit to build in
for adults with developmental
disabilities we have 60 families on our
waiting list there are over 100 people
on the other waiting list for the two
other places in the state that are
similar to this um people with ID need
support to be successful and we need
solutions that are cost effective for
instance when people share overnight
staff they're all paying for that
overnight staff person so some form of
and I'm not going to say congregate care
but putting people in apartments with
the apartments are near each each other
can be a very beneficial thing because
you can have some sharing of Staff um in
the five years since we began working on
our projects the rules and regulations
have toughened and tightened to make it
even tougher to build housing for
developmental dis people with
developmental
disabilities our place is planning one
kind of home that is nine units of
housing they're all independent
Apartments everybody has their own place
they have their own choice they have
their own lives they have
transportation that's coming along um
and then we're also working with a
developer from out of state who builds
40 to 50 units of affordable housing and
25% of those apartments are designated
for
ID and he's been very successful in
other states building these projects and
it's a very beautiful inclusive model
for these tenants who live with other
people um in the same
building they have 247 sta Etc so the
licensing rules in New
Hampshire when we started this project
we were required to be
certified and now we're required to be
licensed like a medical
facility so we're having to really
upgrade the way we're building the
paperwork requirements for lure cause 40
new different types of documentation so
you have to hire more staff to be
licensed
so the whole lure and certification
issue needs to be looked at carefully
because it's really a barrier for places
like us that are trying to build housing
um anyway zoning is another issue we are
in an AR looking at a property in an R20
Zone in Dover and R20 is zone for
congregate care and assisted living for
people over
65 the state recognized the need for
housing for seniors years ago and it's
part of many of their zoning
requirements
however not for the population that
we're presenting you today so if we
could make Statewide changes in zoning
that would allow you know Assisted
Living kind of care for people with not
being in institutions being separate
Apartments everyone has Choice all the
things to not make it institutional but
would be a lot more cost effective um
the licensing requires things like if
you have an Ator it has to be big enough
to hold a gurnie we don't need that if
you have toilets have to support an 800
PB person those are the lure
requirements and we don't need that in
just apartments for people with ID so
hopefully the study committee will pave
the way for the necessary changes in the
rules and regulations for this type of
housing so that it will be safe and
well-run but not ridiculously expensive
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony representative Gibbs
thank you uh and thank you for your
testimony hi over
there um The Lure requirements that you
described where do they come from are
they state or federal what agency uh
DHHS and and and yeah DHHS and they're
following some of DHHS right and
there're they're following some of the
federal rules like the federal rules say
that you can't have more than three
people per unit and that was to avoid
institutional situations and when we
started we were just paying attention to
that now they're sort of going by a no
more than three people Under One Roof
which makes a big difference because it
makes if you have you know five
apartments in a building now you have to
be
licensed I'm glad you I'm glad you said
something about that is that is that
rule making that this is happening or is
this
statue I can't if somebody if somebody
can send an email to the committee I'd
love to know specifically if these are
DHS HHS rules or if they're yeah I think
it's an interpretation of the of the
statute okay got it represent Kell yeah
thank you I I definitely kind of on that
same line would love for for either you
to come back and testify to this
committee specifically on that subject
or have you just follow up with your the
whatever you're being subject to whether
that be a specific law or RSA or um uh
DHHS the contact person or whatever so
that we can grab more information on
that subject because I think that like a
subcommittee or or um as far as that
just being kind of diving into that may
be of value to this committee so thank
you certainly thank you thank you very
much for your testimony thank you okay
we have three left that signed up um Mr
kraton
Ward I'm
sorry my apologies for that don't worry
about
it get in trouble for
that I'm not gonna do that again hi good
morning thank you Mr chairperson and
committee members today um my name is
kraton Ward and I'm a community
organizer with AEL New Hampshire and
today I'm testifying on behalf of Donna
delloo so when I use the first person
pronoun I'm talking about hers um Donna
is a resident of go toown and she's
writing in support of HB
1168 um and she wants to submit R
testimony on the way it impacts her and
her adult son with ID in intellectual
and developmental
disability when my son was 7 years old
he suffered from viral intis a brain
infection leaving him with unstoppable
seizures impaired learning difficulties
and moderate cognitive abilities as a
parent we have supported him throughout
the years in all areas medically
educationally financially and
emotionally fostering his dream to live
somewhat independently within his
hometown
Community he is now 42 years old gets an
SSDI Financial supplement also works
part-time contributing taxes to our
state and our government 12 years ago my
son married his high school sweet
sweetheart who also has disabilities
they work hard to be as independent as
possible possible and live together in
an apartment with ongoing assistance
from both sets of parents to make this
possible to the committee members I ask
you what will happen if my son if I what
will happen to my son if I get sick
myself and die and can no longer provide
the daily support he requires the answer
is he will be homeless and medically
compromised if there's no supported
housing to help him with his daily
medications drive him to appointments
fill out medical forms monitor Bank
accounts help file tax returns fill out
yearly Medicaid Medicare reports and
update Social Security requests my son
is unable to read or understand any of
this paperwork and his area agency and
vendors do not provide this assistance
can you imagine as a parent having to
plan and pay for your child's funeral
Arrangement while you're still alive my
biggest fear is that I may predecease my
son who cannot survive on his own if I
would have a heart attack get in a car
crash or get cancer tomorrow the state
of New Hampshire only offers a foster
care system called enhanced family care
which is unstable the average placement
being just 3 to 5 years can you imagine
being uprooted every few years to places
you don't know uh to be P put with
people you've never met for the rest of
your life people with ID have a right to
age in place without the fear of being
rehomed again in again the only other
option the state of New Hampshire would
provide for him is a nursing home
placement which is so appropriate for
someone only 42 years old and as we all
know there aren't even enough nursing
homes available for senior citizens that
need it I'm an active member of parent
advocacy groups that are in desperation
to find solutions to this problem and
the clock is ticking parents are working
with local and federal agencies begging
for private donations and grants and
trying to identify interested developers
in order to build supportive and
permanent housing for their aging child
places like the home possible project
farmsteads our place and Visions are
examples of parent organized projects
tackling this challenge this issue is
not unique to our state surrounding
states throughout New England have
already implemented solutions that
address the same housing dilemma so why
not New
Hampshire um I'm reaching out to you all
asking you to make this population
visible and include them in our
supported housing needs of New Hampshire
thank you and thank you Miss Ward for
your testimony on behalf of um Miss um
Donell thank you any questions set thank
you Donna's contact information is on
the back to forward any questions to her
I see it she's my neighbor thank
you okay next up I have Andrew
Long
I'll take them thank
you you can have one
too
sure can you guys all hear me okay yes
welcome great to be here hello hello
ladies hello chairman and members of the
housing committee my name is is Andrew
long and I live in Alton I'm support
Bill 1168 to form a committee to look
into housing for those with
developmental disabilities as you can
see I'm a person with developmental
disabilities and I've been worried for
quite some time what is going to happen
to me when my my parents die or they can
no longer take care of
me I know that sounds dark but that is
my reality and countless others just
like me they've taken care of me all of
my life and they deserve a chance to
know I'll be safe and happy in my own
place with support there just aren't
enough opportunities for us I'm
currently on a waiting list of
interested people for the art Place
project end over they are trying to help
solve the lack of housing power problems
for people like me
however I'm one of more than 60
people hoping to be selected to make
this my
home I may not be good at math but I
know those odds do not sound very
positive even if I was lucky enough to
get in I would feel sad for the others
that didn't we need a committee to study
the problem and come up with Solutions
please support Bill HB 1168 a little
about me I'm 30 years old I work at Old
Navy and have more for more than 6 years
I volunteer here at the coico Valley
Humane
Society I'm I'm a stand-up comic as well
I performed many times from many
different organizations a couple of
years ago at the even at the request of
Valerie sonunu for a big conference in
in Manchester I'm a person just like you
I am hoping you will understand this
need is great I'll do my part if the
committee is approved I'll do whatever I
can to help them thank you for for
listening today I'll sign up with a
little comedy since I did say that I'm a
comedian gee I thought that I was
getting fire from Old Navy today when I
was handed a pink
slip I will gladly answer any questions
anybody has for me well thank you very
much um Mr long for your testimony or
other questions representative yella
thank you thank you for taking the
question um what specifically I guess
are your desires as far as
what housing situation you would look
what would that look like to you what
would be good I I just would not like to
be alone and feel free feel like feel
separate and apart like feel separate
and together like to be able to have my
own space have my work and have my life
and yet not feel alone that if I did
need help there would be people around
to help me and that my family can
continue their life life with knowing
that I am
okay and
safe go ahead kind of followup um so do
you envision that kind of looking like a
a a single family home or something more
like an apartment complex or um just a
room in a kind of like a shared living
space where uh you know like a common
area what what types of can you get a a
little bit more specific on that I
envision like a like an area that has
Apartments like our place that has a
shared area as well so that people can
go to their apartment and then when they
want to get together with their friends
or have dinner like have a game night or
something they can go to the common area
and hang out and hang out with other
tenants sure okay so mean like the
combination of everything beautiful
thank you thank you is there any other
questions thank you very much Mr long
very valuable testimony I'm glad the
Community Loan Fund is here maybe they
can speak about the possibility of this
on another
bill okay my last the last person that
signed up is Roos Roger
Esley and of course if there's anybody
else I'd like to testify on this bill
please fill out a pink card for me I
have somebody else
okay
do you mind just turning on the
microphone for me just press the button
RS there thank you all right perfect
um I handed you my pink slip and said
will you please put me last and uh the
reason is I didn't really know what your
committee knows about this problem and I
didn't really know what people were
going to say about it so I'm going to
start by saying saying I have a
30-year-old I am one of the for
4500 I'm I think the oldest one here
that's
testified um I'm 76 and I have a
30-year-old daughter and we have the
great fear that where will she go when
she leaves our house I'm I'm trying not
to be emotional but the last speaker got
to take your
time
so I'm speaking really for ELA
Esley and if you asked her where she
wanted to live I realized I need to
speak in favor of congr G housing I
didn't know what it meant I do know when
we moved to New Hampshire for my wife
got a job teaching at the University of
New Hampshire shortly after we
arrived PE specialist started meeting
with us and asking this question why did
you move to New Hampshire this is not
the state for a family with a disabled
child I've been told that at least 30
times by people like people back here
and here's the problem when we first
arrived I would continually hear from
people sitting behind desks with ties on
and
that oh we've closed the big
institutions we had a terrible problem
with congregate housing and but we've
closed them all now so the problem
solved the thing is they closed them all
with no alternative I knew that 25 years
ago I'm sorry the state I have heard a
representative within a
year tell me how we solve that problem
and they were so proud for New Hampshire
so I'm going to tell you that there's a
Title Wave coming of expenses to the
state because if you have to take care
of my daughter the budget for my
daughter increase would increase to
about $100,000 a year if all of the
parents like me who are desperately
trying to find solutions for our child
immediately said we we're done you're
not helping there is no solution the
state would go
broke and you probably be accused of
Medicaid fraud because the area agencies
pretend they have Solutions they're
supposed to be our Advocates but they
don't have Solutions so let me give you
an example if you ask my daughter where
she wanted to be she would say I want to
be in a house where I have friends and
we can cook meals together she wants a
coate house and here's the strange thing
other states have them I grew up in
Rochester New York and my cousin says
why didn't you move to Rochester we have
hundreds of these units available now
there's waiting lists in New York state
too but things actually exist so the
waiting lists are
meaningful one of the questions that
people would ask me the special ists who
would say why did you move here is
essentially their question was why are
you so clueless about what your
daughter's going to need this state
doesn't do
it I'm so tired
of it makes me Furious the question of
why this committee is needed
why I've known this problem for 25 years
and been terrified and we can't move we
can't afford to move
and now we're stuck here and I don't see
anyone taking meaningful action at the
state level in fact the congregate the
fear of congregate housing is severely
that three h people it's crazy other
states have found solutions to this and
they exist and anyone can drive to look
at them we've done it final how how much
time do I have left as much as you need
okay
four years ago oh by the way one of the
people speaking here told me I'm 76 and
on my 75 I'm sorry on my 75th birthday
at
midnight the doctor came
in with my daughter sitting there the
doctor came in the
emergency and said we've got the good
news and bad news is the good news news
is we know what happened to you the bad
news is you've had a Transit a TIA a
mini
stroke I live on a Razor's Edge now and
my wife suffers from severe depression
so sometimes she can help and sometimes
she can't and I'm looking at a crisis
that you can't imagine it till you're in
it that's the problem you need to let
these people speak so you can help solve
the problem New Hampshire is one of the
most backward States in this area
because they they got their hand burned
on the stove of congregate housing and
said well never again here that's crazy
congregate housing is far cheaper far
more
inclusive and easier to implement than
the solution the state has with that 3 5
year nonsense
finally when we put our area agency
these are the agencies that we have to
work with with our child on the spot and
said we want you to start looking right
now for a place for our daughter live
and here's her only requirements she
wants to have friends and she wants to
be safe and do you know what they came
up with oh and in and she wants to stay
in the area she lives in because that's
where she knows people she has a job she
works at at a grocery store has for nine
years the grocery store does a better
job than in the state of New Hampshire
on being inclusive and when they called
and said we found a solution to you they
found a group home with three
people one of them was had to violent
and had to be
restrained nonverbal and the other was
severely impaired needed continual care
nonverbal that was the community they
were suggesting we send her to if you
lived with this problem you wouldn't be
asking why this is needed I'm sorry
that's thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions seeing
none thank you no much
appreciated okay my last speaker on this
bill is Marissa
Burke also my neighbor welcome
right hello everybody uh my name is
Marissa Berg I am from doown and I am
actually hadn't prepare testimony but
hearing all of the uh testimony that's
been shared today I just wanted to offer
I'm the um executive director of
Community Support Network and we are the
trade organization that represents the
10 uh area agencies for developmental
services and acquired brain injuries in
the state of New Hampshire um so there
there's been several questions that have
come up and I just wanted to offer um
resources and and information from our
perspective um there was a question uh
about enhanced Family Care um and what
that is and I just wanted to talk a
little bit about the options that are
out there in New Hampshire right now um
certainly not to say that it covers all
the bases um there's certainly a lot of
Need for different options for people um
but right now there's enhanced family
care which you've heard uh is adult
foster care um that can be up to three
individuals living in a home in a foster
care uh setting with a family could be a
couple could be a family with children
could be a single person they're they're
all different there are thousands of
situations like that out in the state of
New Hampshire right now um I don't have
actual numbers for you but I would
venture to say that a significant
portion of people who receive
residential services are in that setting
in the state um we also have the option
of which smaller in number uh staffed
residences um I keep hearing the term
congregate housing thrown around there
um we really just have uh staffed
residences here in New Hampshire uh I
heard somebody mention that there is um
some numbers uh so right now we can have
staffed residences in What's called the
certified setting for up to three
individuals uh anything for and above in
one uh individual address has to be a
licensed program and that is the same
licensing department that licenses
places like hospitals uh so there's a
different set of rules uh that govern
lure for settings or four or more
individuals um those are laws that are
in place in the state we do have
regulations that govern each of those uh
the functioning of each of those
programs everything from training
requirements to you know fire and and
security settings um you know all all
kinds of requirements for those each of
them have their own set of
regulations um we also have uh people
living in family you know you've heard
from many families who are desperate for
really the the options that their family
member needs um and it ranges everything
is individual arise just like we are as
people um everybody wants a different
thing when they get older and and it's
really based on what their family needs
are what their individual needs are they
want roommates or not do they want to
live in an in-law type setting you know
it it it runs the gamut um so what we
are supporting this bill uh
because they're needs to be the options
out there for people um for housing they
they need the options to be able to
choose what they want with their life um
people work really really hard to have
their their adult children and and give
them the options that people without
disabilities have and often times uh
housing barriers are are kind of slowing
people down so um I just wanted to offer
kind of a little bit more information as
far as what the barriers are that that
could be out there um and I think that
having somebody having a committee dive
into this uh will be really really
helpful going forward so any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
representative Gibbs thank you and thank
you for being here to speak to us uh do
you know why uh a uh facility um and I'm
going to use the term group housing but
just group in a generic term as you
might say um that has four or more
residents has to be licensed um as a
medical facility uh is that a statute
you know or a regulation and if it's a
regulation do you know what the
rationale for it is so I can't tell you
the background it is both a statute uh
and a regulation um for people who are
in
uh receiving services on the Home and
Community Based care waiver uh those
residences of four or more people have
to be both certified and licensed um so
they have to kind of meet a second
standard um which is the The Lure
criteria um so there are additional
layers of um things so things such as
having a sprinkled you know having
sprinkler systems and um just different
uh requirements over and above what's
required for
certification follow up thank you uh
follow up
um what I was asking about um uh most
importantly though um was not things
like sprinkler systems which are
required in all kinds of um multi-unit
housing uh but rather um things like uh
as was mentioned earlier a requirement
that an elevator has to be large enough
for a gurnie uh which obviously is
necessary in a hospital but it's not
necessary um for a uh some for some kind
of group housing where people are living
uh independently but with support and
want to be able to gather in a group as
also has been mentioned earlier uh why
does it need to go to that point where
you need an elevator that could take a
gurnie do you know yeah so it's not uh
the The Lure requirements is the same
Department that licenses places like
hospitals it's not the actual
same there are lure requirements
specific to residential housing um for
individuals who receive waiver services
so it's not they're they're not having
to literally like almost build a
hospital around individuals um it's just
the same Department that that oversees
this is that something we need to look
further
into yeah so that's Thank you Lisa so um
I something else that you might be
wondering about is there are also uh a
lot of changes that are happening and
coming down from CMS related to settings
requirements CMS being uh Center for
Medicaid so federally uh um and there
are restrictions on the types of
settings that individuals can reside in
um and and some of those are new and and
if there were a committee uh there might
be an opportunity to really take a look
at at the way that some of those changes
are impacting Residential Services as
well thank you well I'm I'm going to
step in real quick before I call on
representative re it seems to me that
from what I've heard is that a lot of
the issues are around the licensing the
staff resident's requirements
like the training requirement code
requirements I guess I'm wondering if I
I now see that there may be value to
studying this as an
independent thing
um if anybody could send me maybe in the
public or Marissa you as well could send
me a kind of list of regulations or
things that are kind of standing in the
way from allowing more group residences
that would be helpful as
well and representative Reed thank you
Mr chair along the chair's question is
it fair to say because we've spent some
time now just discussing the idea of the
licensing and certification of just how
many people can be in a group home
together without or with this particular
requirement and that there's a bunch of
requirements and this is just one issue
of very many issues impacting the ID
community and then the ID Community is
just one Community out of all the
disabled community and so that is the
fact that we're getting down the rabbit
hole and one tiny detail is in fact why
you and if you could speak for everybody
else in support of the bill why everyone
is here asking for a special study
committee rather than having our
committee who has not ever had a
presentation from I think any of the
organizations that have been here today
or the individuals um why why we are not
not quite equipped to deal with this
yet was that a statement or is is that
the case okay yes I would I would
absolutely agree with that and and I
want to point out that the things that
I've been just presenting specifically
requires to or applies to paid
residential services that doesn't
include all of these families that
you've just heard from today who are
also struggling because that's the
refrain that we are hearing we can never
die
we always have to be here to take care
of our adult children we have to make
sure that they're safe and th those I
mean it's it's really far-reaching and I
I would certainly agree with what you
just said or
shared represent D
Lorenzo thank you and thank you for
taking my question so would you say that
there's a Continuum of Care for these
families um an an example is that when
the youngsters are in school they're
turning 20 2 there's a a period of
transition for them and now moving on
there's another period of transition
where the individual needs to um be
independent and the parents need to you
know go their own way and the child
needs to go their own way in a perfect
world I think that's what people would
want and they would want that for their
adult children to be a choice of of
where they would want to
go
representative
Damon I'm not sure if this would come
from you or it's more of a collective
question but if we could also get in
addition to what representative Al Cher
asked for a list of all the
organizations who are stakeholders in
this most of whom have testified today I
know I personally did not know about
some of these organizations as a
resource for information so it be
helpful to have that yes a lot of this
has been educational for the committee
so thank you for everybody that has come
to testify on this um any other
questions or anybody else thank you Miss
Berg for testifying today thank you is
there anybody else that would like to
testify on HB
11168 okay seeing none I'm going to
close the public hearing on HP 11168
we're a little behind schedule so I'm
going to a lot behind schedule so I'm
going to kick off um the hearing on hp10
I overestimated how long underestimated
how long that hearing would be um so I'm
going to the public hearing on
h1065 and I'll call on the prime sponsor
representative
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
everyone uh for the record
representative hope Damon Sullivan
District 8 um nine towns with diverse
housing needs um so this is House Bill
1065 which is relative to fire sprinkler
requirements in residential
buildings um it would create an
exception to the state fire code for
sprinkler systems in existing
residential
buildings so that the sprinklers are not
required if you have four or less units
in these existing buildings the current
standard has been two units are exempt
from sprinkler
um I put this bill forward as a
placeholder basically so that if the
building code and fire code folks did
not accomplish this in their process of
reviewing and updating codes that we
could address it in statute and I
believe you will probably hear from
folks who I think are behind me um that
that actually has been accomplished I
think at this point it is just pending
legislative approval of these revisions
in the codes so to be quite Frank I'm
not really sure that we need to proceed
with the statute uh
suggestion okay thank you very much for
your testimony if it's a
question specifically for represented
amen go
ahead thank you thank you for taking the
question so is it your testimony that
you don't see a value in in having it in
statute because in current in current
statute we have it saying no more than
uh no requirements in in one and
two and
um just just because they have this in
this particular code does not
necessarily mean they could propose a
code in the future um that that did not
and so if it was in statute wouldn't
that be a better protection I guess what
um can you share your thoughts on that
yes thank you for the question it's a
good question
um I think there's always a value
judgment between what is a regulation
and what need is there for a law so my
understanding
is that the building code and the fire
code are what is utilized in communities
as to what is okay to do or not
do
um and I'm I think I'll just pause there
because I think the folks behind me will
give you a more clear answer of that
regulatory process and that will be a
decision for the committee to make about
whether we want to put it into statute
or whether it's not
necessary representative Reed thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question and I apologize I stepped out
very briefly I didn't hear everything
you said but I believe and I'm just
asking for um you to verify that
currently on the state level anything
over two units would require sprinkler
and this would make it so that it would
be anything for and Below would not
require a sprinkler system is that
correct but that as being apparently
handled administratively we hope all of
what you said is correct thank
you okay thank you very much
representative so seeing how this is a
special committee there's a lot of bills
that we're hearing today that members of
this committee are sponsors on and
typically sponsors have not asked
questions but I'm going to defer it to
these special circumstances that some of
these bills we have worked on um all of
last year and we've gotten solicitation
from stakeholders so some may ask
questions that are co-sponsors on the
bill so please allow that today um the
next up I'm going to hear from is uh
Sean Tumi State Fire marals
office
morning Mr Shar and members of the
committee thank you for having me the
record my name is Sean Tumi I serve as
our State Fire Marshal uh I've been
working with representative Damon a bit
on this uh I think since probably uh
last summer um we had heard uh probably
almost a year ago we had heard some
concerns about the sprinklers and up to
four families for existing projects and
uh I was able to handle this on a
variance basis and uh in the past
depending on the project um and that we
didn't have that same capability on the
building code so we Revisited with a
group of stakeholders this summer um and
we developed a building code Amendment
and a fire code Amendment the building
I'll let uh the chair of the building
code review Phil Sherman who's behind me
talk on the building code side a bit but
uh on the SARS of fire code side we
developed an amendment put in front of
the board of Fire Control Board of Fire
Control approved it it went to the
legislative advisory on building and
fire codes uh they recommended it to
move forward and for legislation this
year the fire code bill is Senate Bill
599 which was heard this week in the
Senate Edna it was passed uh and is on
consent uh for um it's on the consent
calendar for w this coming Wednesday the
21st so what we did on the fire code
side is that uh for units up to four
dwelling units um they would have to
meet the existing uh requirements for
residential apartment buildings in the
fire code so just to be clear it's there
is a existing chapter for apartments and
then there's a new chapter for
apartments and there are is a difference
new does require sprinklers existing
women unless there's a very weird
extenuating circumstance so I guess I I
I I mentioned oppose and I only oppose
the bill in the sense that I don't think
this bill is necessary because we have a
a uh a process in the state for building
and fire codes building code amendments
go through the building code review
board stakeholders bring them forward
the board hears them there a group of
for professionals uh those amendments
get heard through public hearing and
then uh they go up through to this the
advisory committee that I mentioned
legislative advisory committee and then
heard by the general court and approved
and ratified through the general court
on the fire code side the same process
accept it's the board of Fire Control
hears those and they come through to
your point representative ukel
the I think the Trust In not making sure
we change something in the future the
boards can't just make something up uh
without the the legislature approving it
so we can't um we can't just arbitrarily
say we're going to take this away
without you guys having visibility on
that change because you guys have the
ability we we recommend building a fire
codes they with the Committees with the
stakeholder input and everything like
that the one um only other consideration
I I suggest and know expanding it in the
statute is that we've worked really hard
over the last several years to have um
more transparency on the building and
fire code process and and um my office
was tasked with having uh building out a
website and having the this is the state
building of fire code these are the
state building and fire code amendments
and then go so far as these are the
local amendments that have been properly
vetted um lawfully eded um vetted at the
local level and then they're not in
conflict with our state building and
fire code so we're just starting to
build out that process we have I think
we have four communities that have
submitted the information it's up on our
website now but there's some bill is
going on right now to try to strengthen
that a little bit more so that we have a
very clear process for the end users in
New Hampshire that this is our state
code these are our state amendments and
oh by the way if you want to build in
the city of conquer this is where you
find the local amendments that have been
we've been verified that they're locally
they're lawfully amended so I think that
summarizes things um happy to try to
answer any questions thank you Mr Tumi
represent yell thank you thank you for
taking the question um you mentioned
local amendments um is it your
understanding
that um let's say the city of Concord
could have a local amendment that
requires sprinkler systems even though
the
state uh fire code did not require
sprinklers for for three and
four uh uh Apartments three dwelling
Apartments um could they essentially uh
have that local option because it's not
in Conflict um and and that the
legislation could serve as a purp uh its
purpose as far as barring that local
option um from being occurred or am I
misunderstanding the the the impact of
such legislation no thank you no that
there you're accurate the locals have
the ability to put a a local Amendment
that's more restrictive than the state
codes um I think the
only
um I think we got to be very careful
when we put code language in the
statutes because it doesn't look at the
bigger picture of like the we're just
narrowing focus on the sprinklers we got
to look at the whole package for the the
safety of the people living in the in
the property right so um if we look at
just the sprinkler requirements we don't
look at egress and fire other Fire
Protection Systems um we've kind of lost
uh sight of the whole code package in
the design so I think that's where from
us on the code side we're trying to
emphasize if we need to make an
amendment we really want to make it and
ratify it at the through the the state
process I understand there's a little
bit of a wild card um at the local level
I think with the the work that we're
doing through the Amendments and they're
having to come to the boards for review
um and we're staying more up to date on
our codes in general in the state we're
trying to say one code cycle behind
we're trying to get away from that sort
of wild card of people doing things that
are kind of almost Rogue from what the
state the stadium back star it's not
totally impossible though I will say
that thank you and this may be a little
outside of the scope of this bill but um
I think it's valuable information for
the committee what types of um local
additional uh restrictions I guess on on
housing or any anything regarding uh
fire are you seeing I guess um across
the State um that may be an issue for
this you know reducing or increasing the
cost of housing or whatever the case may
be that's a tough one for o General so I
mean I think the two that really come to
mind when we talk about it is um
Durham's approach on the energy code and
apply advancing the energy code beyond
what the state is and then I've heard
that of Portsmouth having a adopting a
later version of the electrical code
those are the two that typically come to
mind as the bigger concerns um um we
haven't found all of the local
amendments yet because we just have got
the position in place to do it um but
those those are the ones we typically
hear um the only other thing we hear is
that um I just heard it this morning
like that we have an existing building
code and we need to continue to educate
code officials to follow our existing
building code we have existing
Provisions in the fire code I have to
work to continue to educate fire
officials in our state that we have an
existing Pro existing building process
and if you're going to renovate a
building there it's different than if
you straight up new construction I think
that's where um from the code official
perspective I think that's where some of
the challenges come into play is that
they're not maybe applying the code as
as um as great as we could sometimes um
but I don't I can't speak to every
specific Amendment yet because we don't
we haven't captured all that
data I mean I think if you've if I if
you happen to uh come across anything
that in in the next you know year as
we're as we're committee um can you
forward that information on to us I'm
sure we would be interested absolutely
as you as you learn anything okay um
represent makoni um thank you U chairman
Alexander
um Marshall Tumi nice to see you um once
again I perhaps you could help me I'm
somewhat confused here is it my
understanding that a process is underway
right now which will allow apartment
units of three and four in existing
buildings can vacate having to have uh
sprinklers but new construction still
requires three or four that that will be
the case that is correct as we that's
the current Amendment okay if I could
follow living a little further up north
the um
and you you speak of this process for
amendments and so
forth
is is it still possible for a fire chief
up North with this understanding when
it's in place and perhaps this a Senate
Bill
599 that they would still say in my town
in a building that's existing with three
or four units uh that sprinklers is
still required they should not do that
unless they have a lawful Reas reason to
do so I will say that um we continue to
hear challenges sometimes of code
officials fire in building saying I want
this for these reasons to your point up
north I think this is this is a classic
example of why we're doing some of this
um one example was in recently was in
gorum you know old big Victorian home
the other one's in Claremont I think we
had but it was always a a home at some
point the first floor converted to a
business use and there's still two unit
units say upstairs and now we want to
put one or two units on our first floor
and currently we can't do that without
having to sprinkle the entire building
the line I often use in this case is you
could probably trip and fall and land
outside um but we can't without
sprinkling the whole building so um I
think that I I think that the amendment
that we created which is mirrors what
the ask is in this uh language here um
will address what we've been talking
about for the last probably year and a
half on the building of Firecat side and
and and finally and thank you so much
for helping me um understand that but in
in the event that there was a fire chief
that held up the process and said we
were going he felt for safety purposes
in this Victorian home or whatever that
um this was going to be required there
there's no there's no action that could
be taken by the developer against that
fire chep is there or would your
department step in and and be the go
between on that so typically what
happens people often start the local
level with their administrators or
Selectmen and then very often we'll get
involved and try to help educate on the
code perspective um sometimes I've asked
people to put a variance in um which is
a simple just quick application and that
opens the door much cleaner for us to
come come in and say this is you know
these are this is the interpretation of
the fire code and I would say more often
than not we've been successful when
we've been involved we clearly don't get
involved in every single case um and
so there are still those issues out
there I I think the hard part because
I'll reiterate on
the the more we add code stuff buried in
different parts of the statute from a
user perspective it it's very
challenging as we educate people of as I
go back to this is a state code this is
a state amendments and then oh by the
way you got to go look in 155a you got
to go look in 153 you got to look at
154 um and others um and it just it it's
very hard from a designer and end user
as we start burying code amendments in
different parts of the um code from a
user
perspective go ahead and
um Devil's AB could can you if it's if
it's fine for four residential units
that are
existing and anyone building a new
building has to follow a much better um
most likely a much more
stringent um set of uh construction
details insulation and wiring and
everything else for a simple person like
me why isn't that okay also so I guess
I'll back up a quick minute so the the
reson the fire problem in the in our
state and across the country we're
losing about a dozen people here fire
deaths in homes um one and two family
homes on the from a code perspective
have been required sprinkle systems for
probably 20 years or so now uh we we
chose to take them out make it a user
you know end user decision for our own
our own being and I'm okay with that um
I I'm will just educate on the value of
the sprinkle system as we add more
people and to bake the buildings bigger
um especially for I'd say a
new the your impact within your unit has
a bigger impact on others that I think
that's always the way I think about it
right so as we grow into say the four
units or six units or like where like
where does this stop
um if there were a fire in our in our
homes or in our apartment
building you're going to be you know you
can your care and concern about other
people within the building only go so
far so we were all t as youths right to
have a meeting place at our home right
go go to the I tell my kids to go to the
chicken coop in the front yard well and
I'm going to go out and make sure my two
kids and my wife are out there when when
you have a huge apartment building you
might not know who all the people are in
the building and that I think that's
from a safety perspective what where the
sprinklers become more important uh from
they're they're proven to to save lives
and property the losses are are less
from the existing versus new it's more
expensive to put a Sprinkle system in an
existing building um in new construction
you're already in the street digging up
for water if we have water supply
available for water and sewer if you're
already on the property if you don't
have water sewer to your point in the
North Country we're we're we're putting
septic systems in Wells in and stuff
you're doing the necessary excavation to
get the water supplies in place um it's
different than if you're resisting home
if you
I worked at conquered fire before I was
in the fire Marshall's office I tried to
put sprinkler systems in the fire
stations it was going to cost us a
tremendous amount of money to go in dig
into North Main Street for the central
fire station uh because they just paved
the road so that that becomes an
obstacle and I think that's where some
of the things are you think about with
these existing buildings is it's harder
to it's harder because of all the other
Rules and Things to to facilitate um
water supply and things like that in
existing in existing building thank you
sir thank you Mr chairman of
course um yeah I'm going to call
Representative Gibbs and then
representative
Damon thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you Marshall Tumi for being here and
speaking with us um you mentioned uh
that there are problems with uh local um
uh Fire Chiefs uh and local authorities
not being famili amiliar enough with the
state fire codes and also uh that
sometimes there are problems where your
office uh steps in and provides
educational uh provides education uh to
try to resolve that problem but can you
tell us um are there any uh broader
efforts that you make to acquaint local
officials with the state fire codes sure
thank you for the question so in my ten
years of Fire Marshall uh which started
in June of 21 we implemented a training
program that we try to deliver our goal
is to deliver two um sort of continuent
Education uh fire code topics in
different areas of the state each month
um we've got uh we're doing a bunch on
heating gas Appliance related
inspections in the in this coming month
uh we did some scenario based questions
and answers on fire code so we travel
across the state and do course delivery
and we usually get a dozen to two dozen
code official fire code officials
typically coming in to learn about it
and our the goal for my office really is
uh consistent enforcement of the fire
code
um you you're welcome represent
Damon thank
you thank you for taking my question
Marshall Tumi and I should have um
acknowledged in my introduction how
helpful you and also Phil Sherman with
the building code reboot board have been
um
I'm wanting to ask in regards to your
remark a minute ago about there are some
issues with code compliance and local
interpretation if I'm paraphrasing what
you
said is there anything you would
recommend that we be looking at in terms
of Statute around who is a code
compliance officer or how they proceed
that is there anything that would be
helpful in that regard I think I'm going
to get daggers if I answer that question
but one of the things things that's come
up in the past is of course
certification and education I think
that's the key to it right we our fire
academy in the state we have a fire
inspector 2 and a fire inspector uh
excuse me fire inspector one program and
a fire inspector 2 program we try to
encourage anyone that's doing
inspectional work to get certified um
and then continue your education uh and
I think that what comes up frequently
and I haven't heard it for a couple
years now but is there requirements for
getting people certified there's no
requirement for people to be certified
to do code enforcement work uh the
building officials Association does
phenomenal work they have monthly
trainings there's opportunities for
certification on their path there's
opportunities on our path as well um but
we need to just continue to if you're
going to be a code official get yourself
educated um and you know reach out to uh
the other experts in our state to help
you um interpret and use the codes when
necessary I appreciate that answer and
I'll try to pull the daggers out of your
thank you uh representative bery thank
you Mr chairman
um um Marshall Tumi you've been a
marshall for 10 years
now in the last 10 years um do you have
an average of how many people been I he
started in 2021 so it's I think it's
only a couple years right oh I thought
you said 10 years he has a 10-year term
if I okay foure term four term four term
well in your experience as far back as
you can think about how many people a
year do we lose to fires in New
Hampshire in one to four unit building
in one to four unit I I don't I don't
know that statistic right off the top of
my head I can tell you we lose about a
dozen people a year in residential fires
um our office investigated uh 24 fire uh
24 fatalities last year um which 12 of
them ended up being in in the
residential setting and that seems to be
about the trend we've gone as high as
you know in the 20s and we've dipped a
little bit lower than that but I can get
you some more specifics on fire Death
data one of I think one of the things
that we you will see and if depending on
what testimony behind me but the
National Fire Protection Association uh
collects data for um incidents across
the country and they compile that and
one of the things that we looked at when
we we u considered Amendment for this
was uh looking at the apartments
specifically across Ross the last many
decades the the the curve is pretty flat
as far as uh residential apartment fires
um I will say my my only concern about
um as we diminish Life Safety in in
apartments we you know we talk we've
we've heard conversations about um
modern construction techniques talked
about changes in furniture and more
flammability of furniture we hear about
the emobility devices that are having
fire issues so I think we got to make
sure we continue to watch and balance
the fire safety requirements with the
newer stuff that's coming out um make
sure we don't go backwards right so um
in the 70s we added smoke alarms and
that had a significant decline in fire
deaths um I I guess as a State Fire
Marshal I would hate to go backwards
that's all um so I think we're just
going to continue to evaluate that but
uh about a dozen deaths a year I can get
more uh detail of you if you want to but
okay um a followup we're talking about
one to four units so it's a a small
apartment building buyes that we're
really looking at here so if you can get
us some kind of number on that I'd
appreciate it I'll see what I'll see
what I can do for you sir yeah smoke
alarms really work because I fall asleep
once in a while when I'm cooking and
goes off and it's time to get
up yeah thank you thank you couple two
many years Ellen representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and for your
testimony and your work um in kind of
piggybacking on representative barudi I
would specifically like the numbers
because this is really just affecting
the three and four units specifically
like any numbers you can generate around
three and four unit uh fires where it
was in the fire happened specifically
because of a carryover from one unit to
another because I think that's what
that's the rationale behind the more
units there you need a a sprinkler
system and but my question so I was just
adding to that request but my question
is because I really just want to be very
clear about the difference between this
piece of legislation and what is in the
Senate bill that was recommended uh in
the fire code so the differences are
this would be binding on municipalities
and that they could not
require a sprinkler system on anything
up through four units um the Senate Bill
version it would not be entirely binding
the other difference is that the Senate
Bill version would not would would would
allow the requirement for um for three
and four units if they are new whereas
this one would not um and I think those
are the only are those the are those
differences accurate what I just said
and are there any other differences
between this and the sen version can you
uh just back up on your new existing one
I'm not sure I I think I missed that one
okay I'm trying to I'm trying I'm trying
to understand the difference between
this bill and the Senate version um and
my understanding is the two major
differences are this would be absolutely
binding on municipalities they would not
be able to require a sprinkler system on
anything up through four units the
Senate bill it wouldn't be technically
entirely binding so towns could but then
you're saying that they probably
shouldn't but they could um the second
one is the Senate Bill version this
would say it's new or new construction
or existing you can't require and the
Senate Bill version would allow
requiring for new construction even
though as it was pointed out new
construction is generally more in
compliance with upto-date standards
anyway so this um this bill and the
Senate Bill amendment is is for existing
buildings only both of them um they both
would allow Renovations in existing
buildings so you would be allowed to
create uh up to so you had a two family
and you wanted to create four family
within the same space or you know you go
up to four families within the same
space uh from that construction
perspective but a ground up new building
is not contemplated in this bill or the
Senate Bill does that help answer that
part
I I don't see that maybe it might be in
the section it's under that's not listed
but I don't see anything any reference
oh sorry shall not be required an
existing residential so what you're
saying is that both this and the Senate
Bill apply to an existing structure that
wants to increase the the number of
units in that structure so if it's they
wanted to build an apartment or whatever
so both of them would be
this one binding the Senate one not but
would be um getting rid of in general
getting rid of the requirement for
sprinklers on anything up through four
units as we talk through this and I just
sort of think out loud a little bit the
probably The Binding part is the
probably the big part of it
um hoping the local doesn't try to
circumvent this somehow the only other
thing that I as I look through the
current l language that we have this
starts to talk about fire barriers and
egress and things like that I think that
the code expands on that much better um
and that almost I think muddies the
waters a little bit when we start trying
to intermingle other little code
components without the background of the
code in the statute
um yeah I
don't if the committee felt that it was
absolutely necessary to have this in
place I feel like it would be more
appropriate to say existing residential
no more than for dwellings and comply
with exist like the exist I'm thinking a
lot of it but the existing provisions of
the Life Safety Code the state fire code
and the State Building Code and point
them back to the other separation
requirements ESS requirements and things
like that but I mean we'll get in the
weeds I'm happy to work with you guys uh
if if you have those concerns we need to
go down this road but but um I'm
cautiously optimistic that the local
officials might not go astray but I can
promise you
that um you're more optimistic than I am
uh representative
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
again um I'm wondering if you could in
addition to what's been requested about
data on loss of life which is
clearly what we most want to prevent but
could you also provide us some data on
loss of housing due to fires if that
exists um thinking on a just recent
example in one of the communities I
represent cipe we lost a historic old
building and uh close to two dozen
people are homeless because of that
there there's no place for them to live
I think there was a six 14 or 16 unit
building I was up there for for that one
yeah I'm sure you were quite a
scene I will do my best to try to
capture some of that data um I might try
to get as invest as I can Hampshire
stuff and then I'll get try to get some
of the national numbers I I I will you
know the national numbers are relative
flat on the desks and stuff like that on
the but I I'll work to get you some of
that information to help I I appreciate
that and you know General is fine it
doesn't need to be uh long involved
process for you I know you have a lot to
do okay thank you represent y thank you
um thank you for taking the question
um some of the people seem to be as far
as like the Quest for for data regarding
the deaths looking specifically for two
and three or uh three and four sorry
um but I am not as focused on that I
would like to see kind of going back to
your statement before as far as
sprinklers in general
are saving lives um if we I'm interested
in any of the data that you have that
indicates that um maybe even in a one
person or one one uh one family
dwelling that they didn't have a fire
fire sprinkler system and there was a
death um I would be interested in that
versus
um versus if there was a death in in a
situation where there was a fire a
sprinkler system or you know if there
was 100% all of the deaths in were were
in people that did not have sprinkler
systems that would be interesting data
to me um so if you have that get info
yeah representative Gibbs thank you
Marshall Tumi um you've mentioned the
desirability of including all the
requirements um in the fire code ruled
rather than having them peac meal in
various statutes and that makes a lot of
sense to me but if I understood
correctly what's been said up to now
while this proposed uh bill would
prevent local uh Fire Authority
from requiring sprinklers in existing
buildings uh with uh three or four units
under the uh current um work that you've
been doing on amendments to the fire
code local authorities could still
require um that existing buildings with
three three or four units have
Sprinklers and what I'm wondering my
question is uh would it be a good idea
to um make some further Amendment to the
state fire code uh so that uh local fire
officials could not require sprinklers
in existing buildings with uh three or
four units so the battle will be the
local control discussion
um I think that's really the big thing
right so I think from a consistency and
application across the street that might
be a goal um you know we've we've
supported the ability to make small
local amendments as necessary uh it's I
think the trouble is when people make
huge amendments that are sort of against
what the intent of you as a general
court do and and things like that that's
sort of when we wind up in this room
talking about these things but
um I I found that thoughtful lawfully
adopted local amendments make sense
sometimes um you know there's there's
there's uh operational things I go back
to my conquer days like standardizing
keys for alarm panels and and things
like that that they come up that make it
from a functional and operational
perspective make sense we want uh key
box nox boxes in a certain location on
the building at the front entrance and
things like that that may differ from
Manchester to conquer Nashville
Portsmith or go up to Pittsburgh you
know I think we need to allow them some
flexibility but
uh there's some work in uh house bill
what's the
one there's a house there's a bill no
that's there's a bill being right now
that's trying to uh hone in a little bit
on the local Amendment stuff um
but I don't have a grance right now
representative
makoni thank you Mr chairman um thank
you Marshall again if I if I look at
this piece of legislation we have
1065 I don't know if you have a copy
there line five or line four and I'm I
just want your opinion of this it says
above that the state fire code
Associated shall not require suppression
or sprinkler systems in a detached one
two family dwelling units in a structure
used only for residential purposes I'll
take you back to gorum we have uh we
have buildings we have commercial
buildings that are no longer being used
that might perhaps take care of some of
our residential purposes that building
was never built built for a residential
purpose does that take it out of this or
that entire building was now to be used
for
residents what would you
say if there's a mix if there's a mix of
commercial and residential the
commercial goes away commercial goes
away and it's strictly residential it
would be I would say that it would
follow the existing building where we
would not require the sprinklers as long
as admit the existing uh apartment
chapter is what we have is the amendment
okay thank you sir thank you Mr
chair anyone else there's one more
question uh representative Gibs thank
you um I've just been looking up uh in
the leg lative uh search uh web page uh
for bills regarding local Authority um
and uh the closest thing that I found
was Senate Bill
437 relative to local authority to amend
the State Building Code was that what
you were referring to before yes thank
you and there's some language in there
on the fire code sorry I couldn't
remember the number that is the one so
you were talking about Senate Bill 437
and there was an amendment to that bill
um I believe it passed Senate the other
the Senate um Edna the other the other
day that would cover the fire code as
well correct thank you you're
welcome anyone
else thank you Mr Fire Marshall thank
you the committee now calls Philip
Sherman thank you Mr Mr chair members of
the committee uh my name is Phil Sherman
I'm the chair of the building code
review board uh for those who may not be
familiar with us we write the state
building code for ratification by the
legislature uh based on conversations
with the State Fire Marshall
representative Damon and others uh the
bcrb has already approved amendments
which actually go a little bit farther
than this bill uh and it would permit
conversions from a nonresidential use to
a residential use as long up to four
years units without requiring Sprinklers
and we also needed a second amendment
because there is a route through the
existing building code where you might
be required a sprinkler for major
alterations so we've taken care of that
as well um other sections of the bill
that talk about the specific technical
issues are already covered by the fire
code and the existing building code so I
I don't think there's a lot of need to
get into egress and fire barriers and
those kinds of things have to comply
with them anyway um again as the fire
marshal uh indicated I I agree that
writing specific code language into
statute reduces the potential to deal
with specific conditions that come up no
code can address every condition there's
just too many different situations out
there and our code and and through the
fire code there are Provisions to to be
able to work with things for specific
conditions um lastly in terms of the
state level uh the concern of not having
this in statute but having it in the in
the Amendments remember that currently
our board can't do anything we we cannot
change the code one way or the other
without it being ratified by the
legislature so nothing can drop out of
you know at midnight and suddenly there
it goes um I would talk speak for a
minute about Municipal amendments we
have to remember there's two different
statutes that talk about one and two
family dwellings one prohibits the state
from writing a rule another prohibits
municipalities from writing a rule I
think don't hold me to this I think it's
in
674 uh 51 or
thereabouts
um furthermore there are existing
Municipal amendments out there that when
the prohibition on one and two family
sprinklers came in they were not
repealed so that that statute did not
invalidate old amendments that were
around before that so I'd suggest that
if this does track through to a
municipal uh discussion be careful about
how some of those uh some of those
ordinances may be written and I'm and
again like the fire marshall said we've
only got four municipalities that have
sent these things to us for the website
um we think about these four unit
buildings um and frequently the issue is
tow houses so the old you know two units
upstairs two years downstairs they're
very expensive to build these days and I
I don't think we see all that many of
being built anyway uh but town houses
are just modular and you build them
until you run out of land or the zoning
people say stop right or whatever you
parking maybe um so that's really one of
the types of buildings that that goes in
there those can be built under either of
our codes there's a way to do it under
the residential code so there a series
of single family dwellings there's
another way to do it as a commercial
entity and again some of those Municipal
amendments get into those uh those those
issues um I'd also caution us when we
talk about
statistics we all know what
statisticians can do New Hampshire is a
very small state Nationwide fire
fatalities are 3500 a year perhaps 3,000
plus so to shrink the statistical base
down to New Hampshire or the city of
conquered or this building just gives us
with a less accurate uh view of things
um and that that's all I'll say about
that and then lastly the bill talks
about existing residential buildings
whereas our amendments talk about
existing buildings that are or become
residential so you may want to look at
that wording I don't know how the
lawyers and the Attorney General would
figure that out it may or may not be a
problem and that being said I'm happy to
take any questions thank you Mr Sherman
other questions representa coni thank
you uh Mr chairman thank you Mr chairman
to take the question um when when your
group brings these amendments forward
for legislature review do they come as
individual amendments or do they come as
the Senate likes to give us a pile at
one time and get passed are they
individual so we have uh in in this
cycle we're up we're proposing updating
six of the eight codes that are included
in the State Building Code the National
Electric Code is on a different cycle
because it's published by a different
entity we be back next year with that
and the energy code as some of you may
know we're proposing leaving where it is
it may through Amendment wind up going
to the newer Edition there uh with those
six codes we have 79 amendments many of
them are administrative we just need to
say this is the New Hampshire State
Building Code that kind of stuff some of
them are technical uh I believe 15 of
them are new amendments heavily to deal
with this issue recovery housing or
recovery homes which was a big big thing
bubbling around this year and we picked
up a bunch of other stuff some to bring
the building code into compliance with
some regulations that the governor's
Commission on disability already had
this was just trying to align things and
make it easier for
everybody all of that gets packaged up
and then there's a date in the RSA that
says approved by the building code
review board through this date and then
we shift that date which is is happening
now go ahead thank you so it's it's
voted on as an entire package
so it it all has to be approved you
there aren't individual pieces that come
through
so what we did last year the EPA changed
their rules on refrigeration and we
wound up with the need for a batch of
amendments that actually leap to LEAP to
a code that wasn't published yet to
bring it into account with what the feds
were telling us we had to do do anyway
all we said to the to the legislature
was sit tight let us go back approve
these amendments and then we change the
date out to I think it was in May so it
was that easy and we're not clogging up
the statute with the details of these
amendments thank you so so let me add a
a question on that yes or no does each
code Amendment get voted up or down by
the legislature or is it voted on as a
package
unless somebody changes it it's V it was
voted on as a package last year this
bill is intended to be voted on as a
package but bills changed does the
legislature have the ability to reject
part of it and not all of it or approve
all of it not and part of it right um
let's say that line out of veto
something like
that I I want to use a term but but it's
probably not the right term a bully
pulpit right so if there was an you know
a pretty cohesive instruction to us that
this amendment ought to go away what I
would say as the chair is give us a
couple months we'll take it back we'll
go through the process we'll get rid of
it come back to you with a clean bill
the other way it could happen and I
think it's happened in the past is you
know we have a code number for each
Amendment and we start writing that
stuff into you know except for this
amendment uh that might be necessary if
this issue came up late in the day you
know I toward the end of the session
okay represent biry no I asked your
question okay any other questions from
Mr
Sherman repres represent De Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so looking at um the
building code for a 304 unit
building if there's a garage under in
the building does that
require more
sprinkers no the only real impact of a
garage is a piece of sheetrock and a
door which matters whether it's under or
next to thank you
yeah seeing none thank you Mr Sherman
thank you all right next we'll call on
William
mckenny
welcome I can never I got it right this
time
good yep still morning good morning
represent Alexander and members of the
committee I'm Bill mckenny I'm president
of the Hamshire building officials
Association and I'm here to um just
speak a little bit about our concerns
with this bill um the building officials
uh tend not to support um code
amendments through the building of fire
codes be put in legislation um as far as
becoming law makes it very difficult to
amend those later and we've had some
instances in past and I would bring up
the case of RSA 155d which caused a lot
of conflicts in the state and it took us
about four years to have that amended
out and repealed um in order to resolve
those
conflicts so our concern here is that we
really believe amendments to the
building and fire codes should go
through the process that's been adopted
now and continues to be improved upon as
you know they've put in a new
legislative committee um that the bcrb
uh sends their their information to
their amendments to it's reviewed there
it's moved through committee and then
moved on to the legislature that's a
fairly new process and I think it's
really important that we spend some time
and to see how that's going to that's
going to play out um we really do not
support code amendments being put in in
is individual parts of the legislation
and with that I'll take any questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr
mckin representative
Damon thank you for taking my question
independent of your statement
about uh not supporting code amendments
in
law do you or your organization have an
opinion on the concept that's in this
proposed
law yes uh nhoa did work with the
committee over the summer um in order to
look to look at this uh uh possibility
of moving to no sprinklers in in four
units or less um and provided that the
other conditions are met you know proper
fire separation egress emergency escape
you know ear early warning devices
through smoke detection um we sub we
have no uh objection to this and you
I'll be honest with you if you ask
anybody how how it came to three units
needing sprinklers I think it's because
that's the commercial code right when
once you go to three units or more you
move out of the residential code and you
get end up in the in the commercial code
so now we're in the commercial code
let's sprinkle it so thank
you okay seeing no other questions thank
you thank you very
much all right so the committee would
like to call on Greg
Mor thank you Mr chairman members of a
committee for the record my name is Greg
Moore I'm a regional director for
Americans for Prosperity here today to
testify in support of this legis ation
um I'll start at the very high level the
reason for this committee's existence is
because we have a housing crisis in New
Hampshire we need to find a way to
develop more inventory for the state one
of the barriers to creating more
inventory are the capital costs zoning
zoning and planning are definitely one
one barrier but another barrier is is a
capital cost making conversions that
create more
inventory this is a a this legislation
is a good step in terms of reducing that
Capital cost to create more inventory
for housing in the state of New
Hampshire I would like to speak a little
bit about um some of the the technical
about about putting the building code in
in the statute the building code is in
the statute it's just Incorporated by
reference and what that means is what
that means is for those folks who don't
serve on on the Edna committee means you
vote on it you and you blindly accept
whatever a a third party organization
decides is the right the right thing for
the State of New Hampshire and it often
gets pushed that way because uh the
insurers like to see one uniform set of
regulations across all but that doesn't
mean it's the right policy for the State
of New Hampshire and uh and so this step
I think is an an important one in terms
of uh having a very specific goal in
terms of allowing units of up to four uh
four units to be able to have this
without this additional Capital cost
would be required to do an existing
conversion totally make sense for new
new construction it's not a b it's not
as big a burden for new construction for
existing it is a big burden to try to
make this this
conversion and the only thing that I
would say specific because you have Eda
passing these uh building code
regulations specific to remove conflict
the only thing that I would add is at
the beginning of this this uh paragraph
I would add non withstanding any other
provision of law to the contrary so it's
abundantly clear what the policy is it's
being set by the legislature and you're
not creating a conflict between this
section of Law and potentially another
section of law that is potentially just
Incorporated by reference and finally
the last point I would make is uh
relative to the Senate Bill coming
forward part of the challenges is that
that bill will go to will go undoubtedly
go to the Edna committee it will not
come before this committee and so you
then have two committees working
potentially cross purposes and I think
that that this is a clear statement of
policy by this committee uh which is
based upon the reason why this committee
was set up to exist in the first place
so I think it's an important step to
move forward with this and considering
how far behind I'll stop talking and
take any questions you might have thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify uh before us today
um you mentioned that you support this
this legislation but Al so this proposed
legislation but also um that the
building codes are uh Incorporated in
statute by reference which of course I
understand uh is there any reason um
that you would argue that it's better to
uh provide for existing buildings with
three or four units not being required
to have sprinklers is there any reason
that it's better to do that by Statute
than by revising the building code which
is a comprehensive uh building and fire
codes which are comprehensive statements
um of the requirements for uh those
doing the conversions and therefore are
at least relatively easy to find uh and
as you pointed out are also Incorporated
in the statute by reference thank you
for the question I apologize I have this
giant speaker in front of me so uh I
think that it's up to the legislature to
br side policy
uh Sor sorry could you speak into uh yes
I think it's important for the
legislature to set policy and we
understand what the Dynamics are at play
in terms of of a specific policy of
trying to create more more housing
inventory and uh and this is a bill that
allows for the creation of housing
inventory without an additional Capital
cost a significant additional Capital
cost so I I think it's it's it's from
the legislature's
perspective uh again and again I used to
work for the house so I I and and I used
to work for for for a state agency so I
understand the Dynamics between the two
it's certainly more convenient for a
number of the executive
agencies uh it's more convenient for a
number of the executive agencies to have
uh sort of these comprehensive codes but
at the end of the day from a
policymaking perspective uh it's up to
legislature to set that clear Direction
and that's what this legislation
does representa yella thank you thank
you for taking the question um do you
have any concerns um that seem to have
been brought up by previous speaker that
the restriction on this legislation is
just indicating that the state fire
codes um and Associated roles shall not
require um and not that
that is essentially silent on the
municipal power to amend that um in
possibly a different section of law that
they're that they have that power in in
essentially neutering the the value of
this legislation are you concerned about
that well representative thanks for the
question uh I would say that if you put
non withstanding any other provision of
law to the contrary you would solve that
problem okay thank you okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thanks next up I will call on The
Honorable Ivy
van good morning chairman and committee
thank you so much uh I would like to
urge you to not do anything with this
bill we don't need this bill I was
actually the person who called Sean T me
18 months ago and started this
conversation about not requiring
sprinklers for four or fewer units lots
of other states have done it I just
found out yesterday that Montana did it
and um particularly in a retrofit it's a
huge amount of money it does not
increase safety appreciably there are
better places to put our safety money
that's the big that's the meat of the
testimony but the real thing is we don't
need it because we actually don't want
to handle things like this in statute as
Sean said when I went and talked to him
about this he said we actually don't
want to do this in statute we have a
method and a place to deal with code
issues let's do it through the code and
that's what's happened it's as you have
already heard from everyone else it's
passed through Senate it's Senate I
think it's Senate Bill 599 it's on the
consent calendar it's going to come to
the house
we should vote for it and it will be in
the right place and we will have solved
the issue so I think we should stop
talking about this and move on to some
of those other fascinating bills coming
before us thank you so much for your
time and attention yes I will answer a
question if you have one
representative thank you um thank you
for your perspective um
what do you think about the issue raised
about the the local um Power Municipal
Power to essentially
um still have this rule in place even
after the code is adopted I think that
that is a red herring I don't think it's
likely to happen um I've been living in
the state of New Hampshire for 40 years
I've been involved in local government
for most of those years and as you know
I'm a professional land use planner
these are the kind of things we talk
about I don't and and changing the code
at the local level while it is possible
to do is not an easy lift I can't see a
local a local code official saying you
know what we need to do this I I just
don't see it happening I and I do think
there's a huge problem in having things
in various places my husband who's a
computer specialist says that if you
write if if you put the answer to a
thing in two different places it's going
to be wrong in one of them and I think
that that's a danger of trying to do
this through statute rather than through
code which is where it should live so I
don't see the the problem of a local
community saying oh let's do this as
being a thing that we should be spending
time and energy on I really don't I
think we should let it stay in the in
the code where it already is and leave
it there
okay thank you very much for your time
testimony thank you so much for having
me you have a question thank you for
taking my question would it not make
sense then maybe to amend this and have
a uh a Statewide prohibition such that
uh no local um political subdivision can
make any greater restrictions that are
currently in existence in the code you
can do that if you want to I don't know
that I think it's necessary but you
certainly could do that what I am
concerned about is that we we've now
spent almost an hour going down these
various rabbit holes I'm worried that
this very useful piece of of code is
going to be strangled on the way to the
house floor so if you wanted to make
that change you certainly could I don't
know that I think it's necessary because
of what I just said I I haven't seen a
lot of local jurisdic I only know of two
that have made a change to the codes one
of them is the Durham energy and the
other one when I said conquered and I
can't remember what it is those are the
only two ones I know about and I I just
don't see in our small towns that that's
going to or even our bigger towns or
cities that that's going to be a huge
issue I think there's better energy
places okay thank
you um so just we are running behind so
I'm going to power through lunch um
we'll plug away if there's members of
the committee that need to step away
that is um quite okay so um with that
I'm going to call on M
Fredericks good morning um I am M
friedricks from Durham New Hampshire um
and I use the pronouns uh Zer and the
title mix um and I am here representing
myself today uh thank you very much for
hearing my testimony um but I do also
want to share that I serve on the Town
Council um as an elected official in
Durham um and because of that have been
involved in navigating um Durham's
sprinkler code so Durham um actually has
a a little bit stricter sprinkler code
than the current um State one we re
require existing buildings to be
sprinkled as well and that is because of
um the number of student apartment
buildings that we have in town um
sometimes as many as 14 to 16 units
housed in sometimes old colonial homes
historic buildings wood um that
represent um or that our our um our fire
department has deemed to be a rather
exceptional fire risk to have you know
20 plus 30 so college students living in
a wooden Colonial building um with none
of the modern fire standards um that
said
um we have also recognized and our Fire
Marshall has recognized that we need to
treat buildings with um three or four
units differently than these larger
buildings um and so um that that that is
why I'm here speaking um for myself
today um I wanted to share a little bit
uh of a personal story around this so um
my sibling in Providence Rhode Island um
bought a two family um again his
historic home that He restored um and
he's been trying to to add a third unit
to that um he's owned this property and
been working on it for probably 5 years
now um and he was unable to do the third
unit for most of that time because it
would require um spending more than a
$30,000 on just the sprinkler system and
that's being on public water and we know
of course that in New Hampshire a lot of
lots are not on public water and so they
have much more expensive install ation
costs um eventually he was able um to
receive a a variance to do that third
unit in part because the historic home
had had an apartment back in the 1930s
in that third space but um and that is
the unit that he and his um now wife and
young baby will be moving into now if
they had not been able to do that that
would be um an entire unit of housing
that would be lost there um that
wouldn't have been able to been to be
created um our own story um you know we
uh created an Adu in our home to help us
afford our home we would not be able to
afford our mortgage and property taxes
without it um we have more space than we
need and that is still true um and we
get messages in our neighborhood
Facebook group from grad students who
can only afford $800 a month in rent and
can't find a place to live in Durham we
could create that housing and our
finished basement in our existing space
if this bill were to pass um along with
the second Adu unit bill um HB
1291 um the house you know the house
average household sizes in New Hampshire
are shrinking considerably I think our
average is at like 2.3 people Which is
far below what it was um se you know a
couple decades back and so looking at
our particular example this is a home
that is a square footage of under 2200
ft the occupancy if we were to have a
third unit would be 5 to six people so
that's really comparable to a pretty
standard single family residence um and
so I think that it makes a lot and how
large is the square footage of this
building
altogether um and the reason I think
that it may make sense to to consider
this as a bill still is that um you know
Durham is one of the municipalities that
um has uh exercised local right to
expand upon its code and do stretch
codes and there have been very good
reasons to do that at times um we have
concern about you know some some
existing multi-unit buildings that were
not sprinkler and that were Exempted
under the current state code and that
really were very serious fire risks um
as I mentioned before and um and had
past fires um and in the 1970s had
people die in Durham in those fires and
so there were good reasons for having
those stretch codes we also have a
stretch code in our energy code um and
we really value that as a community and
in fact we we've had you know developers
have had concerns about the increased
cost of that those same developers have
come back repeatedly to the town and
said it was a really good stretch code
because in five years I have more than
made up the money that I had to expend
additionally for those energy costs and
so it's ultimately creating cost savings
and and driving down the cost of housing
in Durham and I think that you know
having some local control enables
municipalities to where appropriate try
out different things see if they make
sense see if they work at a smaller
scale before committing the entire state
to something um and then that's why you
know in other zoning conversations we'
we've talked about why you know if you
try something at in one local level and
it doesn't work well you've made a
mistake in that small area and it's the
impact will be minimal and you can more
easily you know reel that back but if
you've committed the entire State down a
path then that's much harder and it's
much harder to kind of figure out what
is the best next thing for New Hampshire
and so um I am very wary of uh removing
local um control when it comes to being
able to do stretch ordinances but I
think that there are appropriate situ
situations where um the state may need
to step in and and clarify um
particularly given the housing crisis um
what really makes makes sense so thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions
represent y Kell thank you the previous
speaker to talked about how this this uh
was not going to be uh ATT tackled by
local municipality so I'm definitely
interested um in this uh
that that you guys actually did address
this locally um I guess if you know
uh does that local uh stretch code um
address the three and four unit
um requirement and does it require it
and and and just in general could you if
you have it readily available can you
send that code to the committee uh that
stretch code to the committee so that we
can peruse it at our you know ample time
sure I'd be happy to um to send that to
the committee and um currently Durham's
ordinance does require um sprinkling for
all um all buildings with three or more
units and we have recognized and Durham
that that is
problematic um and so we are working to
adjust that and change that and the
thought is the guidance um from our Fire
Marshall is that um he would like to
that
code but happy to share
that okay can you briefly elaborate on
what a stretch code a stretch ordinance
is sure um I'm not sure if that's a
official terminology it's what we um you
know what I've heard used uh around
Durham in terms of town government um so
we have um a couple places in which our
building code is more stringent than the
state of New Hampshire um the sprinkler
ordinance is not actually adopted as
building code is adopted as a town order
heating cost throughout the winter um
and and I know that our Town
Administrator submitted um a letter to
that committee about that and provided
some economic information about um about
why that bill was there not that bill
but that um that code was adopted in
Durham okay thank you see question thank
you for your testimony thank you I'll
now call Ben Frost would you like to
testify
okay thank you Mr chairman uh Ben Frost
Deputy executive director and chief
legal officer for New Hampshire housing
the pink card says Rob dapas he had to
step away I'll put in a new pink card
under my name um
thank you for uh enduring a a long
morning it is now afternoon uh we're
right there with you uh New Hampshire
housing is strongly in support of the
idea of this legislation we understand
the debate currently going on uh among
the committee and and Witnesses
testifying about whether it's a good
idea to put it into statute this code
change or to rely on the revisions to
the code frankly we're we're a bit
agnostic on that um we're simply
supportive of the idea of uh this and we
do have a a letter here in support of
this um the letter indicates you know
that the we have we have a housing
crisis you wouldn't ex exist as a
committee if we didn't um so I'm not
going to go into that I will point out
as others have uh that the sprinkler
requirement in conversions of existing
structures to three and four uh units
is very often prohibitively costly and
that means prohibitively means it
doesn't happen uh it's just too
expensive for the property owners to do
uh and so this would relieve uh those
Property Owners of that financial burden
and allow these sorts of projects to
proceed this this is the kind of
development that we need more of in New
Hampshire uh to address uh this housing
crisis uh and it is you know incremental
infill it's small scale it doesn't
require public subsidy it's just
a really really good and smart thing to
do I will point out a couple things
um and Mr Sherman in his testimony
addressed a question and this is with
regard to the phrase on lines five and
six of the bill where it says uh
existing residential buildings and I I I
think that that is uh unnecessarily
restrictive and so I would recommend a
change so that it reads um shall not be
required in existing buildings intended
for no more than four dwelling units
that allows for the conversion of
existing commercial structures to be
converted to residential and that
eliminates that that uh
confusion um if the committee chooses to
go ahead with this bill uh then I agree
with Mr Moore's recommendation that to
include notwithstanding any other
provision of the law uh contrary so uh
to the contrary because it it captures
that um message that this is what the
legislature means everywhere uh and and
I think would also address uh the local
Amendment question as well um I'll pass
out the letter happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
any questions for for Ben Frost uh
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question and
for all your expertise that's helped us
does your letter include the possible
Amendment language that you just um
suggested for line five and six it does
not because I didn't realize it was
necessary until Mr Sherman spoke could
you perhaps email that to us I would be
happy to draft it thank you so
much okay thank you very much for your
testimony I have two speakers left um
Jeremy
olssen
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee um a lot of what I
wanted to bring up has been spoken by
other people so I will be very brief and
good afternoon once again um I am a
homeowner from Manchester I recently
bought a three-unit house down there so
I own one of the buildings that we're
actually talking about here um as
everybody in here knows we have a
housing crisis going on right now prices
have been going crazy I paid
$525,000 for this place two years ago
the tax assessment says it was only
worth $390 that's
$135,000 increase in two years about 15
years ago these types of buildings were
only worth about 180,000 so they've
tripled in value in 15
years the sprinkler situation is
particularly pertinent my property um
Insurance person told me that the
replacement cost for this house to bring
it up the modern building code which
includes sprinklers would be
$750,000 that's what they cover so I
paid $525 but to build a new house if it
burned to the ground would be a 50%
increase over the cost that I actually
paid for it as somebody else mentioned
sprinkles cost like $330,000 to put into
buildings in some cities say maintenance
costs of thousands of dollars every year
to have the sprinklers tied into the
fire department to maintain them so
these things cost a lot for people who
have existing houses they cost a lot for
new buildings and um I'm surprised I
haven't heard anybody mention this term
yet but one of the problems they have
with housing now is what they refer to
as the missing Middle where you have
home builders where they're willing to
build expensive single families and
expensive duplexes but they don't want
to build three and four units anymore
because even in new construction this
stuff is cost prohibitive and so they're
only building expensive houses for like
Upper Middle Class Type people or
they're building multi-units which cost
millions of dollars but then it's it's
profitable again for them to be investor
properties making three and four unit
houses affordable to build again I think
is vital toward fixing the housing
crisis and so I would 100% support this
bill and I would support even
considering extending this to saying
that even new construction if they're
three and four unit houses that they
should not require Sprinklers and I'd
invite you to look at some of the other
um requirements that they place on them
to make them so expensive as they are
nowadays um
I that's basically everything I had to
say um to answer one of the questions
that came up from Mr yella earlier I
know that right now there is an RSA that
specifically says that localities can
add to but not subtract from the
building code and so cities do that very
frequently it's like you have your base
building code that's passed and then the
cities can basically add more and more
requirements to that if they feel it's
necessary the um testifier from dur
mentioned that I know they do that in
Manchester too so that's definitely a
concern of why this bill would be a good
idea add the notwithstanding Clause to
the beginning of it and make it clear
that localities can't just override this
if they choose to I would be happy to
take any questions that you may have
thank you for your testimony
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony and you
might not be the right person to ask but
I'm just I thought of this a little
while ago and and didn't have the
opportunity as so I'm asking it now so
the section of law that this is amending
as I read it because it's under State
Fire code and rules would prevent the
state from setting a regulation a State
Building Code or fire code to
require um sprinklers on everything
through four but does this as it's
written being in this section prevent
municipalities from from adding to that
thank you for the question and I would
not know the answer to that I read a lot
of legislation but I'm not an attorney
or an expert on
this any other questions thank you for
your testimony thank you I'm now calling
on Elliot
axan hi good morning and thank you very
much A lot has been said so I won't
repeat all of it too much um since your
hours behind I'll hold off on the full
voluntarist philosophical lecture I
prepared it was only 5 10 hours
appreciate that thank you yeah so um
obviously this this is about property
rights if people own a house if I own a
Triplex a quadplex then it should be up
to me um obviously this is something
that you guys all know because you are
the experts in this and you propose this
bill it'll make housing cheaper more
affordable more inventory um so more
housing available I actually have a
relative who's leaving the military
right now transitioning out via
internship looking for an apartment or a
place to rent in Southern New Hampshire
this is something that would make it
easier because more
inventory um I don't think that the
government should be requiring uh
certain sprinkler systems and though I'm
a voluntarist I don't believe in any of
these regulations I had a small house
fire that was still terribly damaging I
would not wish that on anyone um so I
take it extremely seriously um having uh
sprinkler systems and all that the good
thing is that because of uh modern
building and and all the advances in
modern technology and the fact fact that
you can buy like fire extinguishers and
I think I bought one a while ago it's
like a mini with the foam and everything
a fire extinguisher you could buy for a
few bucks um you can have that in your
house as well and the bill says that you
still have to have all the other fire
code um requirements even in these uh
these buildings so I also think that
this is something that should be handled
by the owners and the renters if the
renter thinks if I'm going to rent a
place if I think it's made of wood and
has no fire alarms and no sprinkler
system and you know it's in a dry place
where there are matches maybe I won't
rent there so it's up to me and it's up
to the owners to prove it safe and it's
up to insurances I'm not an expert in
insurance or anything in this realm but
I think um home insurance and stuff will
take care of this for instance if you're
in a wooden log cabin in a very dry
place like Arizona your fire type of
insurance and housing might be more
expensive so I think they'll take care
of that um I would I would also support
an amendment to include um the new
buildings even though it's maybe not
quite as costly I think new buildings
should also be exempt from this for a
Triplex and quadplex um again just on
the property rights issue and on the uh
cost of building and availability of
housing issue um and I think my my last
point I have written down is um there's
been some Talk of the technicality of
whether to do this by the like
Administrative Code versus legislation I
generally support legislation
legislators make legislation I you know
same route as you guys all know and even
though this is not an administrative
rule that could be made like in an
instant by just people adjusting code
apparently they have to come here and
get it approved that is awesome but I
think what they've mentioned earlier
because this is all new to me apparently
it's like an Omnibus kind of thing where
they can put in you know infinite
proposed rules and then the legislature
signs off on it like um uh consent
calendar or Omnibus type of deal and
then so they could put in all sorts of
stuff there where this is one bill for
one specific thing um so it's like a one
subject kind of deal so I I think that's
all I have here too um I think
representative Joella just mentioned
that we all somehow missed that it just
says state it doesn't say municipalities
can't require this sorry it was you you
look so similar that I just yeah um yeah
I don't know how we all missed that but
but if there's an amendment to the bill
um to to include municipalities
especially with Dylan's rule you know
not being able to do this to require
more stretch rules so I mentioned that
I'm obviously not a fan of like uh more
strict stretch rual type stuff by
municipalities um so I think that's all
I'm happy to take questions thank you
for your testimony any questions for Mr
axelman thank you much much is there
anybody else that's here to testify on
HP
1065 representative Walsh yeah thank you
Mr chair and I apologize for being late
I was not slacking I was at a
transportation council meeting uh but
while people are still in the room and I
don't I think we lost our building codes
expert did the authority in the fire
codes in particular in terms of whether
we leave it in rules or whether we go in
statute was the authority having
jurisdiction that's in N fpa1 brought up
at
all and and and the reason I ask would
they still have the authority if we
don't put it in statute to do more than
than what we're seeking and the second
part of my question I know Marshall tum
is here um I'm wondering if we can ask
next time he's here if the bill codes
have a similar provision that would also
give uh Code Enforcement Officers the
same latitude uh in other words you can
see where I'm saying I think we should
be leaning towards the legislation I
figured I'd ask if it was already
brought up I haven't heard that being
brought up thank you representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and not to turn this
into an exec or debate but um I I
understand just to clarify where we're
at I understand that no matter what it
will be dealt with legislatively because
it's either this bill or it's the Senate
Bill the question is do we like what's
in the Senate bill and do we trust that
it's going to go all the way through
without being changed from what this
committee would like to see so it's
going to be legislative it has to be but
the question the larger question that's
come up is that much of our testimony
that we've heard right now has been
presuming that this is prohibiting towns
as it is written and I just kind of
double checked with some experts it only
is saying that the state will not to the
state's building code the requirement
for for three and four so this would
still allow towns to add to it so the
question then becomes what is the intent
of this committee and do we then change
it yep okay so thank you for that
feedback um this is not the last time
we're going to deal with this bill um
okay so I'm closing the public hearing
on 1065 and I'm going to open a public
hearing on 12:15 and call on the prime
sponsor representative Scott Wallace
I got
that thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record I'm
representative Scott Wallace Rockingham
County District 8 the town of Danville
um I'm here to introduce House Bill 1215
relative to subdivision regulations and
the completion of improvements in the
regulation of building
permits uh the Genesis for this bill
came from uh this committee we heard
many uh
stakeholders those being Builders
developers um saying that they have run
into many many times that um once a
building permit is issued or a
subdivision
uh plan
approved between the time that permit
was issued and seeking final sign offs
there may have been some legis uh some
regulatory changes building code changes
local
ordinances that the town's uh officials
Force the developers to bring their
projects up to code with and see that we
in the uh legislature are prohibited
from making any retrospective laws by
the New Hampshire Constitution part the
2 article 23 all political subdivisions
are also subject to that same
prohibition on retrospective law that
being said this bill would simply uh put
into statute that when you are issued an
a building permit by a particular
municipality once you start that project
any changes in the building ordinance
can't be forced upon that
that Builder on that particular project
um that's not to say when a subdivision
is
approved uh let that might take several
years before that gets
underway the building codes May evolve
the building permits wouldn't be issued
at the time of the subdivision approval
so any building codes could still evolve
um after the uh passage of this bill um
this is more or less to make sure that
uh the anticipated costs of projects
remain um as anticipated and don't spir
a lot of control due to subsequent uh
passages of legislation zoning ordinance
or building code rules so it's pretty
much to say when the building permit or
project is approved any legislative or
rule changes subsequent to that approval
would not apply to that particular
project and that's pretty much the
essence of the bill and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you for your
testimony I do know there's a um a
number of people signed up to speak on
this that can add more insight on this
as well corre any questions for
representative
Wallace thank you for your testimony
thank you for being
kind the chair would like to call on um
Marshall
Tumi good afternoon now back
uh thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Sean Tumi State Fire Marshal
for the record
um representative Wallace your uh intro
cleared up a lot of things for me um I I
think that the my only concern with the
bill is uh the lock in portion of it um
what I read and what I kind of perceived
from the reading of this bill is that if
the years later someone starts to do the
construction and we're going going on
backwards years in the codes building
and fire from a safety perspective um I
think that once the permit's issued and
work is progressing that we shouldn't
change Midstream if the work is going on
on a building or fire code side so I I
get that
um uh so I sorry you good um so I I I
think uh maybe just making sure that
we're clear is that if I understand you
right that you're your thought process
you're good with uh sort of locking
things in once once the project starts
you're locked in so if we we're in the
2018 fire code for instance someone gets
their permane now and we go to the 21
codes in in in 6 months or a year from
now I don't start enforcing the 21 codes
on them when those come in effect that's
what you're trying to prevent correct
okay um I'm good I just I guess make
sure make sure that the uh language
matches that that's that would be my
only concern because I read it a little
bit differently so and if you have any
further questions this is a little bit
unusual but I'm more than happy to
answer them okay okay uh representative
yell thank you thank you for uh your
your testimony and I had heard some
Rumblings about similar views on this
I'm wondering if um on line 23 at the
end it says no pending subdivision if
that is sufficiently clear or you think
it should be more clear that when let's
say the
occupancy uh for such uh kind of plot or
whatever or the conclusion of the actual
pending thing before the um the you know
the plan or whatever so it's locked in
from you know applying until completion
and then you kind of start again when
you apply again to a new pending thing
if that needs to be more clear you think
that the no pending on line 24 is
sufficiently clear or um
since
um if I mean you don't have to answer
now you could just say I'll think about
it and get back to the committee if it
if you think that there is some language
that would be thank you for that bailout
question I uh I I agree now again as
hearing it I agree with what you're
trying to do we shouldn't be changing
Midstream the the concern I had was we
frequently get questions of I got the
subdivision approved 10 years ago um I'm
going to start building now uh if we
have to go back to codes from 10 years
ago that's going to be much more
challenging and I think that that was
where my concern was but if if you've
started building four years ago when we
were in the 2015 codes and you're
continuing building a massive building
stay with the 15 codes and finish your
project um I'm I'm good with that it's
it's it's the it's the holding forever
kind of component that we had some
concerns
about if I could respond to that could I
respond to that yep um to your
hypothetical the the legislative intent
is say for example you've got your
subdivision is approved no building
actually starts for a period of years
say a decade when the building permits
are issued under this particular Bill
the building permits and the so the
building and fire and electrical code
energy code would be current at the time
of issuance of the permit not the 10 the
decade old approval on the subdivision
only the 10-year-old subdivision rules
would apply and that if that helps it it
makes it much more clear I'm going to go
sit down and you're support huh you're
now in support yeah just I want to Think
Through the language a little bit make
sure we're speaking the same language
right we're we are I think thank
you okay
repr thank you
uh thank you for taking my question uh
would you mind and I I don't know that
you feel may feel comfortable I don't
know if it's in your purview to write
amendments but um would you mind sending
the committee recommended uh language
that maintains the legislative intent as
spoken to but avoids any um unforeseen
consequences that you might be worried
about I am happy to help with that thank
you great any other questions Marshall
to me thank you for your testimony thank
you right next I'd like to call on Phil
Sherman I don't see him in the oh I do
see Mr chair members of the committee I
will plead total confusion over what
this bill is getting at however
uh the the committee should be sure they
understand that currently at the point
you apply for a building permit that
code is locked in statutorily till the
end of that project if we talk about a
subdivision where there may be one site
plan approval but multiple building
permits as houses go along the codes
track with the house so if somebody
Waits 20 years to build the the last
house they'd be on the the then updated
code I'm not clear given the previous
conversation whether that's the intent
or or what I was reading which I thought
was once I build to today's code that's
the building code on that building
forever more uh so the the code is
locked in for a project there's no
question about that at
15582 part one
um I'm concerned that in fact references
to building codes in general in this
bill don't don't really add much to that
if I understand your intent properly I
think you could focus in on the site
plan and preserve that for all time but
then when somebody comes along and
actually builds something they pull a
permit on the code that's in effect at
the time I think somebody I had a
conversation with mentioned a very large
subdivision say a 100 homes and somebody
was building and building and then
suddenly the code changed in Midstream
well there one we have about a two to
threee process to update the codes two
we have a six-month grace period which
will handle most projects um but it's
not all that hard to know what's coming
down the pike at this point if you
really think it's going to be a
multi-year thing but what if it's a
20-year thing what if it's more than
just straddling a code what if it goes
out out forever and I'm not a zoning or
a planning expert so I don't know
whether there's another clock that ticks
on that end um I would like to comment
on our favorite uh city in the world New
York City because they actually do lock
in the old code on existing buildings
so in my professional life I had to go
read the 1938 building code because the
building was built under that code
pre-World War II however as they've
gotten into this they said well you we
really don't want you to build the
electrical system under the 1938
electrical code or the sprinkler system
or the plumbing system all that the
Technology's completely changed so
they've now got a stack of paper and
you'd have to be a lawyer to get through
it to understand whether you're really
on the 1938 code or all these pieces
that have come along the way have put
you pretty much on the new code anyway
so there there is that problem and the
other part of it U is to just keep in
mind that people with much larger shoes
than I worked very hard to get a
Statewide building coat in 2002 it went
into effect in 2003 and if inspectors
designers and and certainly contractors
have to start dealing with multiple
codes some of which could be very old uh
out the window goes the idea that
everybody is is pretty much working off
the same piece of paper so in summary I
I would hope that you could kind of
carve building and fire codes out of
this thing focus on the site plan
approval if that's really where the
where the major issue is happy to take
any questions um I'm I'm going to go
ahead and ask a question so in a
subdivision of 40 Properties or 50
properties and they're built over a
certain number of years somebody
purchases the land they want to build it
do you think the code if the code's okay
for the first house that's built do you
think the code should be okay for the
last house that's built the same
code I I think if if there's a a
reasonable time frame that might be
something to look at you know say three
to five years where you'd be one one
addition back or something like that but
to put it out as a as an infinite amount
of time when you say okay well the codes
learn and they frequently learn from
problems or they learn from other
regulations whether it's flood or energy
or whatever um and you know there's some
expectation that modern stuff gets built
to Modern codes because you could make
that same argument about a house that
was built in 1820 why why build it to a
new code
right okay thank you other
questions thank you for Testimony thank
you oh represent one second represent
Wallace thank you for taking my question
while I appreciate and understand that
what you said is accurate that these uh
the code is Frozen at the issuance of
the permit it's been my personal
experience in two significant projects
during my career uh where that hasn't
been the case and one of them was a
commercial building I had to go and add
sprinklers to after receiving my co fire
um permit sign off and open for business
okay I had to go in after the fact and
add sprinklers you can imagine what that
cost so although although that is the
case in practice there are
municipalities um and again I've run
into that in other towns that will ask
for things over and above what is
actually in code for whatever reason it
does happen and this will by putting
this in statute this will make it clear
to the towns um that that's not supposed
to happen would you agree with that well
I'd agree that there certainly are cases
where somebody just reaches into their
pocket and says this is what I Want U sp
sp 437 that was discussed previously
is attempting to get our arms around
that uh there would be a very painless
review process but if if we on the bcrb
haven't seen that ordinance it's
unenforcable so whether that flies or
not we'll we'll see so that should fix
the person who's just you know dreaming
up a requirement on their own um the
fire code is a special case but the
building code is very very clear that
once I have that application filed for
the permit or whatever is covered by
that permit I'm good you know if some
official is violating a law yes
absolutely maybe we need to look at that
side it thanks representative uh wsh yep
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I'll ask again a question I
asked on the last bill that's still
relative to this one while you're out of
the room within the building codes
Statewide building code is there any
Authority granted to uh your Municipal
Code Enforcement Officers to interpret
and determine in a different course on
any of the uh rules that may be there
for example like in the fire codes
there's the authority having
jurisdiction that can basically
customize what's required depending on
the
circumstances I'll give you my personal
view just having worked in the code
world for some 40 years now I think the
building codes in general try to be very
explicit you should be able to pick it
up read it do what it says and everybody
ought to be happy now that being said
are there times when somebody needs to
interpret something sure it's the
English language and there may be places
out at the margins where something isn't
clear I'll stick my head way out the
window here um I think NFPA and the fire
code take a little bit more of the view
that the ahj through a very active and
and and present variance process can
deal with some of these bigger issues so
there's you know there are there are
Provisions in the building code for what
they call code modifications there are
Provisions for alternative means and
methods those kinds of things coming
with a some new machine that hasn't been
approved yet that's all there's a way to
deal with that um but we have no
variance process just for that reason
and I think that tends to keep the the
Cod writers to the you know feet to the
fire so that they've got to write
sections that are understandable and
have a beginning and an end
and thank you you're welcome okay see no
other questions thank of your
testimony is William mckin in the room I
don't see him yet I might call on him if
he comes back um Greg
Mo thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record again my name
is Greg Moore Regional director for
Americans for Prosperity here today
testify in support of this
legislation I would say that that at at
the very least is there's no downside to
belt and susp rendering uh what we
believe is practice where I have heard
there to be a variance is often times
when a when a municipality will approve
a project and from the point of approval
to the point of completion there was a
change in the code enforcement officer
so you have a different person putting
eyes on uh what what is approved and
I've heard that from several developers
you have a dynamic in which a d Dynamic
which a new code enforcement officer
comes in there's a change and that new
code enforcement officer is is applying
a different standard than what was
approved by a prior code enforcement
officer so I think that is a specific
instance uh the use case why this
legislation is important so I know
you're way behind I'm going to stop
talking and I'll take questions any
questions for Greg
M seeing none thank you for your
testimony I'll Now call on Ben
Frost
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
committee members again uh Ben Frost
Deputy executive director and chief
legal officer at New Hampshire housing
um we are in support of this legislation
and really it's because of the the
overall approach of it and that is to um
provide important protections for
property owners who have received
approvals uh particularly from local
planning boards
uh to proceed with some sort of
development uh and it protects those
these developments from future changes
to um codes and regulations I
acknowledge that um there are issues
particularly with the building and fire
codes I don't want to speak to those I
do confess um uh similar uh to a prior
speaker confusion over the language of
the bill and the and the prime sponsor's
intention so I I think there may be some
a further discussion of that in either
outside of the Committee hearing or uh
in a work session would be appropriate
because I think that this does go to an
important objective um I want to focus
on section one of the bill which deals
with the existing statute RSA
67439 which is currently the so-called
five-year exemption and IT addresses uh
planning board approvals for
subdivisions and site plans um as
currently structured uh this
law provides five years of protection
for uh planning board approvals that is
the the the owner gets five years of
protection against changes to uh local
zoning or subdivision or site plan
regulations provided within the first
two years uh that permite the person
who's gotten the the approval from the
planning board engages in what's known
as active and substantial development
that is they actually moving ahead with
the project doesn't mean they're they've
completed it but they have engaged in
active and substantial uh Improvement uh
development in the first two years if
they do that they get the full five
years of
protection if they if within the five
years uh they have the the uh developer
has done substantial completion of the
improvements then that project is
permanently protected under law this is
a constitutional issue it's a the notion
of Reliance backed expectations so if
you've invested in something based on
what the government says you can do then
you have a property right in what the
government has said you could do uh so
that that protection becomes permanent
once a substantial completion has been
done by the developer um and that that's
true within the five years that's true
actually anytime that happens uh so
that's a really important precept to
keep in mind
um what the bill proposes to do in
section one uh is to take out uh the the
existing law and replace it with this uh
permanent protection and I think it
there is some confusion here with the
relationship with the between
subdivision site plan and the building
and fire codes uh and I think that does
need to be worked out if the committee
does not want to move ahead with section
one I would profer a uh an alternative
that I think would be really helpful and
that is to extend these
timelines uh it under the current
circumstances with issues of Labor and
Supply chains and delays in financing
and overall economic uh conditions that
come and go uh it may take more than two
years for someone to get a project off
the ground so that they get that full
five your vesting um this is something
that the legislature has dealt with
before in 2011 the legislature changed
uh this statute from uh a four-year
exemption with one year of active and
substantial to the current two and
fiveyear but also included within it a a
window that I'll call it the um the the
the Great Recession projects that is
projects that were approved locally uh
by a planning board between Jan January
1st 2007 and July 1st
2009 that 2 and a half year period if
you if you approved locally during that
two and a half year period you got three
and six
years I don't know what the magic number
is but I would suggest that five years
to achieve uh active and substantial uh
uh development and 10 years to re uh
achieve substantial completion would be
an appropriate uh
remedy have to take any questions thank
you for your testimony represent
viell thank you for uh your testimony it
seemed like at the very beginning you
were um suggesting that the when the
government says you're approved for this
subdivision that you should be improved
for that subdivision and that plan going
forward and then at the end end of your
testimony you're saying well maybe you
could be approved but only for five
years uh or 10 years and
so is do you have a is there am I right
in that in congruity or do you have a
preference one way or the other um and I
just didn't catch it in your testimony
thank you for the question and this is
this is a a common um
misunderstanding among local planning
board members what this statute means uh
lots of local planning board members
think it means um that the approvals are
only good for five years and that is not
the case uh it's a matter of of how
future zoning changes and other local
regulatory changes impact upon an
approval it doesn't mean the approval
expires so even a a a say let's say a a
20 lot subdivision is approved by a
planning board and nothing happens for
six years that approval is still good uh
but the zoning ordinance might have
changed in a way that affects how that
development would proceed uh and that
development under current law uh because
the property owner for whatever reason
did not proceed with it would then be
subject to those changes in zoning uh
that's what the current law is uh
approvals do not planning board
approvals do not expire zoning board
issues are an entirely different issue
statutorily uh but planning board
approvals for subdivisions and site
plans do not
expire so any other questions
representative
Gibbs thank you um just to be sure that
I I understand um if uh the uh developer
receives approval and uh reaches a
certain stage um and maybe um in a
moment you can tell us what stage that
is within five years um then uh changes
that were made uh within those 5 years
uh would not uh that the developer would
not be required to comply with those
changes uh but if that stage were not
reached within 5 years then changes that
were enacted after the 5-year period the
developer would be require ired to
comply am I right about that yes
representative G I think that is an
accurate recitation of the current law
uh and note that these are those stages
as you call them whether it's active and
substantial development or substantial
completion of the improvements those are
the two uh St parts of the statute those
can either be defined by a planning
board on a Case by casee basis as that
is an approval by approval basis or they
can be defined in the planning board's
regulations the subdivision or site plan
regulations as the case may be which
stage does the 5year exemption apply to
that applies to uh having achieved
substantial completions of improvements
shown on the plant that is the language
of the statute and that would mean for a
subdivision it doesn't mean building the
homes because those AR it what it mean
that's not what the planning board has
approved it means putting in a road
laying down the utilities that's those
are the improvements to which that
statute
refers okay thank you for your testimony
oh my apologies representative
Amon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question which not quite sure
how to ask this
but trying to better understand that
substantial completion within five years
and your statement a few moments ago
that if that had been accomplished
then the developer was permanently is
permanently
protected and relating that to
representative Wallace's
situation with the imposition of
sprinkler requirement when it sounds
like substantial completion
had been accomplished can you just weigh
in on that thank yes representative ban
and and the the issue is that uh the
current law in RSA
67439 addresses only zoning and
subdivision and site plan regulations it
does not include building or fire
codes thank
you Gary
Abbott thank you chairman uh committee
members uh for the record my name is
Gary Abbott I'm the Executive Vice
President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire I represent
commercial and Industrial uh
contractors and I come to you today
because I am so glad I followed Ben
Frost um because I think our group had
issues with this I actually brought it
to my board of directors yesterday I
brought it to them back in January
trying to understand the B and I think
they understand the current law they
understand what Ben talked about as far
as zoning and how long to get your
commercial project up and running and to
be protected from future zoning and
changes in land use so we understand the
five-year process that you just that Ben
just explained to
you and I agree with Ben that if you
maybe you want to do in the language is
extend the years I agree with if there's
problems meeting the two-year provision
or the five-year provision maybe making
those adjustments to be more reasonable
in today's market I think is probably a
plus because my group of course said we
like the current process we can live
with it we know there's some hiccups
that the sponsor is trying to fix but at
the current moment we we don't want to
mess with the system too much but I
think Ben's recommendation kind of goes
in that direction where you can get a
compromise
the building codes uh clearly I've been
very involved with the building codes
and the fire codes for many many years
over here and I just want to run you
through the process of a Commercial
contractor he's going to hire a designer
to design his building whatever that's
going to be and they're going to design
it to the the code they're going to look
at what the municipal amendments are and
they're going to design that building
and go through the municipal process to
get that approved and I agree with the
sponsor
once you've met those conditions and
you've met those codes we used to have
this a lot what the sponsor was talking
about where somebody in the field would
have a different idea or a different
interpretation we've clearly moved on
from that about five years ago it was a
major effort that those codes that or
changes in the codes at the municipal
level need to be done
legally through the legal authority of
the min IP ality whether it's either a
vote by the community a vote by the city
council there needs to be documentation
it doesn't need to be some official out
there making up separate rules and
regulations that are different than
other areas
so in recent passage of different bills
the cities and towns are supposed to
file those code changes with the State
Building Code review board it's already
law it's already in but only four
communities are doing it so there is
real no record for the Commercial
contractor coming in it would be a great
to have the state have one resource
where those amendments
are because they can make it more
restrictive and I think your committee's
hit up on that which could be a problem
under a number of items that you're
talking about today but you understand
this if somebody makes that
determination in the field there is a an
appeals process for the interpretation
of the code or the change in the code
that currently can go back to the
building code review board because there
are those disputes I do have contractors
that say hey we don't interpret it that
way we haven't done it that way in the
last three projects those changes so we
have a good system in place but I do
agree Senate Bill 437 that's coming is
trying to tighten those screws down on
City and town compliance and going to
too far beyond adopting codes if we're
if we're adopting 2021 hopefully this
year and there's only 2024 that's not
even completed and out we're up to date
so I don't understand municipalities
wanting to adopt more stringent codes or
more different codes the other part of
that is anybody can build to a higher
Energy Efficiency do anything they want
the issue is here of the authority of
telling private businesses private
commercial developments to do that that
becomes a question we think it should be
the owner's choice in these towns that
get up and say oh we do something more
restrictive we look at it and this is
where your concern is for housing your
your mandating costs and I've got
commercial builders that will s tell you
you mandate some of those things how
quickly is the payback and today with
interest rates the payback's going to be
a lot longer if you have to invest uh
money into that project through a
financial institution with the current
rates so we're in agreement with what
the committee's trying to do here um but
I do think listening to Ben Frost and if
those added years because you want
cities and towns are going to want some
protection that somebody doesn't go
forward with the development at all and
we don't really want to see that either
that it's open-ended forever but we
think we've got a good process and I
hope this committee will support some of
these Senate bills that are coming over
that trying to tighten down the
regulations and kind of push cities and
towns to file their amendments because I
think some amendments could be in
violation of some of the other things
the state has passed or in violation of
the code with that I know you're running
so late uh I appreciate it hearing my
testimony and uh would hope that maybe
tweak this a little
bit all right any questions for Mr
Abbott represent VI P hi thank you thank
you for taking the question it seemed
from your testimony that if the planning
board comes to is presented this
subdivision with this road going here um
and approves
it and let's say the the developer
doesn't start for 11
years um but and in the meantime they've
changed some regulations saying that now
the road needs to go somewhere else that
you're you would prefer that that that
even though it got approved before that
that person now be subject to that new
road requirement instead of uh the one
that actually got approved because this
this language in the bill is essentially
forever that if that road got approved
to go in that way then you can build it
that way it doesn't matter if they
change it in 5 years or 10 years if you
start that that subdivision whenever you
start it that approval follows you and
you're saying that no it should only
follow you for a certain amount of time
um it seemed like in your testimony is
that my correct understanding of of your
interpretation you're correct because
I've been in other hearings and meetings
where towns have complained about
contractors not starting projects and
there are a bunch of issues with that
with delaying to like 11 years that that
could be a major problem of getting a
permit and holding off for 11 years so
I'm cautioning even though I represent
an industry that you would probably
think yeah we'd like forever uh even the
developers I think there's got to be a
balance so I guess that's what I'm
putting on the table is I I think you
want to be fair to the whole process and
I think you have to be understanding I
guess what we we recognize contractors
don't want to be too far back in codes
and those kind of things because of the
liability um we supported the Statewide
building code initially in the 90s
because we did not want towns towns had
codes that were 15 years old the
liability for the contractor not to be
building to the latest code was a
problem I think some of those issues
might happen in land use as well I'm not
big on land use that's why I like Ben
Frost talking about plann use but I
think that's some of the issues we have
that we don't talk about that we're
concerned not to be too far back in
codes because then you have liability
issue for
structural okay I hope that answered
your
question thank you for your testimony
thank you Jeffrey
cream
Jeffrey K from NASA um actually one
thing I you know wanted to go back here
on was there was a talk about the RSA
155 A2 having a lockin thing which is
true and I see it there but that applies
to the state and some of the things in
this bill um are trying to make sure
they apply to municipalities in terms of
ordinances we already had someone
earlier talk about how in Durham we
don't even use building CES we just pass
an ordinance to do certain things right
so I I think the protections provided by
this will are important so I should say
gu I support the Bill thank you um you
know a practical sense it provides
certainty for projects and reduces risks
of abandoned projects that have already
received financing or started
construction or otherwise began
investment of time and money and puts
ongoing projects in equal footing with
existing structures provides Clarity to
the planning boards and political
subdivisions relative risks they may
face if they were to attempt to impose
such changes uh representative Wallace
already talked about the Superior New
Hampshire Constitution but the you know
the US Constitution also has sections on
exposed facto laws so I guess I won't go
into all that but it's interesting that
as we you know we recognize the
retroactive um clause in our
Constitution and the Expos fact those
but we ALS start talking about things
like 10 years five years like the
Constitution does sort of provide a
pretty blanket um statement about uh
retroactive
laws um if the legislature um intends to
uh I'll that we were talked about that
um the bill provides explicit Clarity to
political subdivisions that recor after
changes can not be mandated I think
that's important because it will reduce
the risk of uh of lawsuits and I think
it's important to know that nothing in
the bill prevents a political
subdivision for making non-bonding
suggestions based upon updated rules or
ordinances so in some cases it's
plausible that uh there might be changes
that have structural benefits or safety
benefits or life cycle cost um
reductions like there was talk about you
know better better inflation it's going
to pay for itself well if it's going to
pay for itself what developer or
homeowner is not going to want to do
that right so um certainly nothing is
preventing people from uh adopting those
things
voluntarily um and I guess that's it I
don't want to repeat things
relate oh thank you if you if you'd like
to send us a copy of that that would be
helpful so we can read that on our own
as well send an email thank you for your
testimony any questions questions seeing
none thank you very
much okay um Ivy
van I'm gonna hold off n
graze
thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association uh we do oppose
the legislation but uh based on the
testimony we've heard today um it sounds
like uh Mr Frost Mr Abbott the Fire
Marshall and I assume Mr Sherman would
all like to uh work together on an
amendment we're happy to do so um some
of the suggestions that were made were
to amend um some of the timelines that
currently exist exist um and that's
something that I think we can come to a
compromise on um as as mentioned um
there are some statutes like
15582 one that would apply um and of
course that applies in in the code world
and there is separately um the zoning
subdivision world and I think that Mr
Frost explained that um quite well um so
I think there is a compromise that
stakeholders can come and I'll just
reiterate that there have been pretty
substantial changes in the building
World especially how we apply codes in
this state in the last few years so
still working out some of those details
but I'm confident that we can come
together and make it all work better
Happ to take any questions thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
for n Mr gracek thank you for your
testimony okay um there were two people
signed up that are no longer in the room
so with that is there anybody else that
wish to test fire on hp1
1215 okay so with that that I'm going to
close the public hearing on HP 1215 and
we are going to take a 5 minute recess
and then we will go to HB 1361 thank
you
and we'll call on the prime sponsor
representative
Alexander who's in supported a bill I am
yes thank you Mr chair members of the
House special committee on housing for
the record my name is Joe Alexander I
represent the town of gtown which is
Hillsboro District 29 so first of all
I'm speaking on HB 1361 but I also have
an amendment that I have passed around
to the committee that basically replaces
the entire
bill um so there are extra copies for
members of the public that would like to
look at it um I I kind of want to zoom
back and talk about we spent eight
months as a committee really like honing
down on what are specific needs of the
state what we're lacking um and and we
try to identify key issues in this in
this space to try to move the ball
forward and and and I I have the firm
belief that this of course is a supply
side issue I just don't think we have
enough units um and I think that the
units that are being built are almost
always or or or the ones that are the
most economical for people to build
because of the environment are single
family residences and single family
neighborhood these are the these are the
ones that are the most um financially
advantageous for for developers to build
so this bill would basically clarify um
the RSA around municipal or around
manufactured
housing I think the key the key missing
piece in this entire puzzle is that
there are not enough units at an
affordable price and this is really a
transition to getting New Hampshire with
enough units out of affordable prices so
um to put it in perspective I purchased
a townhouse in 2017 in Goffstown and it
was priced at 160 I I bought it I think
at the time six grand over asking and it
was
$166,000 and back then I was like oh my
God that's a lot of money I'm like wow
and all I did was sit on the thing for
six years and now we're at the point
where my house is doubled in value and
if I came if I tried to buy a townhouse
in gown for1 166 ,000 I mean
representative Rudy's a realtor I think
he'd tell me he'd be like maybe you
should like up your price a little bit
so without trying to
overregulation who got a graduate degree
moved moved into a house um could afford
to buy a house instead of get stuck in
the cycle of $2,000 rent a month unable
to afford a down payment they could have
that key to home ownership which is I
believe strongly is the key to the
middle class this would allow us the
opportunity to do that so this is not
just a bill that will affect young
people I think this is a bill that would
help people that are looking to downsize
elderly may have a smaller family at a
point in their life and they decide you
know what it's time I'd like to retire
into a community that works for me um
you know hearing the
compelling presentation from this
morning this might be a space where
people with developmental disabilities
get to be in a community that with an
affordable home at a decent price um a
lot of these manufactured housing are
housing units are energy efficient um
but they're they're affordable by and
large and again if there's people
concerned about property taxes or
anything like that that like this is a
going to provide a decent um property
tax relief as well by having one of
these units so um with that there's a
bunch of people behind me that are ready
to testify in support of this so I hope
that um you'll refer a lot of the
complicated questions to them but I hope
I gave you a strong compelling story of
why I believe this is the missing piece
of the puzzle so thank you thank you and
U go thank you thank you for taking the
question
um it on line 9 and 10 of your Amendment
um it says a municipality that adopts
land use control measures shall allow in
its sole discretion manufactured housing
to be located it seems like the that
language is trying to require that they
allow it but it also seems like it's
saying that nope they can just allow it
in their sole discretion or not in their
sole discretion um is the purpose of
this legislation to require
municipalities
to um allow or is it to essentially
allow flexibility that they can or
cannot allow uh the light the
manufactured housing thank you yeah well
thank you for the question I would say
this is an effort to be clear but not so
clear if if this makes sense with
municipalities need to afford a
reasonable and real realistic
opportunities for citing and
manufactured housing we found um we had
a presentation by Sansom College last
year the zoning Atlas about you know if
you filter out how many municipalities
allow Zoning for manufactured housing
it's such a small small small amount of
landspace that's available so um I want
to make sure that municipalities are
looking at this at in a reasonable way
so you're saying it's not clear I mean
it it it isn't clear I mean it's not
going to tell you like you must do it
but I think the RSA needs to state that
you need to look at you need to at least
look at it entertain the idea um for
that
followup I think it's my understanding
that the current law already requires
that they allow it in some
form um but the the problem is that they
may only allow it in manufactured
housing Parks but there's no room for a
manufactured housing park or whatever in
their town and so they you know they
don't allow it on a single single family
lot and so it seems like we are not
going anywhere with this legislation um
and so I'm wondering if you would be
open to saying like you have to
essentially anywhere that
it's you allow a single family house
that you could uh you should be allowed
to have a manufact factured single
family house um would that be amendable
to you I'm going to refer that question
to the people behind me okay thanks
thank you okay anyone else
representative
Damon thank you
so so following up on representative
Ella's question just to confirm what I
think you just
said
um the section from line 9 through line
19 is not intended to say that a
municipality would choose at least one
of these options it's simply intended to
say these are options that you should
entertain is that correct
correct would you be open to an
amendment that says a municipality shall
choose one of these options the the bill
is in the hands of the
committee and I am one member of it
so thank you representative De
Lorenzo
oh
okay thank you representative Del
Lorenzo uh yes um when I first read uh
this bill um and became a co-sponsor of
it I thought that I understood um that
the um provision was that uh manufactur
housing must be allowed in some form um
and that the in its sole discretion
applied only to how it shall be how it
shall be allowed so but now I'm I'm
hearing that I might have been wrong
about that that in fact it can be
disallowed thank you for the question if
you I'm going to refer you to line um
to I on which version uh of the
amendment I'm looking at Line 6 to8 it
says um municipalities shall not exclud
manufactured housing and manufactured
housing Parts in subdivisions completely
from municipality by regulation zoning
ordinance or any or any other police
power so therefore the in its sole
discretion does apply only to how they
do it not whether they do it yes thank
you okay thank you and U representative
Damon
thank you
so obviously as a co-sponsor I support
this bill I support it very much and the
amendment is much clearer formatting
than the original bill so thank you I'm
looking for whether we have somewhere in
statute that I don't know about um
definitions of reasonable and realistic
as with the languages here more than
once and I find that language vague yeah
and and I and from my experience as a
legislator and I'm not a lawyer and I I
do make $100 a year I don't know if you
know that so um I I'm not a pro with
this stuff but what I can tell you is
that typically when we put reasonable
and realistic in there we use it in a um
a a way that provides the judicial
branch some flexibility because I think
the general public can say what they
feel is reasonable and what I feel is
realistic I believe most people can say
this is a reasonable ordinance or this
is an unreasonable ordinance and a lot
of the time it's left up to
interpretation okay anyone
else question I'm in to thank Mr
chairman um and um Mr Alexander
representative Alexander um perhaps I
should hold my questions online 27 to 32
for someone else uh unless you'd like to
address those
I um so my my question I think I think
that's yeah if you want to hold off on
that that sound great we'll do thank you
Mr chairman okay anyone else thank you
for thank you Mr
chairman uh we'll call Nathaniel Z
Williams did
I
Nathan
no okay Katie
mcade and supported the
bill MERS my name
is
how's
that thank you chairman and committee me
committee members my name is Katie mcade
I live in Manchester Ward 2 I'm also
vice president of external relations for
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund I
am joined today by my colleagues Kelly
cicarelli and Kathy
Paradise I'm here today to urge support
for House Bill
1361 with the proposed amendment because
it will create more opportunities for
New Hampshire families to achieve the
American dream of home
ownership when my New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund colleagues presented
to this committee last June we shared
some very exciting information New
Hampshire residents can own their own
manufactured home at a lower monthly
cost than renting an apartment of the
same size the New Hampshire Community
Loan Fund is one of few lenders that
offers Fair fixed rate 30-year mortgages
on manufactured homes we also offer 0%
loans for families with very low incomes
to cover down payment and closing costs
as you can imagine demand is
skyrocketing during our last fiscal year
we pre-qualified more than 700
households for manufactured home
mortgages but like other forms of
housing in New Hampshire there is not
enough Supply to meet demand and we were
only able to finance and find and
finance about a 100 homes for families
last year House Bill 1361 with the
proposed amendment is a clarification of
existing law that could create more of
these affordable home ownership
opportunities through the development
and expansion of manufactured home parks
manufactured homes are the perfect
option for both firsttime home buyers
and those ready to downsize adding to
their supply will open the supply of
traditional stick-built single family
homes as
well there are currently about 400
manufactured home parks around New
Hampshire the smallest has four homes
and the largest in exiter has three
397 but the average Community contains
50 to 55 families residents of these
Parks may have lower incomes but they
are important members of our community
and vital to our economy cities and
towns across the state would have a hard
time functioning without the essential
workers Who call these Parks home and
modern manufactured home communities are
no longer the trailer parks of the past
the factory Built Homes are on par with
siteb Built Homes in terms of durability
and safety they adhere to rigorous
standards that cover structural
integrity and resistance to Fire and
natural disasters new manufactured homes
boast appealing designs energy efficient
features and customizable options
manufactured homes are not just
affordable safe and dignified housing
they are one of the few affordable
solutions that provide an accessible
path to home ownership and generational
wealth building for low and moderate
income families we should encourage
their acceptance and appreciation and
create more opportunities for their
placement around New Hampshire the the
New Hampshire Community Loan Fund
applauded this committee for its Brave
bipartisan exploration of real solutions
to New Hampshire's housing crisis and we
look forward to being a trusted resource
please vote to pass House Bill
1361 with the proposed amendment thank
you any questions uh representative
M thank you thank you for taking the
question you you talked in your
testimony that this is a clarification
of the current law already on the books
and I kind of alluded to that in my
previous question I
am interested in your interpretation of
what exactly you think that it
clarifies
and uh and how you believe that the that
this change might um encourage
more availability for place of new
either single or or development cluster
kind of developments according to
current law no municipality can can can
um eliminate manufactured homes at all
right you have to allow for manufactured
homes this expands that to reasonable
and realistic opportunities for the
sighting of both manufactured homes and
parks and subdivisions so it adds that
language
in it also if you look down at
e
um e says municipalities show allow
reasonable and realistic opportunities
for the expansion of manufactured
housing Parks existing as of July 1
that's also
new right now there's about 300 vacant
Lots in um at least in the Resident
owned communities that we work with
there's 300 vacant Lots around New
Hampshire and sometimes you know there
was a house there that needed to be
removed or someone abandoned in a home
and to place a new home there sometimes
the rocks have to go through the zoning
process the local zoning process and can
be denied to place a home in a on a lot
that already
existed thank you for your yes that
would be great um it so you're you're
speaking to line six where it says you
have to be able to allow sighting of
manufactured housing and and
manufactured housing parks and
subdivisions and um however then it goes
on to like B where it's like you can mix
and match all of these things it it
seems
like
they're that there needs to be like okay
there's uh the sighting of manufactured
housing you can do maybe one of these
three things or whatever and then if you
want to do manufactured housing Parks
then you could do one of these three
things or whatever
um those don't seem to be separated out
that that you have to do you know choose
between these to meet meet this
requirement and these to meet that
requirement it seems all kind of jumbled
together in this amendment is is that
kind of your reading of this or is there
some way to delineate that you're um
doing
housing um you're doing housing parks
and you're doing subdivisions
or are you seeing that the housing parks
and subdivisions are the same thing we
want to see manufactured housing in all
places on single Lots in parks in
subdivisions
okay okay um representation
M thank you Mr chairman um I understand
the intent I know that um Towns at this
point in time can't regulate out
manufactured homes so many towns still
up north say on individual Lots or in
Parks so all of that's good so if this
says now that that's an opportunity
everywhere I'm totally behind that where
where I come
into some clarification that I need
starts in line 2 7even and goes to
32 uh I'll start with D municipalities
preventing manufactured housing uh shall
afford reasonable realistic
opportunities for the development I'm
paraphrasing in order to provide
opportunities lot size overall density
requirements of manufactured home parks
shall be
reasonable I'm afraid I'm afraid we
haven't added anything to the
conversation when you um when we go to
a potential developer goes to a
town and um they have many times old
zoning would have made lot size and
density to a point that it was not
favorable for any new
expansion
so I'm in favor but reasonable to these
towns is not reasonable to a developer
my second issue is when I go to 313 2
manufacturers opportunities for
expansion of manufactured housing
parks in full disclosure this was my
business for 30 plus years I developed
mobile home parks ran mobile home parks
uh manufactured home parks it's a proper
term I built manufactured home
subdivisions if there's a vacant I
totally agree that that if there's a
vacant lot in a uh in a park that they
should be able to reoccupy it and
shouldn't have to follow any new
standard I don't see that written here
and I don't interpret 31 and 32 what
what 31 and
32 um says to me as a
developer I have an existing Park I have
acreage that is alongside my Park
I would I would like to be able to
develop that Park as it was already
developed and not turn that into 200
foot of Road Frontage in a quarter acre
lot when the rest of the park that's
been there for 20 plus years is 40 feet
by 80 feet so am am I misunderstanding
and maybe you and I aren't the person
that should have this conversation and I
as a co-sponsor should be speaking with
with the people sitting at our table do
you do you see 31 and 32 in my way or
your way I see them in both
ways um and and I think what we're who
we're really waiting for is the star of
the show here Ben Frost who's been the
star of the day because I think he'll be
able to answer most of these questions
for
us I would uh I will uh defer thank you
okay thank you anyone
else thank you
um call
on rob the pece from New Hampshire
housing in support of the
bill oh we got a
twofer and uh don't worry I'm Rob dapas
but I'm just Ben's arm candy and I know
it
uh I'm the executive director of New
Hampshire housing for those who don't
know us we're an independent
self-supporting Corporation established
by state law uh we're here to support
this bill with the proposed amendment uh
I have letters in support of the
amendment and a side-by-side comparison
that been prepared uh between the
existing statute and the bill as it
would uh as it was is would be amended
uh very quickly uh manufactured housing
provides an important home ownership
option for those who might not otherwise
afford it it's an especially important
part of the housing landscape in New
Hampshire because it can be affordable
without public subsidy which is very
difficult to achieve with other housing
typologies uh modern manufactured
housing as a previous speaker said can
be attractive and efficient and as far
from the uh stigmatized image that many
people might have in their heads the
statute already requires uh reasonable
opportunities uh for the development of
manufactured housing uh we believe the
bill is amended uh clarifies that
requirement and uh and makes some key uh
but relatively modest improvements uh so
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on this and uh I or more likely Ben
would be happy to answer any
questions any
questions I'm seeing none oh we do is
this my opportunity that I've been
looking for there you go Pres mcney the
um so if if I could draw your attention
back to lines 27 to
and I would agree that this this form of
housing is is a is a great alternative
to many and it's coste
effective and it has evolved over the
years to be a much different product
than it was say in the 80s when I
started in on this I surprised say I'm
no longer in this business so it's not
that big a conflict
here I I have real problems with with
realistic opportunities I'm wondering
how you would feel when it comes down to
the requirements for manufactured
housing
Parks
um if there was mention of density being
in
compliance with uh subsurface
regulations or
something I'm I'm just saying that
subsurface
regulations if if a town has a in my
opinion an unreasonable regulation I'm
not so worried about the residential
lots because residential lots you comply
the residential lot my concern is
there's no opportunity to expand or
build more manufactured home parks and
there are there is a large segment of
the population that can afford to have
rent and have their you and have their U
plowing Lawns and everything else taken
care of but that buy in is very
expensive and I think there should
be in statute that on expansion of a of
a
property that reasonable should should
correlate to uh uh
regulations um and I'm spitballing
subsurface in the Water
Division um so you know they might be
able to add on 10 more units five more
units with their existing well
structure and uh if the soils are
favorable or if they were to buy a uh an
adjacent property and uh use that for
the purpose of septic Andor well that
they could continue on with the lot size
that was
originally developed for the
manufacturer and if I'm reaching too far
perhaps we'll come back to this next
time but I do not like reasonable
because having sat on zoning boards for
20 plus
years um and appearing before them all
the time I could tell you which towns
are not reasonable to start with so I'm
wondering your
thoughts uh thank you for the question
representative makoni um I think you're
you're right and listening to your
question earlier too um
about how much this does um the
amendment and I'm referring to Amendment
114h uh is really intended to um parse
out the existing law in a way that it is
readable um I've been doing this stuff
for 30 years and I have to
confess uh I've been reading this
statute wrong for
decades uh it was only last summer when
I was compelled to really dig into it
and
to look at it word by word that I
realized I've gotten it wrong see I was
looking at these three options as three
options and they're not it's really two
options a municipality either allows
manufactured housing on individual Lots
or in parks and
subdivisions those are the two choices
or I guess you you can allow all three
if you want I was looking at it as
individual Lots or Parks or subdivisions
and I think if I've been getting it
wrong I can only imagine how many other
people are getting it wrong too so I
wanted to ensure that there was some
clarity here there's also ambiguity in
the existing law and that is um with
regard to where it says in most but not
necessarily all land areas in District
zone to permit residential uses the
second instance where it says that it's
ambiguous as to whether it applies only
to um placement on individual Lots or
also to
parks and so this the amendment seeks to
clarify this and does clarify it meaning
it applies to all three
situations that's one of the purposes of
the amendment is to give Clarity to
local board members so they know how to
read this it's a tough statute to
understand
um and then as others have said uh the
the new language that is not currently
in the statute that is uh in E the
amendment starting on page one line 31
and going to the end uh that's new
language it acknowledges um the the idea
of expansion of existing parks and
representative Maki to get to your
question um the the notion of reasonable
and realistic is something that's in law
uh I think uh uh representative
Alexander correctly said it gives the
Judiciary the flexibility to interpret
uh and they do uh it is language that
also is in the workforce housing law
although the workforce housing law has a
little more flesh on the bones if you
will of what that
means um but if the committee wants to
think about this more expansively
we'd be very happy to work on an
amendment that would set down specific
criteria I think your idea of using Dees
subsurface Bureau standards for
development is a really good
one okay any any
questions representative
Ella thank you thank you for taking the
question so um your kind of testimony
I'm not sure if
uh your your testimony would be that
we're changing the rules as far as
manufactured uh kind of building on the
last speaker um
testimony that online six we are um
requiring manufactured housing you
previously said that the current law is
or with between manufactured housing and
housing parks and
subdivisions um
and we are changing that to ANS all the
way across you have to do housing and
housing parks and subdivisions all three
of them in your
municipality
um
it's is that a uh your interpretation
and if it is so that we're going to
require all three in the
municipality um why on line 9 and 10
does it say in Soul discretion because
they should just allow it in all three
they should just allow all three why why
in their so discretion what what does
that language mean to you I guess
representative ell with with respect I
think you've got it wrong okay um I I if
you look at the side by side that we
handed out that shows the existing
statute and on the the right column and
the language from Amendment 114h on the
left column you'll see on the on the
first page um going down the right
column where the where it says on
individual lots and most that's at the
end it says
or if you go across to the left column
it says or wait wait wait on at the end
of what
paragraph oh like three paragraphs down
okay yeah yeah um so it the it says or
there so on individual Lots or on
manufactured housing parks in man
manufactured housing parks
and manufactured housing subdivisions so
it's the current law and the amendment
both say on individual
Lots or in parks and
subdivisions and and this the
municipality's discretion is making the
choice between those two on individual
Lots or in parks and
subdivisions
can I follow
up thank you thank you um I was pointing
I was not pointing you to lines 15 and
12 I was uh on the amendment I was
pointing you to line six on the amend on
on the amendment where it says citing of
all three with ANS in between all of
them um and so
in in a like Roman Roman 1
a it's saying that you should do all
three of
them is
that is that not the interpretation of
that that line six I I I think you can
interpret it that way but then it is
followed by the very specific language
that says that the municipality shall
have the discretion to choose these
these options now okay just bear in
mind what what we're doing here is
taking the existing language of the
statute and and parsing it out if the
committee wants to change that we'd be
happy to make that Amendment as
well go thank you I would thank
you
that representative de Leno thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
you know I'm wondering if we're leaving
some ideas on the table by not
considering commercial land
and I say that
because I believe that there could be
opportunity in redevelop redeveloping
malls um I know that Newton mall right
now the lot the mall looks full look a
little closer all the cars there are
from car dealers so I I just I see the
death of malls and I think they could be
a wasteland but there could also be an
opportunity what are your thoughts on
that uh sure there are there certainly
are opportunities and we've seen one
proposed here and conquered with
steelgate Mall uh there so so to some
extent those sorts of things are
happening and there's been separate
legislation proposed that would address
the uh requirement to allow residential
uses in areas where that are zoned
commercial I guess that hasn't been part
of the conversation here that could be
part of allowing reasonable and
realistic opport ities for the
development of manufactured housing
parks and subdivisions in areas that are
Zone commercial but it's not not part of
the currently proposed
legislation okay anyone
else thank you represent Reed thank you
um so it's not I don't think it's
defined in this particular statute but I
was wondering about the definition and
I'm apologize because I was stepped out
um if someone already addressed this but
the definition of manufactured housing
and how it relates to modular prefab
quanito term and would it be appropriate
to use that larger umbrella term for all
of those things and have it all apply
here thank you for the question the the
um these are separate and distinct
things so manufactured housing is by by
statutory definition and it's
in I think the same statute uh 67431 or
32 uh it uh is defined as housing that
is built according to the federal code
that is thank you
Katie all right so six you know I said
67431 it is uh so that is housing that
is buil built according according to the
HUD code that was originally adopted in
19 74 uh so that is and it has specific
size standards uh I think 8T wide 32 ft
long
um we used to call them trailers now we
call them manufactured housing because
once they're moved into place they
typically don't ever move
again um modular is different because
it's not built like manufactured housing
on a chassis doesn't have a permanent
chassis modular is just a block a
building block if you will that is built
according to the residential code not
the federal H HUD code for manufactured
housing so modular housing or panelized
housing which is you know walls
pre-built and you assemble the walls
those are built according to the the
residential code they these are things
that
are um you know they both serve the
purpose of providing occupancy dwellings
for people to live in but they're built
Accord according to different codes and
should be treated different
ly follow what thank you for that answer
because I wasn't seeing the definition
but I presumed it was in RSA just not in
the RSA dealt with by the bill um are is
there a similar statute to this existing
one that says that towns should provide
reasonable opportunities for these other
types of
housing there there is another statute
representative uh that deals with
uh what's called pre-site built housing
and it is intended to
distinguish uh it from manufactured
housing so it captures both panelized
and modular housing uh that I think is
RSA
67431 a it's right around the same same
place in the statutes uh and uh I think
municipalities are required to allow
those because they're being built
according to the building code so they
the municip IP ality cannot treat a
modular or panelized home any
differently than a stick built home it's
built according to the building code
thank
you okay anyone else seeing none thank
you
gentlemen uh Ivy
van in support of the
bill
thank you representative barudi thank
you members of the community of the
committee I am here to speak in favor of
the bill um in my professional life I'm
a land use planner and I've been doing a
lot of work in small towns in New
Hampshire who have received Housing
Opportunity planning grants to see what
they can do to increase opportunities
for housing choice in those communities
one of the things that I have come up
against this past year while I've been
doing that work are uh Town ordinances
that discriminate against manufactured
housing and you know there's a long
whole long history of why they're there
but the fact is they are there and they
should go away um getting a town
individually to make those ordinances go
away is really hard it's a heavy lift I
am in favor of the statute although I
would go a little further I would
require I would have the statute say
towns shall allow manufactured housing
in any place that a stick built or
pre-site built residence is allowed
subject to the same um ordinance
requirements or of not or but and also
in parks and manufactured houses
subdivisions and that there shall be
reasonable accommodation for the
increase in size of manufactured housing
parks and subdivisions so that the towns
don't have the opportunity of saying
well we're complying because we said
that they could put them in Parks but
the statute the ordinance for the parks
in these towns is often so difficult
that they actually cannot be reasonably
increased in size so I recommend that
you take another stab at this relick
your calf as my father would say relick
your calf on this one and said just say
these are housing units and they shall
be allowed all the places than any other
housing unit can be allowed and also in
parks and
subdivisions and that's I'm happy to
take questions um but that's what I came
here to say okay representative
y thank you um I believe
you you misspoke when you were saying
that that that the sites the the housing
parks and subdivisions should
not regulate size I think you did you
mean to say reasonable accommodations
for density instead of like size okay
let me explain what I me
I meant if you are placing a
manufactured housing unit on a on a lot
not in a park not in a manufactured
housing subdivision if you are placing
that unit on a lot that you bought on
Elm Street that you have to comply with
whatever the rules are for putting a
single family house on a lot on Elm
Street with your terms of your setbacks
your frontages your Frontage requirement
whatever your parking requirements are
that's the rule if you're just placing
it on a lot if you're placing it in a
manufactured housing park or subdivision
then the rule there should be there that
the town should allow reasonable
increase in size of manufactured housing
parks and subdivisions and the creation
of new ones does that
help the parks and sub parks and
subdivisions get to make their own rules
about how big the lots are but single
family houses don't
right thanks you kept on saying the
parks should be able to decide uh or the
park should have uh a size and I was
trying to get
clarifying information about what size
you were talking about as far as the
parks no that's sorry that I was
confusing no what I what I mean is there
should be parks and manufactured housing
subdivisions they should be allowed to
get bigger and you should be able to
create a new one um and and you should
also be able to put a manufactured
housing unit on any single family lot in
the
town okay I'll that anyone
else representative mcon yep thank you
thank you Mr
chairman okay we're on the same page I
figured we were the uh and I I believe I
heard you add a little language on
3132 that I liked uh municipality shall
allow reasonable realistic opportunities
for expansion manufactured housing Parks
existing did you then suggest or new I
did what was what was your language on
um what I think I said is municipalities
shall be required to allow manufactured
housing units on any single family lot
or in uh manufactured housing Parks or
manufactured housing subdivisions there
the town shall allow for the increase in
of a manufactured housing park or
subdivision and the creation of new one
of of new manufactured housing Parks or
subdivisions because what I do see is
I've seen more than once where the towns
kind of skirt this by saying well we've
got an existing manufactured housing
Park so we're good we don't have to do
anything else and that is not helpful in
terms of housing people I do also think
that a big part of this is going to be
um explaining and
educating um local municipalities about
what manufactured housing is and what it
looks like and why it's important
because I still have people telling me
that if you buy a manufactured housing
unit it depreciates like a car well no
it doesn't it did before the adoption of
the HUD rules in
1976 but it is no longer
true thank you okay anyone else
representative
Reed thank you thank you for taking my
question and it's good to see you back
um so I have a would you believe
followed up with a request sure would
you believe that when I spoke to my
previous not my current Town planner
about some overly restrictive
ordinances when I was saying we need to
do something about the housing crisis
and this was four years ago before the
housing crisis was as bad as it is now
my then Town planner said oh we already
do enough for those people they have the
trailer
parks those that's an exact quote to
which I said I am one of those people um
and the the request is because I
completely agree as we already heard
from New Hampshire housing um that other
types of kind of unconventional housing
modular prefab are have to be treated
the same as stick built and it makes no
sense to treat manufactured housing
differently would you be willing to get
this committee because I did take notes
on everything you said but I would
prefer it if it came straight from you
get this committee your yeah suggested
Amendment yes I certainly can do that
and you know I'm speaking as a person
who spent this first eight years of her
W life in a single wide friends and
neighbors not even a double wide um I
think that it's high time we stopped
uh assuming that manufactured housing is
and the people who live in it are
somehow less than because they're not
we're
not okay thank you okay anyone else
everybody set well thank you very
much and now we'll call on Alisa
molan housing action New Hampshire and
support of the
bill
thank you representative perui and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Alyssa margolin I serve as
director of housing action New Hampshire
we're a Statewide Coalition of 80
organizations United to improve state
and federal policy so everyone in New
Hampshire has a place to call home um I
um have declined to testify on prior
bills just because of time and knowing
that we've had access to working with so
many of you since you started uh your
work um as a special committee I do just
want to take this opportunity to
publicly thank you um I think we were
all wondering what was going to come of
this effort and you have um shown um a
a a patience a knowledge a breadth and a
depth in order to really understand this
issue and to propose real solutions and
I think before you what we had heard was
that there was maybe an opportunity to
clean up the manufactured housing RSA so
that it was more consistent with the
workforce housing law and you want to go
even further and so we would just like
to say that we would support you in that
obviously it's a really important part
of diverse housing stock um and really
important part of Workforce Housing
Solutions and so we look forward to
working with your committee on this and
a lot of other proposals and that
concludes my
testimony okay thank you any questions
representative
yel thank you thank you for for your uh
testimony would
you have concerns about going further um
as as kind of the questions kind of
indicate um in
that uh that that have you seen or have
you felt any push back as far as uh as
far as you know going further and saying
like no you have to have this in new
places or or allow new parks or
something like that are you fear fearful
or um that going further might
jeopardize you know some cleanup that
needs to happen as far as that or do you
think that you haven't heard significant
push back and and and welcome such such
um expansion yes so um quick answers
will welcome the expansion I will say
that our members are those who develop
manage and finance affordable housing
properties Supportive Housing properties
um push back we know it like you know
like we it's it's what we do um and to
the extent we're asking our state policy
makers to really help us with that to to
to um strengthen state law so that we're
facing less confrontation at the local
level and then we could um meet this
market demand and um and provide
manufactured homes for those who want it
Supportive Housing for people who need
uh homes plus Services Workforce housing
all of it so um I wouldn't hesitate to
to dig in and and go deeper here thank
you okay anyone else thank you very
much and the last cut I have is Karen
Susie who's in support of the
bill good morning morning Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Karen Susi I work at shenin Capital
group and I'm here behalf excuse me this
very on behalf of the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association uh we
represent the manufacturers the
installers uh Park owners
lenders insurers uh we do support this
bill today um I'm not sure that it goes
far enough uh I know there's been some
discussion about whether or not towns do
discriminate against manufactured
housing and Parks um unfortunately that
is our experience that they
do we've experienced um a park down in
Salem they purchased an adjacent lot to
expand um and of course after that
purchase they were denied the ability to
expand um years back there was another
municipality um a park wanted to expand
near conquered and they were told that
in order to do so they would have to
have a twoot minimum
within that
Park excuse me to Aca thank you very
much apologize um so these things do
exist exist and that is one way that
towns get around having to allow
this okay um representative Calla thank
you
um thank you for your testimony and
taking this question um you kind of
hinted at maybe some way that we could
move this legislation a little bit more
forward maybe not allowing them to
require two acre lots for the for the
thing but is there anything um else that
specifically you think uh municipalities
or anyone is discrimination
discriminating against that we could use
to uh in this bill to go further if the
committee was willing to do that other
than you know saying you can't do two
acre lot requirements for housing Parks
no that is an issue um of course and
it's not just an issue for manufactured
homes but I think we see in other towns
that they have of course the minimum lot
standards you know it's minimum size
standards for their lots and so who's
going to purchase a manufactured home
that is you know minimal in size and put
it on 4 acres to 10 acres I mean that's
another way that you're you're zoning
this population out of your
town okay uh we'll start M
representative
Gibb thank you and thank you for taking
my question um and this is almost a
would you believe but not
quite
um how could anyone argue that a
two-acre lot within a two-acre lot
requirement within a manufactured
housing Park could be
reasonable do you have any idea how they
could argue that no I
don't I've been
inter thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question for your testimony um
you may not be the right person to ask
but um is it accurate to say as I
suspect that it is better for a town to
have residents who own their home even
if those homes are manufactured homes uh
despite whatever stigma people may have
against manufactured homes it's better
for the residents to own their home
rather than be renters which is what
they would be forced into if they
weren't able to have a manufactured
home I would agree um certainly it's
still the most right now it's the most
affordable form of housing in the state
of newshire whether you like it or not I
mean
representative
mcney thank you Mr chairman um in you
bring up the same issue that I do about
uh expansion and now having to go by the
latest standard which would be
unreasonable uh would you think it might
make sense to incorporate in this
language we spoke with uh the other
gentleman earlier that perhaps tying in
uh density using subsurface and Water
Division yeah certainly something to
consider okay thank
you okay anyone oh
representative Damon thank you thank you
for Tak my
question so we're in a room full of
people
who predominantly
support this bill and I apologize for
speaking for everyone you didn't all say
that but I think it's the consensus and
other measures to improve housing access
and
quantity and we're going to bring
something forward to the legislature
which is a much more diverse population
and different
perspectives I'm wondering what you or
anyone else might provide in terms
of approaches and ways that we help
people understand that this is not only
needed because every everyone will give
lip service to saying we need to address
housing but how do we make it appealing
to people who are reticent to do this
just a small
question um it's difficult I think you
know unfortunately there is always that
stigma you know that you know it's a a
lower form of housing you know it's it's
again Ivy Ben spoke perfectly when she
said said you know everything's been
ramped up with HUD Energy Efficiency
everything like that um so people tend
to look back and think oh these are your
70s homes that fall apart right um and
that of course if you have a park you're
going to bring in you know five children
for a manufactured home it's going to
you know drain our education system um
so unfortunately that's all education
that you're going to have to do at the
local level and I would probably start
with the New Hampshire Municipal
Association they might of course have a
better how
perfect come on up
n but I mean I would think that they
would certainly be in the best position
to be able to
educate their
members okay anyone
else yeah
who
card
okay
um
M
friend
okay okay you get sorry about
that hi I'm M friedricks um and I'm
representing myself um
I uh support this bill but I wonder if
the committee might consider an
amendment um because um my understanding
is that manufactured housing can be a
really positive opportunity for families
um if they own their own home it
provides all those benefits of home
ownership such as stability as well as
um the ability to to grow that as an
asset um but if it is located on a um
park that is not cooperatively owned um
and that has a
uh a landlord who is um not particularly
responsible or is uh is really looking
to just make a return on investment then
we've seen in some other states across
the country that the rental prices for
that land um can really become another
housing crisis issue um and so I would
encourage the committee to look to other
states um and consider perhaps an
amendment that would um provide greater
benefit to manufactured housing
communities that are owned as
cooperatives where residents truly are
have a home ownership model um and and
really benefit in our knot um because
the the difficulty of of owning a home
um that then is fixed on a you know on a
piece of land if you don't own the land
is that you really can't have a choice
of moving mean you own the home but now
whatever the landlord is charging for
that land the rent on that land you're
paying um and that's why Roc um my
understanding is that's why um rock New
Hampshire got started and why rock you
know um is taking that to a national
level so so please consider um you know
favoring uh a home ownership model um in
this legislation and and I'd encourage
the committee to look more into that
issue um and consider how to work with
rock on some of that wording or um what
could be done to really encourage that
uh cooperatively owned um Park
model thank you very much for your
time okay any
questions okay seeing
none uh
Roy
wner did you press the button thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm Roy schwe from conquered I
just wanted to respond to a couple
things people have said as far as uh the
idea of owning a mobile home or a
modular home and not the land under it I
see that as a real problem because I
remember when the rent for a lot was $50
a month now it's 500 a month and more
there seems to be no limit as to what
they can charge you and has been said
you really have no method of moving it
anywhere else and so I think that we
need to you know if we're going to
encourage the development of uh mobile
homes and modu homes we need to find
some way of I hate to say rent control
because I know that's not going to fly
in the state but some way of keeping you
know lot affordable I know a person that
owned
a mobile home the rent in the lot kept
going up and up and they finally
committed suicide they just couldn't
handle all the expenses so you know I
think it's a good idea and I'll give you
an example if any of you people are
familiar with where Walmart and Market
Basket are at exit 20 in Tilton that
used to be a mobile home park but guess
what Walmart and Market Bas and whoever
decides the land is more valuable to
them I still don't know where all those
people
went and the second thing I wanted to
say is regards of places that are trying
to zone out
uh modular homes one of them is
conquered they are proposing a new
zoning ordinance it's trying to
eliminate the you know stuff on a chaty
like trailers and only allow the uh more
expensive ones you know that are set on
a foundation so I think that you know
that's a real issue if you want to
be expansive you need to say no you
cannot you know eliminate the chassis
built ones just because they may look
tacky because they may be less expensive
and the last thing is I think you really
need to consider what communities have
done already I think it's more important
to apply some pressure to communities
that don't have any modular home parks
than some that already have so many you
know we don't need to have communities
that are 100% modular homes we need to
allow them to upgrade their housing and
at the same time allow some of the
communities that have none to add them
so maybe if you could fit something in
if you do not have any yet it's easier
to build one than if you already have
half the town in them thank you okay
thank you any
questions all right thank you very much
much
um I'm not sure the first name but
Grace Neil okay
Neil oh okay thank thank you Mr chair
all right I'm sorry about that no
worries uh my handwriting is terrible n
GES with the municipal
Association um since we were we were
called upon I will comment um the
amendment that representative Alexander
offered today uh
0114 um in looking at the comparison
between that and and the existing law um
It Is by and large um just a
reformulation of the existing law um
except for Section e which which now
provides for reasonable realistic
opportunity for expansion of
manufactured housing Parks as I believe
the committee has already heard that
just reflects um what the legislature
has done with Workforce
housing um as far as any position on
um that proposed amendment we don't have
one um I've heard several other proposed
amendments today uh we would likely
object to any of those should the
committee consider them um and I guess
there are a couple things I want to
point out I think the committee's heard
some pretty mixed uh information about
uh manufactured home communities and
whether they're of the effects they have
on residence I'm I'm not the expert on
it but I understand that Professor
Esther
Sullivan of um I don't remember what
university um but she wrote a book
called manufactured in security mobile
home parks in America's tenuous rights
to place which
discusses um effectively how
manufactured home parks work obviously
there are a couple of different models
um one of them is the residents own the
park um they're in control of their own
lot rent rents and the other option is
that some Corporation typically owns the
lot um and charges lot rents um
obviously when we're talking about
people living in manufactured homes
we're often talking about lower income
individuals they often don't have the
financial capacity to pay to move their
their home so even if they are
technically movable they can't afford
that um so as a result if they own those
homes they're subject to whatever the
lot rent is if they don't own that
property the problem is is that that
creates a monopoly situation where they
have to continue to pay for that lot
rent because otherwise they're out of a
home and they may not be able to um and
we've seen that and I've certainly
you've heard testimony today about how
that
occurs and so you end up with renters In
This Very tenuous situation who who are
paying substantial portions of their
income to um corporations to hedge funds
in particular um who've capitalize this
over the past couple
decades so I think the committee should
be aware of that that's a serious
concern um certainly um it's a policy
consideration as you going forward and
it affects municipalities because we're
the ones responsible for things like
local welfare so we're the ones who have
to provide Aid if they are not able to
afford that um um so that does concern
us um the other thing I want to mention
is that communities have started to use
tools like land value capture that's
something that um is promoted by places
like the Lincoln Institute for um the
Lincoln Institute which which covers
land policy um and a lot of that focuses
on promoting zoning options that focus
on increasing density on mixed use um
especially in core urban areas but
expanding out from that which allows you
to leverage that density to lower costs
overall for things for provisions of
things like public water and sewer and
Roads because you have more people in a
smaller space paying for that um and you
know if the real were here today and I'm
not sure if they've already testified on
this but they would tell you that they
did some surveys that Americas prefer
Americans prefer walkable communities
that appears that is something that I
think planners Statewide and Nationwide
are aiming to help communities move
toward but we're not there yet when
we're talking about a community like a
manufactured home Community that's a
single use Community um when we're
talking about best use of land that's
not necessarily the best use of land in
all areas of the municipality it may be
a good use of land some places but not
necessarily everywhere um so that's just
some information I want to provide the
committee I'm happy to answer any
questions okay any question
questions no oh representative re thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um so I'm I'm thank you for
raising the issue of and I apologies if
I'm over reaching in my description but
essentially predatory lot rents by
owners of parks
um if and again I understand that you do
you can't really speak outside of what
you've been authorized to to present but
to the best as you're able would it be
um would it would it address the issue
if if there's an amendment that's saying
you have to allow um manufactured homes
in single lots and parks and
subdivisions to to um amend that to say
cooperatives for parks and subdivisions
rather than allowing for the single
ownership because if you're forcing
towns to allow them across the board
then because as I understand the law
right now is giving towns the option
either to allow it here or to allow it
in in lots and if you're forcing them
across the board then we're still saying
well the the town has to allow these
potentially predatory owners of of parks
and so by refining it to they have to
allow cooperatives but not necessarily
the other would that address the issue
that you
raised I'm not sure how to answer that
question um I'm not the person to
Advocate on kind of that area
specifically um what I will say is you
know under current law um municipalities
have to provide reasonable opportunities
to site um manufactured homes so um that
would be a change
um
yeah okay representative M
mcney thank you Mr chairman
um currently uh currently in law if
there's a manufactured home park and
that Park comes up for sale and it has
residency in it then the residents are
offered the opportunity to purchase the
property at the price that was being
sold at so there there's a mechanism
there um I I need to say
that people that own parks are not all
predators people wanting to develop
parks are not Predators the
developers could see a business model
that makes
sense and providing an
opportunity uh for more housing units
some places it's seasonal
housing uh some of those places are
homeownership um I would not be in favor
of language that just said Co-op but
would you at least agree that not all
developers are predatory and that own
mobile home
parks just to clarify I didn't mean to
imply that if that's what the committee
heard I I did not hear you say that sir
I I certainly couldn't impute intentions
for anyone um I was just reporting that
information that has come to me uh what
you do with that is up to you follow up
I I use you as a sound board and I
apologize for that they um would there
was discussion earlier about expanding
allowing
expansion and in the words
reasonable uh are you opposed with
municipality you'd have to see an
amendment but are you are you opposed to
at least saying uh to certain standards
being subsurface Andor water at least
Del laying U some groundwork I'd be
happy to work on any any sort of
amendment um I think you know as long as
we're taking into consideration of the
needs for subsurface water Etc I think
that is probably a reasonable compromise
we can come to thank you
sir anyone else represent your col thank
you there was there was some um some
discussion about the um
allowing
manufactured housing everywhere that
other housing is allowed do you believe
that municipality should have the right
to discriminate as ver the method of the
housing or or or do you think that you
know if it meets all the other
requirements of the housing that that
that it should you know whether it's
single bit uh uh stick built or
manufactured that as long as they meet
those same requirements it it should be
it's able the that you would not oppose
them uh the state uh saying that these
should be equal treated equally by the
municipality or you think that they
should be able to
discriminate my understanding is
existing law requires them to provide
reasonable opportunities for
manufactured housing and most
municipalities have interpreted this in
a way to
allow either option as long as it fits
within existing zoning I don't have a
I'm personally don't have a full know
know of this area so there may be
experts from the state who you could ask
um who would provide more information
but I that's my understanding of how
that has been interpreted based on what
my members have told me okay thank you
very
much he having no more cards we're going
to close the hearing now on House Bill
1399 I don't
know I
think
all
all right thank you for being patient
with us um we're going to I lost my
schedule
house pill 1399 I'd like to um open the
public hearing on house pill or house
pill 1399 and call on the prime sponsor
represent mck Williams and um I've
received quite a bit of pain cards
recently so at this point if you're not
the prime sponsor of the bill I'm going
to ask that you keep your remarks within
two minutes and if you're a member of
the committee maybe consider not asking
would you believe the questions and just
asking questions that you would like to
know the answer to thank
you relate to the
bill that relate directly to the Bill
thank
you thank you chair Alexander um it's a
pleasure to be here my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I
represent South conquered um that
actually encompasses this area right
here where you are sitting you are in my
district um so it's a pleasure to host
you today um I am in my day job an
architect attorney I've been involved in
uh development projects in New Hampshire
for about 10 years and I'm very
passionate about expanding access to
housing for everyone in New Hampshire I
think uh what this committee is charged
with is a noble goal and I hope that we
are able to work together to come up
with some solutions preferably Creative
Solutions the architect and me loves
Creative Solutions um so uh we're
passing out an amendment right now this
is the Reed McWilliams amendment to
House Bill
1399 uh this takes in a little bit of
conversation and change to the base bill
so if you don't have amendment to HB
1399 um let's make sure that you get a
copy and they're going
around they're over there
okay we'll pass them
out for like the public if they want to
see there's a bunch yeah okay yeah
there's a lot of
them thank you so much let's make sure
everyone's looking at the same things so
there's no question questions
referencing back to the uh as introduced
I want to make sure that we're talking
about Amendment U and the actual number
I'm going to have you hold on for a
second do you not have a copy of the
amendment okay can we get representative
makoni a copy of the amendment
please EXC all right we are organized we
are ready to go thank you um all right
so the amendment is 202
24444 H just so everyone's looking at
the same piece of paper
um so uh the intent here and just to
give a little bit of History um is to
come up with a way to allow more than
one unit on areas that have been zoned
as single family provided they meet
specific criteria uh if you if you were
engaged last year we had a pretty big
debate about the fourplex is a house
bill which was allowing up to four units
on single family zoning and I I would
say that my takea away from that bill
was that the appetite for four units may
be a little bit too much so if we dial
it back to two units let's see if we can
be realistic with the checklist criteria
for allowing two units um in what is
otherwise considered single family
residential zoning um so that is the
intent here is to be allowed to increase
uh if you already own a house or if you
are purchasing a house and it's on a lot
under 2 Acres right um and this needs to
be allowed within your town or city for
at least
50% of all all Lots in a municipality
zone for single family residential so if
you live in a small town with mostly
single family residential then at least
50% of that would need to allow this um
you would be allowed as a owner of this
uh house or purchaser of the house or
someone who owns a lot and wants to do
this Construction proess project you can
expand a single family residence to no
more than two residential
units um if you meet the following
checklist of criteria and these are all
sort of negotiated points taking in
input from all kinds of
participants uh the first is that the
proposed housing would not require
demolition or alteration of housing
subject to covenants ordinances or law
that restricts rents to affordable
housing or persons of families of mar
low or very low income so if you're
already in a community and that this
house is subject to those types of
restrictions then you would already be
out your proposal to go to two units
won't work um second piece of that is if
this is already housing that you've
either purchased or you currently own
and it's been occupied by a tenant in
the last three years uh that's housing
that we really don't want to start
disrupting or changing and so therefore
you are out so those two pieces if
you're subject to those you can't go to
two
units um the next uh number two in the
bill this is line 14 uh the proposed
Housing Development does not allow
demolition of more than 25% of existing
exterior structural walls unless the
Housing Development meets at least one
of the following conditions which are
the exceptions so 25% of your exterior
walls would mean that if you have four
exterior walls and the building is a
perfect square and plan you can only
blow out one of those of the four
exterior walls so let's just say it's a
20 20 20 20 square 20 ft on each side
you can only blow out one of those 20ft
walls so that would mean that you can't
be expanding on two sides um unless
you've got an exception so the
exceptions to the
25% demo is if a local ordinance so
allows so there may be some local
ordinances that will let you do more
than 25% demo or the site has not been
occupied by a tenant in the last three
years so once again if either of those
are um the case then you can get past
the 25% demolition limit uh Point number
three the development is not located
within a historic district or is
designated or listed as a state or
national landmark or historic property
so if your town has taken the effort of
designating national landmark historic
historic district Etc then you are out
your property cannot have this second
unit Point number four development is
located outside side of Hazard areas as
identified by either a hazard risk map
or a risk factor rating of minimal for
flood and fire risk uh so once again you
are allowed to do your second unit but
you need to be outside of a hazard risk
area so uh we've been having some
flooding on the Sea Coast there are some
concerns about future development in
areas that are already heavily flooding
uh and so with that in mind uh something
like that would probably fall outside of
the ability to put in a second unit
because of your current current concerns
about
flooding uh so then we go on to say
notwithstanding any local ordinance or
bylaw and except as provided in the
earlier paragraph Tob your planning
board May impose objective zoning
subdivision and design review standards
that don't conflict with this paragraph
So some examples of that may be um side
yard setbacks front yard setbacks things
that they already have on the books for
having to conform to how big your
structure is uh most towns and cities
that have requirement we'll say it can't
be more than 2 and a half stories or 35
ft all of these things can and do still
apply so you can't just come in and do
your second unit and go up five stories
you won't would not be able to do that
because there may be a local ordinance
that limits that and that still
stands um going to 2A line 29 the
planning board shall not impose
objective zoning subdivision and
objective design review standards that
would have the effect of physically
precluding construction of up to two
units and being at least a th000 square
feet in floor area so you can't prevent
the construction of the two units and a
th000 square feet in floor area provided
it meets the checklist we just went
through and doesn't get kicked out from
any of those
criteria so you've got an existing house
and you want to add your second unit and
you haven't gotten kicked out yet we're
on the second page line one not
notwithstanding sub paragraph b2a no
setback shall be required for an
existing structure or a structure
constructed in the same location and to
the same dimensions as an existing
structure so your grandfathered in if
you've already got this uh Victorian
that's built right up to the lot line um
in a downtown site you're not going to
be forced to have a setback if you're
adding in um another
unit moving on not withstanding that
paragraph above all other circumstances
not described in uh the previous
discussion about planning and zoning a
planning board may require a setback of
up to 4 F feet from the side and rear
lot lines so if there isn't one now the
the planning board may add one in and
say we need that 4 foot offset from side
and rear lot lines so in addition to the
conditions established a planning board
may require any of the following
conditions when considering application
for two residential units as provided
for in this section um a planning board
may require that there's off street
parking for up to one space per unit so
if you already have a pretty small lot
let's say we got a downtown quarter acre
lot there's an existing house there's a
teeny tiny little driveway and you'd
like to put a little bump out in the
back to do your second unit there can be
a requirement for off street parking for
one space per unit so you'll need to
figure out where to get that extension
of the driveway for the second parking
space for the second unit and then of
course um we had all kinds of discussion
about the four PLU is a house bill what
do we do about Wastewater um and
specifically for cities and towns that
have Wastewater issues and cannot handle
the capacity that they currently are
dealing with um so this is a discussion
and a plan for how to deal with
Wastewater
concerns so obviously if you don't have
a city sewer City Water um it's a
different test than if you do for
example residential units connected to
an on-site wastewater treatment system a
perk test completed within 5 years can
be required by the town or if the perk
test has been recertified within the
last 10 years we're not trying to create
an undue burden to someone who has an
existing house and wants to add a second
unit but we do want to make sure that
the water is still good um if the
municipality is proven through
engineering study that it does not have
adequate Water and Sewer city of NASA
and to allow this development two units
may be disallowed by the planning board
for a term of up to 10 years but after
the expiration of that term it must be
allowed so it gives a period of time for
a city or town to get their act together
and make sure that they're still
allowing housing to happen there but
they've got a 10e stay from that would
be from the term of 10 years the
intention here is from the time the
applicant requests the second unit so
they're sort of a rolling clock you've
got to get your act together in 10 years
to allow that um but I I understand that
there are some cities and towns where
it's just not possible right now to do
additional uh
units so not withstanding the subar
paragraph a a planning board may deny a
proposed Housing Development if the
building official makes a written
finding based upon a preponderance of
the evidence that the proposed housing
development project under this paragraph
would have a specific adverse impact
upon public health and safety or the
physical environment and for which there
is no feasible method to satisfactorily
mitigate or avoid that specific adverse
impact and certainly we've seen some
concerns in The Lakes Region when it
comes to septic sewage um issues with
dealing with an additional unit and the
strain that that may cause especially if
there is no um there's no town or city
provided sewer um and so we don't want
to be creating issues with green algae
in our beautiful lakes and
ponds that's just an example I'm sure
there are many other things that towns
may find that are specific to them so a
planning board may require that a rental
of any unit created pursuant to this
paragraph be for a term longer than 30
days we've received concerns about
short-term rentals I know Conway just
had a big lawsuit last year about
finding short-term rentals and what that
means for development in the town uh and
so really uh we're allowing the towns to
push for if you're doing a second unit
it can't be a short-term
rental um and finally application shall
not be rejected solely because it
proposes adjacent or connected
structures provided that the structures
meet building codes safety standards and
are sufficient to allow separate
conveyance um so obviously if you're
doing something that the town officials
may be concerned about fire code uh or
other safety standards then there would
be a conversation about making sure that
you meet those requirements uh but it
can't be rejected out of hand just
because of those concerns there needs to
be a way to still get your second
unit uh at the end a municipality may
require that any or all residential
units built under the terms of this
section shall meet the definition of
Workforce housing uh RSA 674 colon 58
Roman 4 as it pertains to rental housing
and shall meet the definition of
affordable in RSA 674 col 58 Romans 1 a
municipality may require restrictive
covenant to be recorded in the registry
of deeds to enforce compliance with
these definitions and so this allows
cities and towns that really do want to
start putting in a percentage goal for
affordable housing to say all right if
we're going to allow a second unit and
50% of our residential zoning we want to
make sure that that is definitely
Workforce housing um so that is the
amendment and I'm absolutely happy to
answer questions I understand understand
that this is a bit of a change from the
initial proposal but I think that it's
pretty well negotiated and discussed
with the stakeholders so I'm open for
questions okay I'm gonna um start off
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative MC Williams
um assuming I followed you correctly uh
this proposal would allow a total of two
units where there had previously been
one under various circumstances you have
described so my questions are how does
that relate first of all to the existing
uh accessory D accessory dwell leg unit
statute and then how does it relate to
House Bill
1291 which would allow a total of three
units thank you very much for the
question I'll start with the first one
um the intent here with this bill is to
allow you to take an existing house and
either put an addition ition on it or
subdivide it let's just say it naturally
lends itself to having a second
staircase and the upper portion of it to
be a separate unit um that truly is its
own apartment and address we're not
calling it an accessory dwelling unit
we're calling it unit number two uh and
so there are probably people who are way
better at explaining this than me who
will testify after me about this but the
intent here is to make it um an actual
unit as opposed to accessory unit um and
so I want it to be addressed distinctly
and differently um in terms of your
second question about the three unit
bill um I'm not as familiar with that so
I'm probably not going to be able to do
you justice on comparing the two but I'm
happy to send an email afterwards when
I've had some time to digest it thank
you represent
Kell thank you
um thank you for uh your detailed
presentation as we just got the language
in front front of us
um my cons uh I guess what if
anything um or do you have the concerns
as far as accessory like when we have
put in the laws like requiring accessory
dwelling units and you can have you have
to be able to allow them in certain
situations etc etc um
municipalities essentially took that as
a blueprint of this is when we're going
to allow accessory
dwellings um do you have that same
concern that municipalities who may
currently allow
duplexes um could take this law and say
okay you can have duplexes if you meet
all of these criteria and that's the
only time that you can have duplexes
essentially making
it way harder than it currently is to
have duplicates um
do do you see anything in this that
would say like you know there's this is
in addition to um you know your current
like transferring one one singles you
know uh family dwelling into multif
family or is this just a blueprint for
eliminating
duplexes thank you so much for the
question um so I was very specific um on
line six page one of the amendment where
we talk about zoned for single family
residences right so we're really talking
about um R1 single family zoning
generally uh and so if you have duplexes
already in single family residential it
may have been rezoned to get there um
but the intent here is to stretch single
family to Encompass plus one if we meet
all the checklist criteria um in terms
of of being able to do duplexes uh right
if you wanted to do a mirrored two equal
units on a lot that's zoned single
family residential this would allow that
to happen you could purchase a lot
single family residential that meets all
the checklist criteria and construct a
duplex side by side or top and bottom
either way um because it meets the
criteria and it's two units so it's
basically stretching single family
residential with all the criteria met
for 50% of the lot in the municipality
to allow that duplex to happen but I'm
not saying it has to be a duplex because
the size of the second unit is left
intentionally vague but you can always
do at least a th000 square feet right
because we're allowing a th000 square
feet on line 31 you could obviously do
more if it's allowed under the base
zoning right in terms of lot area um
total footprint of the building um sidey
yard setbacks all the other constraints
you have to work with when you're doing
uh a renovation addition new
construction you still have those same s
uh site
requirements um but I think the purpose
here is not so much about saying new
construction duplexes the purpose here
is you get another unit if you meet the
criteria so I hope that answers your
question but I'm happy to take it
followup if it
doesn't I have a different question
please be as brief as possible thank
you
um
when on line one it says um at least 50%
of the Lots in a municipality zone for
single family
residences
um or a line line six 5 to six sorry um
the which Lots is the 50% are are you
imagining a Zone created by the
municipality that these are the 50% or
are you just like like the first 50%
that apply or how how is that 50% are
you imagining that uh you know to that's
that's a great question um I think that
it's sort of self selecting and I say
that because we have an awful lot of
things that kick you out right we have
um the issues with covenants ordinance
restricting rent um affordable housing
right so if you already have an
affordable
housing rule on the books then that
single family housing Zone with
affordable housing is already out so for
your town that piece is not part of the
50% Target that we need to achieve right
so it's sort of self- selecting um and
the same thing with if you have a
historic district that's also single
family residential that piece is out of
the 50% already so you have to look
elsewhere to get to the 50%
goal
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
in relation to both representative yella
and representative Gibbs questions it is
my understanding and my question is is
this correct in your understanding that
the difference here between this bill
and the upcoming Adu bill which is mine
um is that this bill because this
committee has heard extensive uh
presentation on the benefit of duplexes
and the fact that they are um unfairly
zoned out and we we need more duplexes
in the state they are part of that
missing middle that was referenced
earlier and so that this would allow
duplexes which are different from adus
because for a couple things one they
aren't restricted to the size that adus
are restricted to and um two um your
bill would specifically allow developers
to develop it whereas the Adu law as it
exists will allow allows municipalities
to limit to owner
occupants thank you so much for the
layup yes and
yes um and and I think it's really
important to distinguish that the intent
here is to get to missing middle housing
and and the the purpose here is that we
want to make sure you can have two units
where otherwise it would only be one
unit and won only ever be one unit but
we're sort of piercing the veil of
single family residential and allowing
it to be to once it meets all these
criteria for
50%
briefly please briefly is it also your
understanding that uh while the
underlying bill as introduced said that
all the Lots would allow this extra unit
to be built essentially creating
potentially a duplex that um the reason
the amendment amends it down to all lots
of two acres and in any case at least
50% was to allow the towns to protect
agricultural areas um which may be
beneficial from an environmental
standpoint thank you for the question
yes agricultural is certainly a concern
I would also add our Timber lots to that
as well um we have an awful lot of green
space in New Hampshire that we want to
preserve and certainly we do have other
things that are priorities in the
checklist like historic districts um and
uh uh special areas for affordable
housing so thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you um I have a question on
a different subject than
earlier uh where it says um uh that uh
the development is not located within a
historic district or is designated or
listed uh as a landmark or historic
property um that sounds like uh you
can't do it if it's located within a
historic district but you can do it if
it's designated um as a landmark or
historic property did you mean not in a
historic district and not designated a
Landmark thank you so much for the
question uh when we look at this is line
19 uh parentheses 3 and
parenthesis we're going all the way back
up to line eight where it says if the
proposed Housing Development meets all
of the following requirements so if you
jump from line 8 to line 19
we're reading this as if the proposed
Housing Development meets all the
following requirements and this one is
uh number three the development is not
located within a historic district or is
and it should say not that was my
question designated or listed as a state
or national landmark or historic
property so that should say not it
should say not because obviously we're
not looking to to preclude listed or
State national landmark or historic
property yes thank you
any other questions representative
makoni thank you Mr chairman if um turn
your attention to page two line
seven uh C in addition to any conditions
established in accordance with
subparagraph I wish I could read as fast
as you uh
representative um a planning board may
require any of the following conditions
when considering an application for two
residential units and I item 11 uh item
number two on 11 says for residential
units connected to an on-site wastewater
treatment system a septic system I
believe is what we're is proposed to a
municipality yep a percolation test
completed within the last five years if
the percolation test has been
recertified within 10 years what what
are you telling me in that language
because I I think you need some work and
I'd be willing to help or or send you to
subsurface absolutely um the intent here
is that you have existing septic already
and you know you're adding another unit
so we need to do a perk test for your
existing septic or provide the perk test
within the last five years or if it's
older than that it's been recertified
within the last 10 years to show that
you can handle the uh increased demand
and this is allowing the municipality to
request the perk test if they want it I
if if I could I I might suggest that you
look at that language I think you you
need to talk about a uh an Adu is
allowed by right but you have to you
have to have a um a in-pocket
subsurface approval for the septic
system in the event that the current
system fails it's a septic system and a
permit but for subsurface not a perk
test a perk test uh being a practitioner
a perk test is just digging a hole and
seeing what the soil is I I think I
think you want to some somehow
substitute in there that meets current
subsurface regulations I don't I don't
think the Department's going to be as
forgiving as they were with adus so um
the towns are going to want to know
subsurface going to want to know that it
can handle that additional
flow love it if there is to help yes
thank you very much if there's
additional feedback we'll definitely be
having a work session on this and I will
invite up represent MC Williams to chat
with the committee about that um are
there any other questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none thank you thank you
so if there's someone here
from yes can you fill out a pink card
please maybe it's in
here um if there is anyone here that is
specifically testifying on 1291 I
overestimated or underestimated how much
time these hearings would take um and i'
prefer not to make uh General Court
staff stay here past 5:00 P p.m. on a
Friday so with that I'm my job is chair
I'm going to recess $ 12291 to another
day so if you're here specifically for
that bill I will notice it in the
calendar and it will be after the
February break so it will not be next
week okay my apologies to everyone that
showed up today I think we need more
time to um dissect this and I want to
make sure we're being fair to everybody
that came here speak today okay so with
that on 1399 we're going to continue I'm
going to stick with the two-minute time
frame I'm going to call on Alyssa
marglin oh and by the way if you are
here and you cannot show up next time
please send us an email um our emails
are online we'd love to hear your
feedback thank you thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Alysa margal and housing action New
Hampshire um we were uh supporters of
the for Flex bill um that had been
introduced by um former representative
van and then by representative Mick
Williams and what we learned in that
advocacy is that there were a ton of
questions and the bill before you does
an excellent job of addressing so many
of the stakeholders concerns what we
heard from many members was that it
wasn't concern about allowing for a
duplex on a single family property
rather it was all these other uh
potential issues
in addition I want to note that um this
is also uh consistent with what was um
considered uh how the fourplex bill was
adopted in the state of Maine um housing
action New Hampshire provides
administrative support to the
legislative housing caucus and we
brought um some legislators who led um
the zoning Reform Bill LD 2003 and they
took a similar approach uh to what
representative McWilliams has uh before
you here by only allowing um this uh
Missing middle housing in um Urban
growth areas um we think this bill
really addresses all so many of the
concerns that we heard and we we urge
your support for it and I know you're
short on time so I'll conclude my
testimony thank you very much for your
testimony other questions for miss
marglin seeing none thank you very much
um next I'm going to call on Ben
Frost
thank you Mr chairman and it's not
evening yet good
afternoon not yet committee members I'm
Ben Frost I'm the deputy executive
director and chief legal officer for New
Hampshire Housing and I'm here to
express our support for this
legislation um and um having reviewed
the um Amendment um I think most of the
comments I had on the bill as introduced
also apply to the amendment if not all
of them um and let me preface my
comments by quickly saying um oftentimes
people say they're in support of a bill
and then offer criticism that trashes it
um these uh uh points I'm about to make
are only to improve it and I look
forward to working with the sponsor and
the committee uh to come up with a
really really really good Amendment um
first I'll note uh on referring to the
amendment this is
444h uh line seven on page one uh is the
word
ministerially um I as a lawyer I have a
I'm comfortable with what it means but
uh it does not occur elsewhere in the
Planning and Zoning statutes I did a
quick search this morning and the word
ministerial occurs 14 times in the
entire body of rsas and it mostly refers
to actions dealing with Professional
Licensing uh I would encourage um us
working together to come up with a a
different way of looking at
that um also and I think far more
importantly is the role of the planning
board in all of this uh in there are I
don't know how many references to the
planning board uh in both the bill as
introduced and in the
amendment the planning board does not
have statutory jurisdiction over single
family homes or
duplexes so without actually creating
that
jurisdiction this legislation assumes
the jurisdiction that does not exist I
think it would probably be better to
assign the roles here in this bill to a
building
inspector uh and that really takes it
out of the non
ministerial discretionary sorts of viiew
uh what the building inspector does is a
ministerial function that is does it
meet the code if it does then permit
granted no hearing no special
process
um I I think overall I and I understand
how hard the sponsor and also uh working
with her representative Reed have uh
worked to address things that they have
seen come up in Prior years
hearings um I'm hopeful that we could
come up with something that has less
conditional stuff in it and let fewer
limiting factors and is frankly easier
to say yes we can do this we can convert
this single family home to a a duplex um
I will note uh that um the relationship
between accessory the accessory dwelling
unit law including I think also house B
1291 um is is is pretty easy to dispose
of because the accessory dwelling unit
law is limited exclusively to single
family residences so once you've
converted a single family home to a
duplex the Adu law no longer
applies
um representative Gibbs talked about
history if you could wrap up that' be my
last comment and this is wish um
representative Gibbs talked about
historic districts and that provision
there um I please don't hold this
against against me I grew up in ipswitch
Massachusetts um in a house that was
built in
1707 my mom still lives there um
ipswitch is has probably the highest
concentration of um pre-ol you know
Colonial aromes that were built in the
um the uh 18th
century uh and earlier in fact the house
that was next to the house I grew up in
was a duplex built in
1650 uh there is no reason why duplexes
can't exist in historic districts they
would be subject to the same
architectural controls that any building
would be in such a place thank you thank
you for your
testimony thank you very much um now I'm
going to call on N Grace from the new
Municipal
Association
thank you Mr chair n graes for the
municipal Association um I did submit a
letter online um so in the interest of
time I won't build upon that except to
say that
they uh I agree with the the items that
Mr Frost noted that um ought to be under
consideration by the committee and we do
oppose the bill just to be clear and you
send specific reasons why you in in the
letter wonderful thank
you will
Stewart thank you chair Alexander
members of the committee for the record
my name is Will Stewart I'm the
executive director of stay workpl New
Hampshire which if you're unfamiliar
with it is a Statewide nonprofit whose
mission is to attract and retain more
young people and we are in support of
House Bill 139 9 we're going all around
the state right now talking to young
people as part of our policy and pint
series at eight locations you know as
far north as Coos County and as far
south as nashwa and what we were hearing
at every single event that we're holding
in these past two months is housing
housing housing as being the number one
challenge facing young people here in
the state so we are in full support and
you'll hear from us again representative
Reed on your bill when it's rescheduled
and a few others in front of this
Committee in the coming weeks and months
uh talking about this need for housing
and um you know the the biggest
impediment to attracting and retaining
again the young people the young
Workforce the young volunteers that all
of our employers and communities need so
for these reasons we are in full support
of this bill and look forward to uh to
supporting it as it goes through the
process happy to answer any questions if
there are any thank you very much are
there any questions for will St
represent representative
yella thank you are you specifically in
support of increased options or are you
in in support of all of these limits on
the
uh the qualifications as far as like you
have to jump through this hoop and that
hoop um or you just like we would like
to have more more options in general and
don't you're not saying that we should
remove some of those uh impediments I'm
not you know taking a position on those
uh impediments you know generally
speaking we want to see more options and
make it easier to have more
options follow PA set okay thank you
very
much oh SE this um Tory
Benford
okay what's your name there you are van
Kramer
good afternoon
everyone for the record my name is Ben
Kramer um I live in New Market I'm
organizing director at New Hampshire
youth movement I represent an
organization with a base of over a 100
dedicated members and more than 5,000
supporters ages 15 to 30 across new hire
um I have written testimony for myself
I'm just going to hand that in um Tori
had to get back to work um so I'm going
to read her testimony in herstead
uh this is from Tori my name is Tori
Bamford and I'm a resident of Dober good
housing is hard to find today the price
of a single family home is higher than
ever mortgage rates are as high as they
have ever been in a long time and the
rental market is saturated which drives
up the cost of monthly rents because
those who are who would have previously
been able to buy a house no longer can
the ability to to be creative about land
use policies like the ability to build a
duplex and adus will allow for housing
at a greater density which will allow
rent prices to become more affordable
for a young person like me who's grown
up in New Hampshire affordable housing
means a chance to continue to live and
work here in the state I call home
please support both HB 1399 and HB 1291
um and for the record New Hampshire
youth New Hampshire youth movement also
supports both of these bills um as well
as 1400 all the ones that are before you
to die okay thank you thank
you
Jane Jane
jlin I'm sorry
Lane I asked that if you could keep your
remarks specifically to 1399 that'd be
helpful thank you uh so my name is Lane
um my friend couldn't be here today so
I'm going to be testifying on behalf of
him so his name is Jack um he currently
lives in KY Maine but he's lived in do
for the majority of his life and he also
attended UNH and T and I uh support 1399
and also
1291 so this is Jack's words I graduated
from UNH with a degree in civil
engineering and got a job working with
the USDA I immediately started looking
for a one bedroom or studio apartment in
Dober or nearby but there are no
affordable options and the few in the
few places that I could afford were
sketchy and run down it was fortunate
that I could stay at my mom's during
that incredibly stressful time working
for my new job and trying to find out
trying to figure out housing the
apartment I eventually rented in Dober
cost $1,300 a month which is more than
half my income at the time spending that
much on rent put a lot of pressure on my
budget fortunately I stayed healthy or
medical situation could have pushed me
over the financial Edge now I live in KY
Maine with three friends in a house
owned by my friend's mom she's renting
uh it to us at a below market rate as
much as I appreciate having roommates I
want to eventually live on my own but
the current housing market is too
expensive for that the idea of actually
owning a home feels completely
unattainable for most young people in
New Hampshire right now I urge you to to
support HP 1399 I'd very much like to
move back to New Hampshire and be a
contributing taxpayer in the state that
has always been my home thank you thank
you for your
testimony appreciate it thank
you next I'd like to call on Ivy
van
fourplex Ivy van here to talk to you
thank you for having me uh did you did
you make that nickname or is that no I
have been called fourplex Ivy fan for
quite a while now um fourplex is in fact
a house but that's not what we're here
to talk about today um I don't love this
bill as probably doesn't come in as in
any Supply surprise to you but the piece
of it that I really don't love the two
pieces are the piece that Ben Frost
identified where you're handing over a
whole lot of decisions to the local
planning board I think that's a bad call
it's going to be complicated and it's
really easy to say you know what we
don't understand this so no so I'd like
to see that moved over to the code
officer these are code issues the second
uh concern that I have about this bill
is the ability for a town to restrict
the new unit to affordable housing and
this is not because I hate affordable
housing this is because in the current
construction Market it may not be
possible to create a new unit given the
costs of Labor Lumber all of that and
rent it at the 60% of area median income
which is the be is the bar for what is
Affordable Workforce housing so I I hate
to see that um I will tell a quick
anecdote and then get out of your hair
uh subal Massachusetts I think three
years ago enacted um an ordinance that
said if you have three units one of them
if you create three units or you rehab a
Triple Decker one of the units has to be
permanently affordable and registered at
the registry of deeds and all of that
and in the intervening 3 years exactly
11 units were created but what happened
was Somerville the land of the Triple
Decker became Somerville the land of the
two flat Triple
Decker the triple Deckers got turned
into two because creating that unit and
making it permanently affordable doesn't
pencil so instead of making more unit
and making them permanently affordable
they ended up with fewer units which
still weren't affordable so I'd like to
not I'd like to see us avoid that very
well-meaning
trap so CAU I have
a somewhat support for the bill but I'd
like to see a better version thanks so
much happy to take
questions no one wants to ask I actually
want to ask one so on the second on page
two at the end you're talking about
section g
right you want to say you want to remove
that because you believe that that will
create more if if a municipality chooses
to adopt it it would create it would
restrict housing more than it would
exactly I mean it's incredibly
well-meaning but what we've seen in the
real world and Somerville is not the
only example of this it's just the one
that I know best um we have seen in the
real world when that doing that ends up
restricting housing rather than creating
more housing because it's you know we
know the rulle for every dollar that
you're going to get out and rent you can
spend $100 creating that unit if I can
only rent that unit for $1,200 and it
cost me 24 $240,000 to create it which
is not an unusual number I can't build
that
unit so yeah okay thank you
thanks okay thank you very much thank
you so much always happy to be
here Nathan
zelic
do you mind just turning on the mic for
me thank you this good perfect it's a
little better yeah so um I live in
Manchester I'm a trucker local and I
decided to come up here uh I'm in favor
of this bill to allow
duplexes I've lived in New Hampshire for
about six years I've lived in Rundown
units with I've lived in somewhat nice
units I spent some time living in in
totally illegal Black Market Housing
Development no smoke detectors but it
was actually affordable and sunny and
nice um just a bit of quick math the
median income for working people like me
per capita it's like
50,000 household it's
990,000 the median house price right now
is about half a mil so we're looking at
3600 bucks a month so for a household
making median income it's what like 50%
of monthly gross that's not doable and
for a single individual you got to have
roommates roommates are unstable I've
known a lot of people who've left the
state um I mean people laugh but you
know Virginia and Ohio are quite
affordable in comparison you know
Indiana too and I know working people
like me young
professionals that are just leaving um
I'd like to be able to stay in the state
but increasingly because of the lack of
affordable housing and a duplex you take
a half a Mill House it doesn't scale any
aily you maybe tax on 600 700 to get
that duplex 350 you get it down to much
closer to 30% of uh median household
income it is somewhat affordable for
someone like me so duplexes could be the
reason that I stay in the state you know
um there is Black Market housing that's
rising to meet demand but it's not
Rising fast enough um it'd be really
nice if there's safe legal housing
that's permitted to meet demand you know
um like I I don't want to have to choose
between someplace that's run down or
someplace that's black market but not
rundown or leaving the state and if you
just look at the basic math that duplex
it it does put it barely within reach
you know at least if I get a roommate um
and I'm sure there's a lot of young
people in the state would say the same
thing the vast majority of the working
class human beings in this state that
drive your trucks and take care of your
kids and make this state function can't
really afford to live here and it's only
a matter of time before the housing
turnover and the population increase
means we have to make a decision
duplexes increase the density and
because the cost doesn't scale any early
you get those economies of scale and it
gives us a chance to stay in the state
this is a good Bill maybe you could make
tweaks to it but it's a really really
good bill and it's far better than what
we have now thank you thank you for your
testimony I also have to go serve food
and sling beers later so I completely
understand the work in class life yeah
something okay um any questions all set
okay M Frederick friedricks fried I know
it
now
hello um mix M friedricks from Durham
New Hampshire representing 350 uh New
Hampshire and I just want to clarify to
earlier I misspoke on the manufactured
housing bill that I was here
representing 350 New Hampshire at that
time as well been wearing a couple
different hats today so I got myself
confused um I uh mainly wanted to come
forth um with uh oral testimony for this
um bill today because uh 350 New
Hampshire had raised some concerns about
the bill as originally written and had
reached out to um the primary sponsor
and the co-sponsors about those and I
actually um met with representative Reed
and um worked on some of the the parts
of the amendment um and so um I think
we've already heard a lot of um great
reasons to support this bill from the
public so mainly I'd like to make myself
available for any questions that the
committee may have um particularly
around um you know the the uh suggested
Amendment well thank you for your
testimony and I will say that this
committee will definitely have a work
session on this amendment um as this is
the first time we're seeing it today so
I certainly welcome you back for that as
well to be available are there questions
for
M seeing none thank you very
much Aaron
Kilkenny
good afternoon I have a written um
version of My Testimony if anyone would
like it for accessibility or a um
reference
versions go ahead and pass it we'll pass
it around if you want to hand it to
representative Gibbs thank you
good afternoon distinguished council
members my name is Aaron Kilkenny and
I'm from Durham New Hampshire I come
before you today not as a policy expert
but as a Granite State constituent
invested in my community um I support HB
1399 and hb1 1291 and humbly ask you to
vote Yes on both of these bills I
believe housing is a human right I
believe that um both uh increasing the
um access um for municipalities to um
build duplexes um could seriously um
tackle our housing crisis um that we
face in my town of Durham this could
significantly alleviate the pain and
suffering I see um in my community um
I've dedicated much of my time to this
issue I study town planning and land
economics at the University of New
Hampshire I've spent hours is exporing
over hundreds of pages of Duram Master
plans and meeting minutes from our
housing task force also attending public
and making public comment at our
planning board meetings I'd like to
speak to you all today on a part of the
housing crisis affecting people like me
the most I'm disabled both mentally and
physically and my home is so vital to
living with my disabilities although I
lie on the low end of needs required to
handle my disabilities something some
days things change I could be perfectly
fine or completely shut down because of
noises outside side or muscle pain so
bad I am bedridden I can imagine my
disabled peers needing a place to rest
their bodies and minds but not able to
do so because of the rising rents or
insanely High grocery bills I see stru
such strength within my disability
Community but this strength cannot um
compensate for a roof over your head um
I see all the factors um affecting this
crisis I'm sure you would do as well um
and we can't wave a magic wand but I
believe this is a rare opportunity for
granite Staters to have more freedom on
their properties when uh constructing
duplexes or adus um this New Freedom
could in turn create more housing and um
help those most vulnerable um again I
support both of these um bills um and I
am happy to answer any questions thank
you very much for your testimony are
there questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
and we have your testimon you will also
read it as
well um so the next I have is em Emma
flat flattery
flarity got
it hi uh my name is Emma flarity and I
live in Durham as a student at UNH this
is my second year and I'm currently
living in an off campus apartment in
Durham the housing crisis has impacted
all students in UNH Reg ation for campus
housing happened in October but many
students were left without a guaranteed
place to stay and sought off housing off
campus excuse me they saw housing off
campus housing was largely unavailable
and unaffordable in Durham and
surrounding towns so many students are
worried about displacement for the
coming school year currently New
Hampshire is facing a housing crisis the
creation of more housing will enable
more people to have a safe livable roof
over their heads especially in these
colder months unhoused people face
difficulties and dangers I also support
adus as a solution to this problem these
Solutions can have the potential to
double the amount of available housing
in New Hampshire every human deserves
the warmth and comfort of a home so I
urge you to vote in support of Bill 399
and 1291 to make New Hampshire a safer
state for all thank you and I am open to
any questions thank you any
questions representative
y hi thank you thank you for coming um
as a student in Durham um have
you felt welcome by the community as far
as like
um being being a student because I've
definitely heard of people um in Durham
saying like we don't we don't want more
students either living on campus or off-
campus or something like that um has it
been difficult for you uh you know
integrating into that community and and
specifically around housing um did did
you felt discriminated against because
of of being a a resident at Durham or a
a student at Durham I guess well I
wouldn't necessarily use the word
discriminated against but I do know that
a lot of Durham residents don't consider
students at UNH residents of Durham they
consider us students as like a separate
population um so in terms of
housing um I know that off-campus
housing is Extreme unaffordable um
because there are a
few like organizations like around the
Durham campus that charge like really
high rent rates because of the campus
nearby um and I'm lucky I'm very
privileged because my parents help pay
with my rent um but the reality is that
University Housing is largely the most
affordable option and it's extremely
expensive so I know that finding housing
in the surrounding area is like nearly
impossible okay thank you is that it
okay thank you very much thank you and
we'll have Nicholas Patrick who has
written testimony you can give it to
representative
Gibbs that's okay if you you can email
it as well whatever you prefer to do
thank you
so I'll try to keep this brief as saying
as uh my colleagues were saying that we
do have a really hard time I would say
that we absolutely are discriminated
against and Durham uh I'd like to also
go I should probably start with my
introduction my name is Nicholas Patrick
and I'm from Dublin New Hampshire and
I'm here to support House Bill
1399 uh balancing the housing need uh
with the state's population is a hard
balance with the desire to keep the
state's aesthetic and beauty while
dealing with the population growth uh I
think this duplex law would be perfect
as it D drastically moves along the
vital construction we need it also
centers and is built as it sees uh says
in Clause one paragraph 1 it uh it's
mostly focused on urban areas I think
it's a good idea because we already are
building there and it's not destroying
any of the Aesthetics of New Hampshire
nor the community I also think
urbanizing a lot of our centers would
also allow for easier access to use
social services and also create a better
Community if as long as there built
right uh thank you that's it and I'm
happy to answer anything questions you
might have represent the thank you thank
you for uh coming today
um would you say what what type of
housing uh would be your preference
would you prefer like apartment housing
or single family on two acre lots or um
what or duplexes what what would be your
preference to see more in the state yeah
that's a great question I think it all
depends I think we really have to look
at the Town level and where we're
building uh I think when you get more
more into the rural areas I think more
duplexes and family housing would be
best just because that's where you want
to move a lot of the families in and
raise the kids and make the school
districts better and I think when you go
to more college towns or more urban
areas that we should look a little bit
more into single family housing and
individual housing just so we can move
you know single people as well as people
without families or students into the
smaller apartments or the studio
apartments and then open up the bigger
housings for family that's what I would
think I I have a question for you so
when you say you're discriminated
against how do you mean that's a great
question and so I'd say probably two or
three major things number one uh rent
control or not rent control but the rent
prices specifically in Durham New
Hampshire and although that not is that
just because there's an increased demand
in that region simp not discrimination
right well let me finish um part of it
is the
$2,300 so the rent's really high right
and the question is the you know we
haven't seen an enormous boom in the
University's population so how come the
rent has skyrocketed I mean it has
skyrocketed everywhere but why is it so
much higher there even though the
population hasn't boomed and I think
that's because of the types of housing
we're building the housing that we're
seeing the units that was being built
aren't for you know college students
they aren't smaller they aren't
necessarily studio apartments those
exist in Durham New Hampshire but not
necessarily what we're building and so
they're trying to build a lot of stuff
like that and of course I don't have
specific quotes but if a lot of the Town
Hall minutes you can see kind of the
policies they're trying to enact that
aren't meant to help students and I
think that um we've seen a huge uh
culling on the buildings that we're
trying to make and I think that that
holds a lot of progress towards how much
housing is in the area as well as the
instability of Roommates versus the
stability of a family living in one unit
well I appreciate your comments and if
you if you feel like you're being
discriminated against I urge you to vote
in your um local Town elections y um
because you have a say as well awesome
thank you representative
Gibbs thank you and thank you for coming
in today
uh did I understand correctly that one
of the things you would really like to
see would be more studio apartments um
that would be uh reasonably priced for
students and other um single people yeah
absolutely I mean I'm not 100% sure with
like the vocabulary of housing units but
like studio apartments smaller ones more
for individually like one or two people
like you know two bedroom one bedroom
stuff like that so yeah something like
that recently priced represent every
thank you and thank you for your
testimony are you aware that in your
town of Durham um in addition to a kind
of preference for those more expensive
units Durham also uh prohibits unrelated
individuals from occupying a bedroom
together um which is specifically geared
towards preventing students from from in
a cost-effective way um room
mating yeah uh well I heard about it but
I wasn't aware until now but but that's
really interesting it's definitely
something that me and my organization
will probably look into and work towards
in the
future represent viell thank you uh
thank you for for uh allowing this F
this question um you keep on referencing
your organization and I'm I'm so there
was a uh I'm interested in what is the
organization that you're referring to
and um if you're aware of a bill in min
County government that actually tried to
limit the uh discrimination based on uh
your familial status uh and that Durham
came to testify in opposition to that uh
restriction being lifted um because
maybe you it sounds like you might be
interested in such a bill
and uh Durham's position on that yeah
absolutely I think uh we would
definitely be interested in that type of
bill um specifically the organization
I'm with is the New Hampshire youth
movement I just don't don't announce it
specifically I don't know how the
lobbyist laws work and so I don't want
to say who I'm representing I come and
represent myself but that is an
organization I work with you're
affiliated with yes
okay okay thank you for your testimony
than you Matthew
Stern uh good after afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee uh
my name is Matthew Stern and I am a
student at the University of New
Hampshire in Durham and I'm here today
to express my support for House Bill
1399 as well as House Bill
1291 New Hampshire is currently
experiencing a severe housing crisis
many people are having difficulty
finding places to live for an affordable
price high rent costs and a lack of
options are pricing people out of New
Hampshire new units must be built to
keep up with the safe population House
Bill 1399 will take essential steps and
Lessing the housing burden by allowing
property owners who build a duplex or
maintain an Adu on their property you
are giving them another source of income
while simultaneously creating a new
housing unit as a University of New
Hampshire student I aspired to one day
have the ability to move on from domator
living however the current housing
situation poses a significant obstacle
to achieving this goal houseful 1399
along with houseful 1291 would play a
crucial role in improving the chances
people like myself to find affordable
and suitable living arrangements outside
of the dorms thank you you and please
support house pill 1399 and house 1291
take any questions you may have thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions not seeing any thank you very
much thank you okay the last pink card I
have for this bill is Breen
herrian
welcome uh good afternoon housing
committee my name is is Reen harrian I'm
from Portsmouth New Hampshire and I am
here to support house bille uh 1399 and
1291 and so my story basically is
growing up my parents were living
separately and so I was grateful enough
to have my mother's house as a safe
haven as an escape from my other parent
um if it wasn't for her I would have had
to be making the decision between
staying in an abusive household or
risking being homeless
a lot of people do not have the
privilege and the options that I had in
living in New Hampshire if somebody has
only one or two parents living together
who they do not feel safe in that house
and they don't have another place to go
because the housing is too expensive and
it's not
accessible I was simply one person away
from a really bad situation many people
don't have the privilege and options
that I had and that's why it is so so
important for us to have this affordable
and accessible housing in New Hampshire
so I again ask that you support House
Bill 1399 and House Bill 1291 thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for this witness seeing
none thank
you okay are there any
other U members of the public that like
to testify on HB
1399 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on that and um open up
our last public hearing of the today is
going to be House Bill 1400 and I'll
call on representative MC Williams
welcome
back thank you so much chair Alexander
it's my pleasure to be here for the
record representative Rebecca McWilliams
from South conquered um I'm here to
introduce House Bill 1400 and it is not
yet amended but we should probably talk
because I've been having some good
conversations with the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and there may be
some ways to amend this but let's just
talk about the need for this bill um as
I mentioned in my previous testimony um
I am an architect and I do work in
Housing and Development in New Hampshire
um and parking has become a really
interesting and sort of antiquated
concern uh I say this because uh we look
at at least here where I live in
conquered we look at some of the parking
lots for um for large housing
developments and even off street parking
for small housing uh and there's an
awful lot of asphalt often more asphalt
than it really looks like there needs to
be and that is a direct response to
zoning uh which in some instances
requires um a parking space sometimes
per bedroom although that's not the case
in conquer we have ordinances across the
state that do occasionally say one
parking space per bedroom um or uh in
some of the other instances at least two
parking spaces per unit uh sometimes
more sometimes less uh We've certainly
seen that with the adoption of the adus
uh a couple years back some towns have
chosen to uh require up to four parking
spaces for an Adu in addition to the
parking spaces required for the house
that hosts the Adu and so when you look
at that it becomes a bit prohibitive to
expand our housing stock because we have
to have this paved asphalt on the lot
already because zoning requires it um so
in response uh this bill seeks to limit
the maximum residential parking spaces
allowed per unit to one parking space
per unit and so we're sort of raining it
back in and saying we have too much
asphalt so the average household in New
Hampshire is 1.5 people and I would say
to you that those 1.5 people probably
have a car and if they have a second car
they could choose to pave a second space
in the lot that they own for their
second car but they should not be forced
by the municipality to have two paved
parking spaces if the average is
1.5 uh and so there are obviously
exceptions and this is the whole point
of having a code minimum is that owners
and developers may increase at their own
prerogative but when we start making the
code minimum a number that prevents
additional uh development within a lot
then we're holding ourselves back as a
state and we're preventing housing um
interesting and fun fact is that a
parking space uh dimensionally is 9 ft
by 18 ft so if you have two parking
spaces together next to each other that
is 18 by 36 six that is exactly the size
of a studio apartment and so if you are
requiring four spaces and you only
really need two you could dial it back
and require less than four and put in a
studio Adu or as we discussed in the
previous Bill a uh duplex uh and so I
really think that it's important that we
as a state look at this uh because
obviously zoning is very specific town
by town uh but when we require so much
asphalt that we cannot move forward with
construction additions Renovations
duplexes Etc um I think that we're
standing in our own way um so with that
I'm happy to answer questions and as I
said there may be an amendment on this
because I've been having some good
conversations about very large housing
developments uh but I'd rather start the
discussion where we're at so thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative
Gibbs thank you and again thank thank
you for being here representative MC
Williams and bringing this bill forward
um I am somewhat confused by the
language of the bill uh the bill uses
the term maximum number of parking
spaces whereas you've just been
referring to minimum and what I what I
don't understand is did you mean that
the uh town uh may not require more than
one or may not allow more than one um
thank you very much for the question so
this is a requirement you may not
require as a municipality more than one
parking space per housing
unit oh did you mean then uh that the
requirement is a minimum number not a
maximum
number so I think we could massage the
language if you have concerns between
the use of the word minimum and maximum
but the intent is no more than than one
space per unit and however you want to
phrase that to be super clear the the
words I used were code minimum as in we
set the baselines the the the threshold
is what we set as the code for the state
is the very minimum that you can do as a
developer so if you're coming in and
you're building a you know six-unit
complex the code will require six
parking spaces let me let me try and
clarify my question a little bit
um okay I'm the planning board you're
the developer and you want to build a
4unit building okay so am I allowed to
say to you under this bill I'm only
allowed to say to you that you have to
have at least one parking space per unit
or that you have to have no more than
one parking space per unit thank you for
the clarification no more than one
parking space per unit be required by
the planning board I'm sorry I'm I'm
still confused
okay suppose you want to so suppose
you're the developer and you want to put
two parking spaces am I the planning
board now have to say to you no you
can't put two parking spaces per unit
you can only put
one uh no thank you for the question I
want to be very clear the planning board
is
setting you must at least provide four
because you have four units and
therefore four parking spaces anything
you do beyond that is on you it's your
decision you could provide eight if you
wanted to but we need to require four as
the planning board and the developer
will go back and say well you know I may
actually think that I want some guest
parking and I want to I want to put a
little bit more in than what you require
but they're not mandated to do
additional parking beyond the four that
are required one per unit for the four
you require more than that but you can't
allow more than that yes thank
you representative Damon thank you does
it specify somewhere in statute and
thank you for taking my question that
the parking spaces need to be paved the
asphalt I was not aware of that it does
not thank you for the question um and
the example I was using is from uh my
district in conquered which is very much
an urban District but there is no
requirement for paving at all and as an
architect I would not encourage Paving I
would say porest pavers is the way to go
we have all kinds of runoff issues in
this state and we want to preserve our
green um areas so thank you for the
question
appreciate representative Reed thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question and and not to go back but I
suspect the confusion that was mentioned
earlier is a result as is been the case
very frequently of an OS Cur per fuffle
would you agree that the wording of line
five shall should
to reach your intent the town shall not
set the minimum residential parking
spaces per unit to greater than one
parking space for residential
unit not maximum
um I don't think I want to go there with
the word minimum or maximum at this
point I think both of those seem to be
absolute I think instead um I I would
say that uh the goal here is one
residential parking space per unit that
the town cannot require more than one so
yes I we could say that but minimum and
maximum are becoming dangerous so
perhaps municipality may not require
more than one residential parking space
per
unit I'm going to leave it up to some
other smart people to come up with the
language and hopefully refer an
amendment back to this committee that'
be
helpful any other
questions okay thank you very much thank
you Greg
Moore
thank you again Mr chairman members of
the committee I know how great it is to
be standing between you and a long
weekend so I'll be mercifully brief um
we support uh by the way Greg Moore Reon
director for American for Prosperity we
support this legislation we believe it's
a it's an important protection once
again on individuals property rights but
I would say that I would say that
legislation like this sort of sort of
demonstrates the the whack of mole
nature of some of these regulations that
that that are popping up and uh at a
higher level I think it's important for
the work of this committee to continue
going forward so we can either address
each of these whacka problems or
secondarily uh just sort of
reconsider what what Authority the state
grants to municipalities for Z zoning
and planning so I think that that's yes
we support this but at a higher level I
think think that this is a perfect
example of of of the type of work that
needs to be done regularly by the
legislature to update these types of
statutes and just basically reconsider
the over overall relationship as we are
not a home rule state uh the state
decides what authorities it grants to
municipalities in these in these
examples and and um every two years you
can find more of these probably a dozen
more of these and so I just hope you you
guys uh keep it up and uh continue down
this path I think it's important thank
you for your testimony any questions
thank you very much Sarah
Holland New Hampshire Realtors are they
here they probably sent this earlier
Nick
Taylor thank you Mr chairman and members
of the thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Nick Taylor the
executive director of the workforce
Housing Coalition of the greater Sea
Coast also want to thank you for this
long day and for all your work over the
last year tackling this important issue
we're here in support of this bill
parking mandates are major housing
issues as you know excessive parking
mandates increase cost limit housing
Supply parking is expensive it can cost
thousands of dollars if not tens of
thousands of dollars per spot and those
costs get passed right down to renters
and to potential buyers um when we talk
about affordability of potential housing
and developers even with this bill can
choose to provide more Park if they
believe it's necessary but that should
be their call they know their tenants
they know the intensity of the use um
and parking mandates are particularly
impactful for developers of Workforce
housing and affordable housing as their
tenants often either don't have a car or
have one car that they share so anything
that starts to you know increase that
that mandate there hits them
particularly hard in a way that they do
not have the bandwidth within their
their cost to make it work so again
we're here and support this bill and
thank you you for today's
hearing thank you very
much appreciate it thank
you n
gra thank you Mr chair the last time you
have to see me today n gra for the
municipal Association um we do oppose
this
legislation um but I've handed out um
both a copy of the letter that I
submitted uh digitally as well as a copy
of Section 8 of SP
538 um that is also pertaining to
parking minimums but in a different
manner that is something that if you
were to enact as a replace all Amendment
we would be okay with um the the
difference there is that it would still
allow local control and then it would
allow some uh setting of parking
minimums but it would require the
planning board consider any
alternative um alternative parking
solution proposed by the applicant um so
basically any applicant that was coming
forward that had was going to build on
you know a street that had adequate
street parking or something like that
they could say look we don't need to
meet the minimum parking requirements
because you can park on the street and
um that would have to be considered by
the planning board um the other thing
that I want to point out is that parking
policy is very complex um you know I'm
certainly happy to work with anyone on
on further amendments um and I just want
to point out that based on car
registrations and population Granite
Staters own about one car per person um
obviously when we're talking about
trying to calculate what is the
appropriate parking for um for people
that's very complex um typically it's a
it's a more difficult problem in multif
family units than it is single family
homes um and ultimately at the end of
the day most people except those working
at third shift have to park their cars
um where they live um so we have to make
sure that they have adequate parking
throughout the state in the correct Loc
so that's why we are able to support um
the language in Senate Bill 538 but we
can't support the minimum that's
proposed in this legislation happy to
take any questions the Comm may have
okay thank you for your testimony
representative Reed thank you for taking
my question uh you said that Granite
Staters on average own one vehicle per
person but I presume you mean per adult
is that accurate yes thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
okay next up Ivy
van welcome
back we got a special committee this
time I know so exciting uh I am in fact
iy van from Peter bro New Hampshire and
I am here to speak in favor of this bill
and the reason that I am speaking in
favor of it I you know because I always
think things should be way more radical
than they are I think we should do away
with parking requirements alog together
and I'll tell you why uh planners and I
am one really we're terrible at figuring
out how much parking anything needs we
have tables that say things like for
every 1273 gallons of water in your
Municipal swimming pool you require two
parking places and I did not make that
up that's an actual Institute of Traffic
Engineers statistic but the Institute of
Traffic Engineers five years ago said
the thing that we all knew was true
which is they made up those numbers they
don't know we don't know we should stop
pretending we do so that's one reason
why I'm at least in favor of reducing it
to one the other is financial
logistical it costs I just checked these
numbers to build one off street parking
place with correct substrate paved and
of course if you live in Coos County or
you know out in the country you don't
need to PVE it but if we're talking
about a parking place in town we're
talking about
$6,500 to build one parking place so if
I have to build two for my fourplex for
every unit in my
fourplex um eight I have to charge each
one of those units for those parking
places and using back of the de of the
envelope developer math that's $130 a
month in rent for having created those
parking places which maybe we don't even
need and here's the other part of my
reason for supporting this almost 30% of
all households in the United States are
one person households one one one um the
work that I've been doing with all the
little towns all over New Hampshire this
year I have yet to work in a town where
the average household size is more than
2.1 which means that in a lot of those
towns more than
40% of the households are one person
they don't need two parking places
parking places cost money they um
contribute to Rainwater runoff storm
water runoff and if you're building in a
place where the planning board has rules
about um per impervious coverage and
storm water management having to produce
all those parking places May kick me
over into having to create some kind of
complicated and sophisticated and by the
way that's code for
expensive storm water management system
involving vaults and tubes and God only
knows
what parking requirements make things
more
expensive they make storm water issues
worse they encourage people to
drive and they're
unnecessary so given all of that well I
wish you would say that towns can't
require parking minimums at all this is
a step in the right direction and by the
way um in speaking of not requiring
parking minimums at all in New Hampshire
I think there are
I think there are 11 jurisdictions that
have done just that and Nationwide there
are hundreds if you go and look for
parking reform Network you can see a big
map of the United States that shows you
all the places where they have
eliminated parking requirements
including Buffalo New York 10 years ago
pretty sure the world didn't come to an
end and I'm happy to take
questions thank you for your t
representative
yella thank you thank you for uh your
testimony
um in one of my municipalities they're
doing a an invest New Hampshire kind of
review of their zoning yeah that's the
work that I've been doing for a lot of
places but go ahead that's one of the
reasons why I'm asking sorry so so um
one of the things that they in one of
their presentations they mentioned that
they looked back
uh I think 20 or something years um and
they kind of made the makeup of the
municipality as far as how many people
were living in each um residence and
then they compared that to now and a lot
and people have been shifting away from
having a multiple people in in houses to
one person per houses have you
um have you seen that Trend across
multiple municipalities and not just the
one I happen to attend I have seen that
Trend across the United States thank you
part of the thing that's driving our
housing crisis is the fewer numbers of
persons living in each household if you
go from having four people in a
household or having two people in a
household you have to have twice as many
houses and we're seeing
that oh thank you um and do you do you
think that
that spreading out of instead of having
four people to a household only having
one person to a household um is a
significant impact on the housing demand
even though there's not necessarily
more people even in my municipality I
think they they went up by like three
people or something in the last 20 years
but we needed a lot more housing for
that same number of people absolutely
absolutely we we are seeing that
everywhere and it's particularly true um
as New Hampshire ages um you have more
single single person households but they
are still living in the big house
because they can't move to a smaller
house because there is no smaller house
so it's part of the problem in so many
ways sorry thank you very much okay
great Bryce C
Kao thank you for the uh pronunciation
key there
there all right good afternoon chair
Alexander and honorable committee
members uh the testimony that I've
passed out has testimony 4 hb400 as well
as 1291 I'll just speak to 1400 today um
but thank you for being here here today
it's been a long one um and so for the
record my name is Bryce cwo and for the
past four years I've been Ser serving on
the Manchester planning board the past
two I've been serving as the chair um I
am here to provide testimony on hb400 in
my own personal capacity though not on
behalf of the board so without other way
I strongly support
hb400 and I urge you all to support it
as well the reason why is because as you
all know parking minimums are the
required number of off street parking
spaces that a business or Residential
Building must provide as specified in a
municipal zoning code um and while
well-meaning
they have an undeniably detrimental
effect on housing Supply and
affordability other people have talked
to this already um developers are
already incentivized to provide enough H
uh parking to meet Market demands
whether they're building housing or
businesses because if they don't have
enough
parking people who they want to sell
things to or people who they want to
rent to aren't going to want to go there
now despite that all across New
Hampshire including in Manchester cities
and towns are forcing developers to
build unwanted extra parking spaces if
this parking was free and could go under
ground at no cost then that would be
fine
but we are Paving over Paradise at a
terrible cost iivan mentioned it um as
well each unnecessary parking space can
take thousands if not tens of thousands
of dollars to create depending on
whether it is just Standalone or on in a
structure like a parking garage or
underground um and each dollar that is
spent on unnecessary parking is a dollar
that is going to be recouped in the form
of rent or in the form of sales prices
so the bill before you um is pretty
simple straightforward and targeted I
agree that the language could be refined
so that it is a bit clearer um but that
being said the question in front of this
committee and in front of the state
legislator is should the state of New
Hampshire allow cities and towns
to have the authority to mandate more
than one parking space per housing unit
and I think not because we are in a
housing crisis we should act accordingly
we should be trying to remove barriers
to housing as we encounter them um and
cities across the country are reducing
or eliminating these minimums and I
think New Hampshire should be next um
this is just bringing it down to one
space being required but um in the end
providing storage space for cars should
never take priority in my opinion over
providing housing for people and so in
an effort to improve housing Supply and
affordability across the entire State I
respectfully encourage this committee to
support uh
hp400 um I do have one more thing real
quick uh just in case we don't get to it
in a question but some people might
wonder why should the state get involved
here this is pretty much a local thing
people might want local control and my
simplest and most honest answer here is
if we could actually rely on
municipalities to do this on their own
and to fix this on their own they would
have already we wouldn't be talking here
today about this issue um same goes for
many of the other housing bills but
State action is being sought because
town and City governments have not met
this moment so with that thank you for
your time be happy to answer any
questions but I know it's been a long
day thank you for your
testimony appreciate it thank you thank
you Roy schwier
schwier I'm Mr Bill Roy schwager from
conquer thank you Mr chairman and
members of the
committee what I haven't heard yet is
there seems to be an idea that we should
uh have less dependence on cars and more
on walking and public transportation and
so forth and if that's the case this
bill goes exactly the wrong way I
remember when conquer didn't allow
overnight parking on streets and that
meant they didn't plow the snow up on
the sidewalks so people would shovel the
sidewalks you could actually walk on
sidewalks
and I remember when uh you know people
would actually do that but now because
they're trying to you know provide
parking the sidewalks R full of snow no
one wants to shovel snow from the whole
street off the sidewalk so now the
people have to walk in the street and if
you really want to encourage you know
alternative uses you need to make the
developers provide the parking in their
own Lots so the city can take back their
streets and their side walks for people
to actually
use
and I I live in North conquer which is
different from represen MC Williams
apparently I have issues and I'll email
you folks a photo that people are
parking overnight on the sidewalk
because they don't have enough parking
in the photo I'm going to show you there
are two duplexes Each of which has five
parking spaces and each of them still
has a vehicle parked on the street
because people own more cars than you
think we have a lot of work housing well
in my neighborhood Workforce housing
means somebody may be a plumber and
electrician so in addition to their own
car they've got this monster van with
stuff they've got to find someplace to
park so there's yet one more thing that
parked on the street it's even too big
for a parking space but you know they
park it on the street and they try and
cure that problem downtown by having a
parking garage but people won't pay to
park in the garage unless they subsidize
it so we're making everyone's housing in
the city more expensive by requiring
people to to uh you know subsidize the
parking for the developers that don't
provide it so I think we need to have a
situation where the developer is
required to provide a reasonable amount
of parking that's is probably based not
on the number of units but perhaps on
the number of
bedrooms I can explain that there's this
one duplex I know of it had three
bedrooms on each side originally one
person lived on one side and rented out
one room and the other side had two
adults and two kids so they had four
cars already that's as many as the lot
can hold well guess what when the taxes
went up the person decided to run out
both bedrooms so there's now three cars
on that side plus the teenager it's not
just adults that have cars the teenager
got a car on the other side so now we
have six cars in this duplex and you're
saying oh one's enough well I think
that's not right I think we should allow
the communities to determine how many
parking spaces we need if it's downtown
you have parking garages that may be
zero but it's further out it may mean
one per bedroom or something like that
once again represent M Williams talks
about a quarter acre lot I've got an
eighth of an acre and some of my
neighbors have a 16th of an acre you
know why are we trying to cram more
people onto those there's better places
to put them so I'm going to call this
bill your choice of the developers uh
Delight or the slum Lord's Delight Andor
hate your neighbor bill because you're
going to park on the street all the time
and take up the space thank
you thank you for your time
testimony thank
you Ben
Kramer hello
again Ben Kramer I live in New Market
organizing director at New Hampshire
youth movement um still here to
represent young people and my
organization um I have two copies of of
my full testimony I'll give you the
Abridged version um we support this bill
I think because it directly
addresses the link between the cost of
building parking and the cost of housing
like so many others have said that cost
is passed on to occupants and especially
to renters and we have a major rent
problem in this state
um yeah we should do away with parking
minimums to let the people who know the
projects best decide how much parking is
truly needed
and cut the red tape between us and
building the housing we need to solve
the
shortage we support this bill I'll leave
it at that um I also want to say like I
genuinely appreciate the work that this
committee has done and like taking this
long day we have a major housing crisis
in the states and we need solutions that
rise to the scale of Crisis and I
appreciate all the hard work that has
gone into this and the good faith
collaboration that has gone into this
and the bills being heard today are an
excellent starting place and a
foundation that we need to build on to
actually continue to rise to the scale
of the crisis um and and address what we
really need in the state so thank you
thank
you Matt
minan I'm
sorry almost got there I'm used I feel
like I can't read it's been so late yeah
well thank you uh chairman Alexander
members of the special committee it's
been a long day um I did submit my
remarks online and email them to you so
I'll keep it short um my name is Matt
I live in Claremont and I am the
advocacy and engagement director with
603 forward a nonprofit uh Statewide
organization dedicated to uh empowering
educating and activating young people in
our state today I'm here to testify in
support of House Bill
1400 um you know parking requirements
play an important role in how many homes
are able to be developed in several ways
um the added cost of parking to
development whether there's enough land
to support the required parking and the
overall impact on affordability are just
a couple
um parking requirements are most often
minimums that are set either per
apartment or per bedroom meaning that
for a development to be built there must
be a certain number of parking spaces
and uh these rules do not allow for
assessing the needs of future residents
in the building but instead apply a one
siiz fits all rule regardless of whether
or not for example the unit is on a bus
line is going to be a home to seniors or
is for working people with cars um also
as you heard parking is incredibly
expensive so developers often have to
charge a higher price in order to cover
the cost of building that is required of
them um these reasons are and more that
you've heard today um but mostly the
concerns on affordability on tenants are
some reasons why uh we encourage you to
uh support this bill and consider uh
reconsider parking requirements in New
Hampshire and um thank you so much for
your time and this long day and I'll see
you at some hearings in the future after
February break I guess wonderful thank
you for your testimony representative
Vella has a question for you if that's
okay
yeah certainly thank you thank you for
for coming um do have you uh found that
um the young people that you deal with
are taking advantage of more options as
far as like electric bikes and maybe one
wheels and stuff like that that may be
able to transport them a farther
distance without actually the
maintenance cost and the size
requirements of that uh a false parking
space and may um you know a Avail
themselves of that type of uh technology
in recent years so that the reduced need
for these parking spaces is um is occurs
in in that population yeah certainly I
think you know a a desire of a lot of
young folks is to live in like a
walkable downtown where you can get
there really easily but even just
speaking from my personal experience I
have a bike I live you know not the
closest to downtown but I think it's a
great way to get um I often take my bike
downtown I have to ride some errands I
have a lot of friends who have like you
said ebikes or scooters those like weird
onewheel things I think certainly it's a
desire of young folks to not have to
rely on a traditional vehicle for
transportation and um be able to get do
things other
ways yeah thank you for your testimony
thank you have a good day you as well
Nicholas
Patrick is he still
here okay Jane
hey uh good afternoon thank you for
taking my testimony um it's been a long
day appreciate your patience um I live
in Manchester uh Ward one and I work
with a group called Manchester housing
Alliance welcome back yeah thank you and
we uh attempt to make uh incentives for
people to build more affordable housing
and I think that I would agree with Ivy
van who says we should just get rid of
parking minimums altogether and not
allow municipalities to create parking
minimums and I think it's up to
developers because as um Bryce said uh
you know developers have an incentive to
create a project that people are going
to want to rent and if they think they
can rent it with four parking spaces or
eight parking spaces I mean so much for
that um but when we require them to
create parking spaces I don't know if
you've ever been to one of Ivy Vans uh
little workshops on zoning but if you
require parking spaces and there's a
maximum amount of lot coverage then
you're making uh requiring the building
that they build to be particularly small
or smaller than it would be so you're
actually
eliminating um you know maybe three or
four housing units just for the sake of
having extra parking for everybody
and um we've seen developers in uh
Manchester be creative about this and
maybe buy a cheaper lot you know down
the street or something for their
tenants to park if they think that's
going to be an incentive there's also
the opportunity for tenants in a
particular building to rent a parking
space if they need one but when we
require the developer to have say eight
parking spaces then everybody in the
building is basically paying that extra
rent whether they happen to need a
parking space or not and um so I think
it reduces the number of units that
we're able to build and um and you know
in addition to all the other things that
iy van and Bryce said about lot coverage
and impermeable surfaces and cost of
parking lots etc etc etc so I'll just
end it there unless anybody has any
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you
thank you Jeremy
Olsen I have one more pink card so if
anybody else wishes to testify please
pass it up thank
you good afternoon members of the
committee I hadn't planned on testifying
on this bill but I heard some stuff I
just wanted to um web basically I look
at this I'm absolutely in support of
this bill and I look at this as it's
both about property rights for the owner
and the developer of the property and I
also see this as this because this is
basically a bipartisan bill because like
conservatives and Libertarians should
support this as a basic private property
rights thing and Progressive support it
because it's helping us move away from
like such a car-based society if people
living in areas where you have people
parking cars illegally on the sidewalk
parking cars where they're not supposed
to be on the road that shouldn't be a
problem for the city to then impose
something on the property owner to do
something about it people are parking on
the sidewalk ticket the car tell the car
don't tell the property owner they have
to build a parking spot for that
secondly I own a rental property I tell
my tenants that they can or cannot have
cars if I did not have a parking lot on
my property I'd tell them they can't
have a car on the property they're not
going to be able to park it on the
sidewalk or something in front of it so
um again I'm I'm entirely in support of
this bill it's a private property rights
thing and I think it's a good bill to
get rid of the parking minimums that
they currently have in many cities be
Happ to take any questions thank you for
your testimony I think we're all set
thank
you Ben
Frost for the last time
today
hopefully say so Mr
chairman good afternoon thank you Mr
chairman uh Ben Frost deputy director
and chief legal officer at new hampter
housing uh we are in support of this
legislation and just by note of
reference New Hampshire housing among
variety of things that we do we Finance
the construction and long-term asset
management of affordable rental housing
uh when I look at the plans that are
submitted To Us by developers I
acknowledge that generally speaking
about half of the developed area is
parking uh and that is often times un
well not not unused but it is uh
inefficiently used that is there's a lot
more parking than is actually needed
by the developments that we
finance that yields uh additional costs
and reduced opportunities for housing
because where there is required to be
parking we could instead have more
buildings housing more people creating
more units um in in her testimony Ivy
van talked about a a cost per per uh
space uh there's been a lot of numbers
around this all over the country does
depend upon the cost of land wherever
you have happen to be I've seen numbers
in excess of $440,000 per parking space
um which is just added to the cost of
development uh and this gets to a notion
among planners that's known as the high
cost of free parking somebody's paying
for it it may be free to the person
who's parking the vehicle there as is in
the developments that we Finance but the
developer paying for that which means
we're paying for it because we're
financing the development of those those
properties
um I'll close with an object example of
uh the Ridiculousness of some parking
standards I live in the Town of Warner
where I Serv as the planning board chair
for uh seven years I was on the board
for 12
years if I had stayed longer I would
have change would have tried to change
something uh and that is the parking
standards and I would have uh
recommended eliminating the parking
standards alt together and leave it to
the private Market to Fig f it out uh
this this bill Deals Only with
residential uh uses uh that is true but
the the example from Warner is probably
the best parcel of land in the center of
the
village is a Surface parking lot because
the planning board required
it for the uh commercial use across the
street this is property that should be
developed and it's just a parking
lot literally one foot away from on
street
parking it is totally
unnecessary as is so many of the
regulations we face so happy to take any
questions represent
yell thank you um since you do this
financing um have you been able to uh in
different municipalities or or uh in the
different projects that you've you've uh
financed have you been able to
quantify um the cost in New Hampshire to
uh this increased requirement for for uh
parking thank you for the question uh
and no we have not done it we are we
could do it if we if we chose to and I
think it's a it's an interesting
research question that I'd be interested
in
pursuing I have a question um how would
this Bill affect mixed
use um development or areas I know it
says just residential but I think about
you know in the perfect world when you
in a world when you have a Whole Foods
on the first floor and then a bunch of
like like how would this Bill affect
that directly when it's zoned for mixed
use or is mixed use development Mr
chairman that is a terrific question and
I think it uh the the way this bill
would work is it applies only to
residential that are zon solely for
residential purposes it it says it says
residential parking spaces per unit
forget about the zoning is it's it's the
use that we're talking about so um let's
say you're dealing with a mixed use
development this is a great opportunity
for what's known as shared parking so
daytime commercial use evening time
residential use
okay thank you thank you the last
speaker is John
Kipper welcome thank you chairman thank
you my name is John Kyper I'm from New
Market and uh I'm here because I own a
little restaurant in New Market and I
have uh five or six employees most of
them walk to work half of them do not
own cars uh and there some proposed
development of Workforce housing in our
town and a lot of the push back about
that Workforce housing is based around
the parking requirements and whether or
not there's enough space for the 60
spots required for the 30 units that are
proposed um and I just I think that uh
this bill would help alleviate that
issue which um I think parking becomes
one of those things that people bring up
when they just really don't want any
more development in their town and if
that's the issue then we should talk
about that issue but you know I I hate
it when people bring up parking what
they really mean is that they don't want
any more buildings built anywhere in New
Hampshire thank you I'm having to take
questions thank you for your testimony
are there any questions representative
Damon thank you for bringing up the
elephant in the
room represent
mononi thank you Mr chairman thank you
for waiting all the way through for that
um could you just elaborate you you're a
business owner uh how many parking
spaces have they required you to have
for your business and it sounds like
you're in a walking area yeah we um the
downtown area of our town does not
basically waves the parking requirements
um that said uh I rent parking I
actually rent from a Chinese restaurant
next door and from another you know guy
around the corner um our downtown area
has a lot of apartments that have no
parking
and people just you know they figure it
out if you know and I lived downtown
before I opened my restaurant and me and
my girlfriend just got one car and
honestly it was way cheaper you know and
I look at my parents they um they're
retired they have two cars and there's
almost never a time when both of my
parents are leaving the house at the
same time and if they moved into an
apartment with just one unit you know
one parking unit they would be fine with
just one car and I think people just
learn to adapt thank you
sir any other question representative
Reed I was waiting I apologize Mr chair
this isn't really pertinent but thank
you illustrious constituent for showing
up and I uh would you believe that the
food served at your restaurant is quite
delicious and I would highly recommend
anyone visit Johnny Boston New Market
thank you thank you very much thank you
for your testimony okay so with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on
hp400 before we all run out of here as
committee I guess I want your feedback
on the bills we've heard today so
obviously we will be coming back to here
on hb1 1291 but I want to know where
everyone is at on the other bills if
you're comfortable going to an executive
session if we need a work session kind
of give me some feedback representative
gives my feeling is that we or at least
I need a little more time to think and
go over some of the written
documentation that's been given to us
and I know that there's at least one
bill that I'm going to work on what
should be a pretty simple um Amendment
recommendation but I I do think that
we're going to need a general work
session um there are a couple of bills
where we've said specifically we need a
work session and then we can leave it
open in case there's anything else so I
don't think we're ready to go into
executive session until we've had at
least one work session and I I'm not
ready to provide feedback uh at this
time I don't know I mean I I generally
support a lot of the bills that have
been presented but beyond that uh I
don't think I'm ready to provide
feedback I don't know if others are okay
so you're saying a day maybe the public
Hearing in a work session following the
other public hearing we have okay makes
sense representative Reed thank you Mr
Chair by my count um I believe every
single one of the bills we heard we
mentioned an amendment um with the
possible exception of the very first one
which I did have a proposed amendment in
mind for that which was merely adding
this committee should it continue to
exist in the following term to the list
of entities that that that study
committee would report to I would
support that Amendment but um if people
wanted to execute positively right now I
would uh go along with that other than
that um I think every single one we went
through we talked we asked people
testifying for Amendment language
um I did step out for a bit but I have
Amendment notes on every single one okay
represent makoni thank you Mr chairman I
would suggest that you schedule your
public hearing early in the morning
again work session to follow EXA those
that can be EXA and then set up your
second date for executive session I'm
willing to go full day and Hammer out I
I think we can hammer out more than half
of thank you represent birdie yeah we
need we need U full days on these but um
hearing the public input in the morning
and maybe uh
workshop and executive session in the
afternoon
okay represented Wallace yes I uh Echo
representative Gibb sentiments um I
believe that uh at this point in time
I'm a I'm airm uh in support of every
one of the bills we've heard with some
minor adjustments nothing substantive
okay but again a uh you know 9 or 10
o'clock in the morning public hearing on
the remaining bill after that work
session exective in the afternoon
representa d
mostly agreed with what has been said um
wondering and I'm not sure if this is
protocol if we can do some work on
drafting amendments to bring to that
work session I'm thinking and I'm sure
other folks have seen this in other
committee work OLS is not rolling things
out real fast so if we're we might want
to be preemptive will get out yeah
though if you if you set a deadline on
them and let them know um I will say
like as long as it's less than a four
of the committee so if you want to form
your own group and chat real quick about
a bill create amendment that works um
represent
Kell um thank you um my thoughts are on
the the um committee Bill the uh study
committee the first bill of the day I
think that um I would not be in support
of creating another committee I think
that I think that a subcommittee of this
committee
would be fine and I think that uh such a
committee should um
have uh hearings in throughout the state
or whatever and and just do the work I
don't think that um creating another one
is going to be necessary just to get
more State reps involved
um I think that the I would like to see
um essentially like work
sessions
um of of significant length probably
um the opportunity to do probably
one for maybe only one a day or
something like that for uh or or it
could be just com like combine them all
into one work session the problem is I
think that we would have people showing
up for something that we might not even
get to that day um and so I uh either
like a subcommittee for each of the
bills um except for the parking one I
don't think that one requires ve very
much much time but um I think that uh
the only one I'm really concerned of
that has uh requires I think a lot of
work is the two the the um two
uh duplex unit duplex one because I've
that one is just has a lot of
requirements and stuff like that so um
that's my my thoughts on the subject so
thank you take them for what they're
worth um representative Reed thank you I
actually agree with representative mcc's
assessment that
um and I'm presuming is is March 8th the
correct the Friday of the week after the
vacation okay um 1291 and first thing in
the morning followed by a full day full
committee exe or so not exe work session
on all the bills that were heard today
and that nobody would be showing up
because the only hearing is 1291 so
people are showing up for 1291 people
don't necessarily need to show up for
the work session because they're not
automatically given the right to speak
but going back to the study committee
bill I think it was we showed our
ignorance on issues of disability in
this committee today because and I know
I personally was in tears um there are
members of the House who uh belong to a
disability caucus who would be much more
Well Suited this is something that needs
repeated meetings much like we had much
like as the chair had scheduled repeated
presentations from different groups uh
all last year for us this is something
that's going to have to meet repe
repeatedly disability issues are complex
we went down the rabbit hole on one tiny
tiny tiny piece of it so I think this
committee should wholeheartedly
completely support the study
committee okay representative
Gibbs thank you uh I just heard a re
reference to uh our next meeting
possibly being on March 8th and
unfortunately I need I checked my
calendar and I need to point out that I
have a County delegation meeting uh
maram County delegation meeting on March
8th um wouldn't that be in the evening
no it's in the morning what time uh so
in the morning of March 8th um what time
sorry what time 10 o'clock okay and it
probably go till about noon
okay okay any other feedback okay yes oh
represent wall uh going back to the uh
the disability study committee bill one
thing we have to be aware of this is an
election year and that bill sets the
reporting deadline for November of this
year so just keep that in mind folks
well I I would be happy amending the
reporting deadline as well as like I
said I think that this committee is
suitable to be reported to by that study
committee okay all right so um standby
on a on a date following up on the next
public hearing I think I might still do
it on March 8th at least the public
hearing but um we'll have the work
session following that in the afternoon
if the work session was at 1 she'd be
able to get it I think y y okay well
thank you very much it's been a long day
I appreciate everybody slugging along
with us thank
you